Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Hier ist die Freakshow. Hallo. Wir schreiben den 13.
Juni. 13. Juni 2025. Es ist die 293. Freakshow.
Freitag der 13.
Nein, wir haben immer noch keine Antwort darauf, was wir mit der 300 machen. Freitag der 13. Oh.
Oh. Oh. What could possibly go wrong.
Also, das ist eine gute Frage. Mal schauen, unter welchem Vorzeichen diese Sendung steht.
Wie auch immer, hallo, ich bin's,
Tim, Tim Britlaff, ich begrüße Roddy mir gegenüber. Ja, hallo. Roddy.
Und Ralf, zu meiner Linken.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Und direkt aus dem Cyberspace, meiner Rechten, Luca. Hallo, Luca.
Hallo.
Moin. Du bist remote dazu geschaltet, macht natürlich für die Hörer keinen Unterschied,
weil wir hier technische Brillanz am Start haben. Und man merkt es einfach gar nicht. Oder?
Ja, ja.
Läuft perfekt.
Läuft perfekt, genau. So ist es nämlich gedacht.
Und trink kein Bier.
Genau.
Zumindest nicht unseres.
So Luca, du warst ja schon ein paar Mal bei uns. Jetzt habe ich nicht geguckt,
wie oft. Aber mehr als zweimal. Ne, mehr als einmal.
Das ist jetzt glaube ich das dritte Mal, dass ich dabei bin.
Genau. So habe ich das auch in Erinnerung. Ja, herzlich welcome back.
Wir sind ja gerade wieder viel am machen und am tun und wir waren auch gemeinsam unterwegs.
Ich hatte ja hier von der von den Elixierkonferenzen besucht.
Elixierkonferenz, es macht nur richtig Spaß, wenn auch Luca dabei ist.
Von daher hatten wir da schon das Vergnügen und ich denke, wir hatten da eine Menge Spaß, oder?
Auf jeden Fall. Also wir müssen noch mal gucken, wie viele Elixierkonferenzen
wir dieses Jahr noch besuchen können. Das ist ja noch das halbe Jahr da.
Einer haben wir noch auf der Liste. Ich weiß nicht, ob danach überhaupt noch irgendwas ist.
Die Codebeam ist ja auch noch in Berlin wieder, oder?
Ist sie?
Ich glaube, ja.
Okay. Codebeam Europe in Berlin, sagst du?
Back to Berlin. Oh, 4. November. 5. November, 5.6. Alles klar.
Okay, dann kriegen wir ja unsere 1, 2, 3, 4.
4 Konferenzen kriegen wir voll. Das reicht dann auch erstmal,
glaube ich. Ja, wenn man nicht genug kriegen kann. Anyway, ähm...
Heute haben wir ganz schön viel auf der Liste. Mal gucken, wie wir das runtergebrochen bekommen.
Wir werden natürlich über die WWDC reden müssen.
Mit anderen Worten, was Apple mal wieder alles kundgetan hat und versprochen
hat und angekündigt hat.
Und dann, keine Ahnung, vielleicht rufen wir nochmal Max an und fragen,
was davon alles illusorisch ist.
Aber dazu dann vielleicht später mehr. Ja,
Luca war auf Reisen, da wollen wir auf jeden Fall drüber sprechen und dann hatte
ich ja angekündigt, dass wir heute mal das mit dieser Tierlist machen.
Ich kann euch bestätigen, die Begeisterung in dieser Runde hält sich stark in
Grenzen und ich habe damit schon ein bisschen gerechnet, aber das hält mich
natürlich nicht zurück.
Aber nur dem Umstand geschuldet, dass die Sendung jetzt schon einen sehr langen Eindruck macht.
Und wenn ich mir das Thema anschaue, glaube ich nicht, dass wir da unter einer
bis zwei Stunden rausgehen.
Tja, aber du bist ja kerngesund, Ralf, oder?
Ja, so mittel heute. Endlich mal wieder ein bisschen krank in der Sendung.
Kernige Gesundheit am Start.
Aber ich hole mir jetzt erstmal das versprochene Malz hier.
Achso, ja, genau. Bleib sitzen, sabbel weiter.
Du willst auch eins.
Ja, während die Welt brennt an vielen Orten,
gehen wir hier sozusagen weiterhin unserem Optimismus kund und wollen erstmal
mit ein paar Kleinigkeiten einsteigen, bevor wir hier mit den...
den großen Themen anfangen. Vielen Dank.
Hier kommt das Malzbier. Flinsburger Malzbier kann ich wirklich sehr empfehlen.
Habe ich erst vor kurzem entdeckt. Ist gar nicht so doof.
So, das werden wir jetzt mal testen. Erstmal, ob es auch Plöpp macht.
Es ploppt richtig korrekt.
Es ploppt korrekt.
Malzbier ist schon auch irgendwie...
Ich habe es nicht gehört.
Ups, dafür spritzt es auch ein wenig.
Bis nach Hamburg.
Nee, nicht bis nach Hamburg. Ich habe es nicht gehört.
Das Ploppen hast du nicht gehört, ist nicht dein Ernst.
Naja, doch.
So, testen wir es mal an.
Der Plop-Filter hat gut gewirkt.
Du hast ja, kurz mal zwischendurch, also Luca, noch mal zur Erinnerung,
ist ja hier, wie sagt man so schön, wie hieß das früher, über Satellit dabei.
Zugeschaltet.
Kennst du das so früher, wenn die Reporter aus Amerika berichtet haben?
Ja, da war die Latenz, aber viel, viel höher.
Da war die Latenz höher und da stand dann immer Übersatellitstand im Bild.
Das fand ich sehr schön, genau. Ob du jetzt Übersatellit bist,
wissen wir nicht, kann schon sein.
Unwahrscheinlich.
Ja, naja, vielleicht.
Kann alles sein.
Ja, kann sein, aber du hast jetzt keine Starlink-Antenne, du bist schon irgendwie erdgebunden.
Da steht jetzt aber Zoom über dem Bild.
Da steht Zoom, aber du verwendest ja ein Laptop, aber du verwendest nicht deine
Laptop-Kamera, sondern du verwendest ja gerade das iPhone als Kamera,
wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Genau, ich benutze dieses, ja, du willst fragen, warum?
Genau, warum machst du das, warum benutzt du nicht die eingebaute Kamera, ist die kaputt?
Ne, die eingebaute Kamera funktioniert, aber mein Laptop steht zu meiner linken
und dann würde ich immer sehr komisch rüber gucken, nach links,
also an euch vorbei, wenn ich euch anschaue, was sehr komisch ist.
Aber du siehst uns doch auf dem Laptop.
Ich sehe euch auf meinem externen Bildschirm. Ich habe vor mir einen großen externen Bildschirm.
Aha, verstehe. Okay, macht Sinn.
Und ich hatte eigentlich mal von einem, ich glaube von einem ehemaligen Arbeitgeber
so eine teure Logitech-Webcam bekommen.
Die sind zwar teuer, aber das heißt nicht, dass die gut sind.
Die sind nicht furchtbar, aber irgendwann ist die mal kaputt gegangen und da
habe ich gedacht, hey Moment, ich habe doch ein Handy, was irgendwie so coole
Continuity-Features hat. Und habe mir dann kurz einen Mount gedruckt, designt und gedruckt.
Und seitdem benutze ich halt mein Telefon. Funktioniert super.
Es sieht auch einfach vom Bild her sehr viel besser aus als immer noch.
Jetzt auch die neuesten Kameras, die sie einbauen, ist einfach so.
Gut, dann würde ich sagen, steigen wir nochmal gleich hier in die bunte Themenwelt
an. Es ist ja eine Menge passiert in der Welt.
Unter anderem kam diese Woche die Breaking News.
Ne, es war gar keine Breaking News, es war lange angekündigt.
Aber jetzt war der offizielle Verkaufsstart der Nintendo Switch,
der bei den meisten Leuten so aussah wie, ja, wenn du jetzt eine bestellst,
dann kriegst du die im September.
Und da dachte ich mir so, okay, wenn das so ist, dann konnte man einen Tag bei
Amazon einen Einladungsbutton klicken.
Man könnte sich also quasi bei Amazon melden dafür, dass man eingeladen wird, eine Switch zu kaufen.
Diese Einladung würde dann binnen 24 Stunden ausgesprochen werden.
meine, dass ich nicht binnen 24 Stunden was bekommen habe, aber dann zwei Tage
später haben sie mir gesagt, dass sie mir keine Einladung schicken können. Warum auch immer.
Ja, man merkt, da ist Nvidia-Artware drin. Einfach nicht lieferbar.
Ich war nicht so extrem hinterher, weil ich habe ja schon eine Switch.
Aber Ralf, du bist fündig geworden.
Ich war hinterher. Ich habe ja diverse Male berichtet, dass die Switch in unserer
Familieninfrastruktur unersetzlich ist.
um meine Kiddies zu bespaßen und Minecraft in der Familie und so, wir hatten das alles.
Ja, aber wenn dann irgendwie so die 2 rauskommt, da wollte ich dann auch schon
vom Start weg mit dabei sein.
Ja.
Das hat mich schon alles auch sehr interessiert, was da so kommt und wie Spiele,
die ich eigentlich mag und die auf der Switch 1 eigentlich kaum spielbar sind,
wie die sich dann so auf der 2 verhalten würden.
Und Nintendo hatte für treue Kunden eigentlich so ein System ersonnen,
dass wenn du so ein Nintendo-Online-Abo hast und dort auch im letzten Jahr mindestens
x-mal eingeloggt warst,
dann bekommst du auch so ein Premium-Invite zugeschickt hier.
Du hast jetzt die Option, bei den ersten dabei zu sein, die zu einer Switch kommen.
Ich habe mir diese Konditionen angeguckt und dachte so, da müsste ich eigentlich
überall drunter fallen, weil definitiv haben wir online, damit wir halt irgendwie
Mario Kart online spielen können und ähnliches. Und definitiv waren wir zigmal
eingeloggt im letzten Jahr.
Habe auch immer brav irgendwie im Online-Shop was gekauft, aber ich habe keinen
Invite-Code bekommen. Nix, nada.
Und dann hatte ich das Thema eigentlich schon abgeschrieben,
weil es ging auch zwischenzeitlich, die ganzen Zölle mit Trump und so weiter,
was wird das für Auswirkungen auf die internationalen Lieferketten haben und
sind wir in Europa auch betroffen und wird überhaupt eine einzige Switch in
die USA geliefert und so weiter und so fort.
Hatte das Ganze also schon ein bisschen nach hinten geparkt,
nach dem Motto, ja Gott, guckst halt in einem halben Jahr dann irgendwie mal
vorbei, ob irgendwo im Elektronikmarkt eines Nichtvertrauens was steht oder nicht.
Und dann bin ich aber...
Drei Tage vor Lounge, der war glaube ich letzte Woche Donnerstag oder sowas
offiziell, nicht diese Woche, sondern letzte Woche,
einfach mal auf die normale Nintendo-Seite gegangen und habe mich da in meinen
Account eingeloggt und dann stand da so Switch bestellen zum Release Start.
Da klicke ich jetzt mal drauf und dann klickte ich da drauf und dann konnte
man die ganz normal bestellen und ganz normal bezahlen und hat gesagt,
ja kriegst du einen Release Tag, ohne Drama, ohne alles.
Entschuldigung, auf welcher Plattform war das?
Nintendo Online, ganz normal. Ach, direkt bei Nintendo. Direkt bei Nintendo auf der Seite.
Also nicht irgendwie Amazon oder ähnliches, sondern einfach direkt bei Nintendo
in meinem ganz normalen Account eingeloggt und da konnte ich die einfach bestellen
und dann ist die einfach gekommen und es fühlte sich an wie ein normaler Bestellvorgang im Jahr 2025.
Und ist das immer noch so?
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen. Ob das also jetzt nochmal irgendwie eine Welle
war von Teilen, die sie dann doch irgendwie nicht losgeworden sind oder Kreditkarten
funktionierten nicht und sie hatten irgendeinen Restbestand oder ob die einfach
mal genug produziert haben, was ja,
finde ich, bei der Switch 2 so ein No-Brainer sein würde, dass sie sich gut verkaufen wird.
Naja, aber du kannst ja nur so eine gewisse Anzahl vor produzieren.
Das ist ja, ich meine, als die erste Switch gelauncht war, war das doch so,
dass kurz bevor sie dann tatsächlich auf den Markt kommen sollte,
irgendwie der Dollar zu einem Höhenflug ansetzte und Nintendo alle Switches
nach Europa umgeleitet hat und hier stapelten sie sich beim Schlecker und die
Amis haben alle gejammert,
dass sie keine Switch finden, nur weit und breit.
Deswegen dachte ich mir, das werden sie doch diesmal mit den Zöllen genauso machen.
Also es mag sein, dass das jetzt alles gar nicht repräsentativ ist.
Was hat denn Amazon jetzt gerade, wenn man eine da einfach bestellen würde?
Also ich habe mal bei Nintendo geguckt, was da jetzt gerade steht.
Wenn ich mich da einlogge und auf den Nintendo Switch gehe, erstmal der Hinweis,
lebenslang begrenzt Doppelpunkt ein pro Kunde, wohlgemerkt EIN,
ausgeschrieben, ein pro Kunde, ein?
Lebenslang.
Dieses Produkt hat derzeit ein Lebenszeitlimit von ein pro Kunde.
Darunter steht, dieser Artikel ist nicht vorrätig. Leider ist dieses Produkt
derzeit nicht vorrätig. Bitte versuche es später noch einmal.
Das sind doch alles diese leeren Versprechungen.
Okay, was ist da überhaupt das Problem? Also ich meine, Warum erzeugen?
Also ich meine, die wissen doch, dass sie alles haben wollen.
Oder können die echt nicht mehr genug produzieren? Wenn sie nicht genug produzieren
können, wieso produzieren sie nicht einfach erstmal mehr vor?
Ja, Amazon sagt auch, derzeit nicht verfügbar.
Ja, es ist halt auch ein Kapital, das du erst mal vorstrecken musst.
Ja, das sollte ja für Nintendo das Problem sein.
Das ist doch Nintendo, die haben ja auch Geld, oder?
Ich glaube nicht, dass die da irgendwie ein Finanzierungsproblem haben.
Und dann musst du auch eine Fab finden, die dir das Silicon produziert.
Das ist ja auch eher das Problem. Also bei, wie heißt es denn,
TSMC, Kontingente kaufen, das musst du halt inzwischen anderthalb Jahre vorher machen.
Und dann kannst du, wenn du ein großer Chip-Hersteller bist,
natürlich irgendwie tauschen, was du da gerade herstellen lässt,
aber wenn du das Kontingent nicht anderthalb Jahre vorher gekauft hast, wird es ja knapp.
Gut, kommen wir auf die eigentliche Frage zu sprechen.
Ich habe jetzt gerade mal hier bei Saturn geguckt.
Taub das Ding, was?
Kurze Nachklappe irgendwie bei Saturn. Kann man sie jetzt bestellen mit einem
Zeitfenster 1. Achter, 2. Achter?
Also in einem anderthalb Monaten.
Weil die haben ihre Logistik eigentlich auch immer ganz gut am Start.
Ich mache ja immer gerne Impulskauf. Also bei so Sachen, die nicht lieferbar
sind, da warte ich dann immer bis sie lieferbar sind, damit ich sie dann im Affekt kaufen kann.
Das affektet dich nicht.
Wenn Luca willst du auch eine haben?
Dann kaufst du gleich zwei, ne? Für Überspielung.
Ah ne, geht nicht, geht nicht. Ist ja nur beschränkt auf eine.
Ein Prokunde, Lebenszeitlimit.
Ja, aber pro Laden, ne?
Ein Prokunde auf jeden Fall. Das ist schon mal ein Hinweis. So, und jetzt?
Ist geil? Also ich wollte sie haben und ich habe natürlich Meinungen dazu,
weil ich habe es jetzt auch schon echt viel ausprobiert.
Das erste Mal, die ist echt groß.
Also das macht schon einen Riesenunterschied, dass der Screen,
ich weiß gar nicht, nominell ist es nicht so viel größer.
Ich glaube die Diagonale ist ein Viertel mehr oder sowas, aber es wirkt sehr viel immersiver.
Das heißt also, wenn man die jetzt in der Hand hält, dann ist das Bild gefühlt
riesig im Vergleich, wenn man die Einser daneben hat.
Es ist dann eben aber auch groß und sperrig. Das heißt, es ist auch gefühlt
jenseits von diesem, das ist ja so ein kleines schnuckeliges Device,
was ich mal eben so überall mitnehme.
Auch wenn es in einem Case hinterher ist, ist es eigentlich kein Unterschied groß.
Aber vom ersten Eindruck her denkt man so, das ist ja fast ein bisschen zu groß für einen Handheld.
Aber da gewöhnt man sich dran, wie man sich an so vieles gewöhnt und dann denkt
man, ach, aber schön, dass es so
groß ist. So muss ich nicht ständig meine Lesebrille irgendwie aufsetzen.
Dann gibt es so Sachen, die mir egaler nicht sein könnten, wie beispielsweise
das jetzt die Joy-Cons, also die beiden abnehmbaren Controller links und rechts,
dass sie jetzt magnetisch sind.
Ja, das ist cool, dass es jetzt so dran snappt.
Wie ist denn der Maus-Modus von den Dingern?
Ja, siehst du, den habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Das ist das einzige. Man kann aber auch.
Wie ich gehört habe, eine ganz normale Maus anziehen.
Also man kann den rechten Joy-Con kann man einfach so um 90 Grad drehen und
beispielsweise dann auf der Couch oder irgendwie natürlich auf dem Tisch oder
sowas durch die Gegend schubsen, so hochkant, als ob es eine Maus wäre.
Und das soll wohl gut funktionieren, habe ich aber in der Tat noch nicht probiert.
Was aber natürlich für so Ego-Shooter, ist das nicht so die Kernkompetenz der
Switch sicherlich, aber natürlich einen Unterschied macht, aber auch natürlich
für so Strategiespiel-Sachen, wo man irgendwie dann doch schnell von A nach B kommt.
Ich habe gleich auch ein Beispiel, wo ich das eigentlich definitiv mal ausprobieren wollte.
Und ansonsten ist das, was natürlich dann eben doch am meisten Unterschied macht,
ist halt einfach die Hardware, die verbaut ist.
Da war die Switch 1 ja schon, als sie rauskam, ein bisschen schwachbrüstig unterwegs,
so was sie an Grafikleistung hatte.
Aber wie üblich, wenn man gut drauf tunet und gut drauf optimiert,
dann geht natürlich einiges und gerade die Nintendo eigenen Spiele sahen eigentlich
auf der Switch 1 schon immer fantastisch aus.
Also das Mario Kart 8 auf der Switch 1 ist einfach super von der Grafik her
und alles wahnsinnig flüssig, butterweich, nie fängt irgendwo was an zu ruckeln.
Und das ist auch einer...
Pokémon-Spiele zielst du dann nicht dazu?
Zu denen komme ich gleich, weil die sind nämlich gerade bei mir,
da kann ich auch jetzt zu kommen,
große Ausnahme in der Tat im Nintendo Katalog sind die,
offiziellen Pokémon Spiele, also insbesondere hier dieses Purple und wie heißt
das andere das ist ja so ein Zwillings Release gewesen das ist eigentlich dasselbe Spiel,
aber man startet mit quasi irgendwem unterschiedlichen Hauptcharakter und das
ruckelte auf der Switch 1 wie Hechtsuppe obwohl die Grafik wirklich dermaßen
viel hässlicher war als alles was du beispielsweise bei Zelda irgendwo gesehen hast, es war also völlig,
unklar, warum dieses Teil, was ja nun doch irgendwie so eine der Premium-Linien
sein müsste von Nintendo, ja, Pokémon,
das ging technisch gar nicht so.
Meine Familie hat es trotzdem geliebt, die sind da alle gerade voll im Pokémon-Fieber,
mich lässt das leider so ein bisschen kalt, aber ich dachte also,
ich kann das schon alleine nicht spielen, weil das scheiße aussieht und ruckelt
so, das geht nicht, funktioniert nicht.
So, und dafür ist am Release-Tag ein Patch rausgekommen für eben die Switch
2 und was soll ich sagen, es sind immer noch ziemlich nicht so toll aus.
Es sieht schon deutlich besser aus, aber vor allen Dingen ist es butterweich.
Also du hast jetzt sauber mindestens 30, ich glaube eher 60 Frames pro Sekunde.
Das heißt, man muss sich nur eine neue Konsole kaufen, um das Spiel spielen zu können.
Und dann kann man jetzt vernünftig, was will man mehr.
Aber da würde ich nach wie vor
sagen, die Entwicklerinnen mit einem nassen Waschlappen links und rechts.
Weil das, was da grafisch zu sehen ist, ist echt nicht beeindruckend.
Das kriegst du mit einer Playstation 3 locker hin, dass das mit der Switch 1
nicht gelaufen haben soll.
Da liefen ganz andere Geschichten. So, wohingegen beispielsweise jetzt das neue Mario Kart World,
was ja jetzt so auch das Launch-Game ist, ernsthaft, wenn du mir jetzt also
Mario Kart 8 und jetzt das World so ohne großen Kontext nebeneinander gezeigt
hättest, hätte ich auch gesagt, es ist dasselbe Spiel.
Also wenn du so A, B Bilder nebeneinander hast, dann magst du da sehen,
die Texturen sind besser aufgelöst und es sind jetzt irgendwie 24 Autos statt 12 und so weiter.
Da wird es schon viele gute Gründe geben, aber so der erste Eindruck ist,
es sah vorher super aus und war total flüssig, es sieht jetzt super aus und ist total flüssig.
So viel Unterschied ist da nicht. Und den Eindruck hatte ich auch bei den Zelda-Spielen.
Also ich habe beide Zelda-Spiele sehr, sehr lange gespielt. Das zweite komplett
durch, das erste so zu zwei Drittel ungefähr.
Also ich habe das glaube ich ganz gut so im Gedächtnis, wie sich das alles anfühlt
und ansieht und ja, es ist ein bisschen flüssiger und ja, in komplexen Szenen
und ja, die Texturen sind auch ein bisschen hübscher, aber so im Gesamtensemble, finde ich.
Gewinnt es auch nicht so rasend viel.
Da gibt es aber sehr viele Leute, die das anders sehen. Also da bin ich,
glaube ich, eher nexoten Meinung.
Aber für mich ist so ein bisschen das Zwischenfazit, die schon für die Switch
1 sehr durchoptimierten Premium-Titel von Nintendo selber gewinnen.
Finde ich, gar nicht so rasend viel auf der Switch 2.
Dafür hätte ich sie mir jetzt nicht geholt, um jetzt Zelda nochmal super viel
toller spielen zu können.
So, was jetzt aber wirklich aufgeschlossen wurde, sind halt Spiele,
die auf der Switch 1 mal so gerade eben irgendwie liefen und die nicht von Nintendo selber kamen.
Da habe ich einfach zwei Kandidaten ein bisschen intensiver durchgetestet.
Das eine ist No Man's Sky.
Das hatten wir ja auch schon mal in der Sendung. Dieses Open World.
Das ganze Universum wird generativ berechnet und du hast Millionen von Sonnensystemen
und Planeten und kannst Basen bauen.
Also Minecraft in Space, mit noch so ein bisschen Rahmenhandlung drumherum.
Das fand ich schon immer sehr erstaunlich, dass das überhaupt auf der Switch
1 lief. Aber das war auch unfassbar hässlich.
Also das Spiel ist, glaube ich, mittlerweile zwölf Jahre alt ungefähr.
Das hat auch schon ein bisschen was auf dem Buckel, wird aber immer noch mit
kostenlosen Updates versorgt. Also Wahnsinn, was die für eine Firmenpolicy haben.
Wenn du es also vor zwölf Jahren gekauft hast, kannst du dir die aktuellsten
Updates immer noch umsonst dafür holen.
Und die haben auch die ganze Grafik hochgebohrt. Die haben eine 3D-Fassung davon
gemacht für die PS4. Das fand ich auch faszinierend, das in 3D mal zu haben.
So, und das lief aber auf der Switch 1. Könntest du quasi einen Check dran machen,
ja, das Spiel gibt es, aber spielen willst du es eigentlich nicht.
So, und das sieht jetzt auf der Switch 2 fantastisch aus. Es ist butterweich,
es ist sehr, sehr viel detaillierter. Ich schmeiß mal so ein Vergleichvideo in die Shownotes rein.
So, jetzt muss ich mich erstmal hier durch diese neue GUI klicken.
Ist ja alles neu hier beim Mac. Man findet ja nichts mehr. Wir kommen noch dazu.
So, das ist jetzt ein ganz schönes AB-Vergleichvideo, wo man wirklich nebeneinander
links hat man die Switch 1 Version und rechts die Switch 2.
Das ist schon ein Unterschied wie Tag und Nacht und das eine kannst du jetzt
halt richtig gut spielen und das andere ging halt eigentlich nicht.
Und ganz ähnlicher Fall Hogwarts Legacy, das heißt also das Harry Potter Spiel,
auch Open World, sehr sehr große Story, sehr detailliertes World Building und ja, J.J.
Rowling, eigentlich sollte die keinen Cent mehr von uns allen bekommen,
aber wenn man halt doch irgendwie im Harry Potter Universum ist,
ist dieses Spiel schon sehr sehr cool, muss man sagen.
Es spielt halt in einer Zeitlinie, deutlich vor den Büchern und Filmen.
Und das war halt auch ein Wunder, fand ich, dass sie das überhaupt auf die Switch 1 bekommen haben.
Das sah aber auch wahnsinnig hässlich aus und hat wahnsinnig geruckelt.
Das musste man sich also auch schon wirklich sehr schön reden,
um zu sagen, so das spielen wir jetzt.
und da ist die 2er-Version auf der Switch 2 jetzt auch komplett tadellos und
die kann man sich für 9 Euro upgraden. Das finde ich dann auch legitim.
Also man zahlt 9 Euro und kriegt ein komplett neu portiertes Spiel.
Das ist also nicht nur ein paar Code-Zeilen angepasst, sondern das ist glaube
ich ein Port von der PS5-Version, wenn ich mich nicht ganz täusche.
Das heißt also, die haben die PS5-Fassung von Hogwarts Legacy genommen und haben
die an die Switch 2 angepasst, anstatt die Switch 1 Version zu nehmen und dort
irgendwo was an Texturen oder so auszutauschen.
Dazu auch das Video in den Shownotes. Das sind so zwei Beispiele,
wo ich sagen würde, da ist jetzt plötzlich eine Art von Spielen freigeschaltet
für die Switch, die vorher einfach,
nicht erreichbar war. Und worauf ich mich da als nächstes freue,
ist Elden Ring. Das wird rauskommen für die Switch 2. Ich glaube,
das wird auch gut werden.
Oh je, das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, ehrlich gesagt.
Von der Performance her?
Ja, oder von der Grafik. Such dir eins von beiden aus.
Aber also guck dir Hogwarts Legacy an. Ich würde sagen, das ist schon so im
selben Ballpark, was da...
Also um das mal so ein bisschen zu qualifizieren vielleicht.
Also wenn ich mir jetzt hier diese Side-by-Side-Geschichte anschaue,
Du hast sehr viel mehr Detail, Tiefe, sehr viel mehr Lichteffekte in der Switch 2 Version.
Also so Licht, was irgendwo rein ins Gesicht strahlt und so weiter.
Guck dir die Bäume an jetzt beispielsweise. In der Switch 1 kloppen die halt
dann so irgendwie hoch und in der Switch 2 sind sie einfach da und werden immer detaillierter.
Charaktere ist ein riesen Unterschied. Das heißt also, wie gut sind die Figuren
und Personen gerade im Gesicht modelliert.
Haare und so. Das ist schon deutlich besser.
Aber, Ralf, was der Chat auch anmerkt, ist ja Cyberpunk.
Ja, das habe ich nicht, das kenne ich nicht.
Hast du noch nicht getestet. Das ist ja auf dem PC echt ein unglaublich krass
gut aussehendes Spiel, was so die Beleuchtung angeht.
Komplett Ray-Traced alles.
Also komplettes Path-Tracing kann dieser Renderer, glaube ich,
die da haben, sieht unglaublich aus und dass das überhaupt auf der Switch 2
läuft, finde ich erstaunlich.
Also auf der Switch 1 hätte man das glaube ich nie zum Laufen bekommen.
Ja, aber das wollen sie auch auf dem Mac portieren und damit wahrscheinlich auch auf iOS.
Das kann ich mir auch nicht so richtig vorstellen, dass das ordentlich aussieht.
Also wird wahrscheinlich deutlich schlechter aussehen.
Also du siehst aber jetzt auch bei Hogwarts Legacy, also im Gegensatz zur Switch
1 sieht es natürlich super aus, Aber zum Original auf dem PC sieht es halt, naja, okay aus.
Ja, also von der Grundperformance sortiert die sich halt so etwas oberhalb der
PlayStation 4 ein, die Switch 2.
Also es ist halt nicht auf dem Level der PlayStation 5.
Es wird diskutiert, ob es jetzt eher die PS4 Pro ist oder doch eher die Standard.
Das ist je nachdem, auf welche Parameter man da so schaut. Ja.
Aber das ist halt so die Welt, da kannst du halt dann schon irgendwie ein Spiel
in der Komplexität und in der Brillanz von dem Last of Us,
könntest du da eben schon umsetzen und Hogwarts Legacy, würde ich sagen,
ist bisher das grafisch Beste, was ich da jetzt so gesehen habe und das macht
dann auch einfach mal Spaß und der Riesenfortschritt gegenüber halt PC und PS5
ist halt, es ist halt Handheld.
Das heißt, du kannst dich halt abends ins Bett legen und das halt einfach so
im Bett eine Runde daddeln.
Was du natürlich mit hier diesen, hatte ich auch schon mal vorgestellt,
Remote Play Apps auch machen kannst, dass du dann halt dein iPad oder deinen
Laptop nimmst und dann die Playstation im Wohnzimmer halt einfach über WLAN dir rüber streamst,
aber dann ist es halt schon auch hier und da mal ein bisschen ruckelig und nicht so richtig.
Also dafür, dass es ein Handheld ist, finde ich, ist das schon wirklich bemerkenswert,
was sie da zusammengebaut haben.
Ja, das schon, aber ich glaube, wenn du die aktuelle Generation,
so Rock Ally und Steam Deck ist jetzt auch schon ein bisschen älter,
wenn du die anguckst, dagegen kannst du dann doch nicht anstinken.
Also das ist schon irgendwie, da saß Nintendo jetzt ein bisschen lange auf einer
Hardware, was keiner verstanden hat.
Diese Rock Allies und Steam Decks und so, die sind ja aber auch mal richtige Klopper.
Ralf, du meintest, die Switch 2 ist deutlich größer, aber wenn du dann das Steam
Deck nochmal direkt vergleichst, ich bin mir sicher, das ist doppelt so schwer.
Gut, das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema, klar.
Ja, also insgesamt bin ich zufrieden.
Die Familie hat Spaß, kann man nicht meckern.
Jetzt erzähl doch nochmal die wichtigste Sache. Dieses ganze,
Sind die neuen Races geil bei Mario Kart? Das ist doch die einzige Frage,
die man auch beantworten muss.
Ja, siehst du, da bin ich jetzt fast der Falsche. Also ich spiele ganz gerne
Mario Kart, aber ich kann auch driften. So weit bin ich.
Aber leider, dass ich das jetzt betone, zeigt auch schon, auf welchem Level ich da bin.
Du hast keine Chance gegen mich, verstehe.
Das müsste sich herausfinden. Das müssen wir hier mal live erproben.
Das können wir gerne machen.
Ich bin da glaube ich schon ganz robust unterwegs, aber ich bin da jetzt echt kein Mario Kart Nerd.
Wir können mal ein Twitch-Stream machen mit Mario Kart.
Ich kenne also die alten Strecken nicht alle auswendig aus dem FF und wo welche
Abkürzung ist und wo man noch irgendwie welche Goodies und so weiter.
Auf dem Level bin ich nicht unterwegs.
Ich habe aber durchaus wahrgenommen, und das ist so, dass jetzt ungefähr die
Hälfte der Tracks jetzt auf der PS2, auf der Switch 2 alte, so best of sind
von den bisherigen acht Teilen und die Hälfte ungefähr neu.
Und der eigentliche Gag hier bei dem Mario Kart World ist, dass die jetzt alle
auf eine Landkarte gepappt sind
und man dazwischen halt hin und her fahren kann. Das ist schon witzig.
Und da gibt es ja noch Dinge, die man tun kann. Du kannst halt irgendwie wieder
Münzen sammeln und dann kannst du noch...
Es gibt auch noch einen anderen Modus, in dem man spielen kann.
Es gibt so einen Ausscheidemodus.
Der ist ganz... Den fand ich ganz cool. So ein Knockout-Style?
Genau, da fährst du also quasi einmal durch den Kontinent über irgendwie vier,
fünf Stationen und bei jeder Station fliegen die langsamsten fünf raus aus dem Feld.
Du musst also gucken, dass du immer bei den oberen bleibst.
Den Modus fand ich glaube ich ganz witzig, weil da wiederholt sich halt gar nichts.
Du fährst halt nicht irgendwie fünfmal eine Strecke im Kreis,
sondern fährst halt wirklich von A nach B.
Und das ist auch sehr, sehr abwechslungsreich, was da passiert,
weil diese Kontinente halt sehr unterschiedlich modelliert sind.
Man kann sich das alles alles vorstellen bei Mario.
da ich das mit meinen Kindern spiele haben wir entsprechend natürlich jetzt
irgendwie nur die 100er Klasse und da war ich dann immer auf Position 1 von
daher war das für mich dann relativ wurscht wer der hinter mir irgendwie jetzt
raus wird also so gut bin ich dann eben doch,
aber das war jetzt also für mich quasi keine Challenge, das heißt das müsste
ich also irgendwie dann auf 200, 250 mal spielen ich glaube die höchste Klasse
gibt es ja noch gar nicht das war glaube ich irgendwie so ein großer Skandal 250.
Gibt es jetzt?
Also was sind die Klassen bei 1?
Normalerweise 50, 100, 200, 50, 100, 150 und 200.
Genau und die 150 gibt es, aber die 200 gibt es glaube ich noch nicht.
Und alle Fans laufen CETA und Mordio, wann die denn endlich kommt.
Na gut.
Und was es dann noch gibt, das fand ich ganz witzig, sind, du kannst halt bei
Yoshi, der betreibt halt ganz viele Tankstellen und da kannst du hinfahren und
dann bekommst du so Challenges, die auch sehr unterschiedlich sind,
wo man also quasi so kleine Rennaufgaben irgendwie lösen muss.
Die kann man sich natürlich dann alle zusammensammeln und es gibt ja noch so Geheimnisfelder.
eins davon fand ich ganz cool du fährst halt über so eine sehr sehr große Golden
Gate Bridge artige Brücke und vor dir fährt ein Laster und in dem ist halt hinten
in der Laderampe ist halt so ein Geheimnis Item und wenn du da rauf fährst quasi
in den Laster rein und dieses Item aktivierst,
dann steuerst du ab da zum Beispiel den Laster und kannst dann mit dem riesen
Laster über die Brücke und die ganzen Autos alle zur Seite dutschen und so ein bisschen Racken.
Du hast diesen Free-Roam-Modus jetzt einmal am Rande erwähnt.
Ich hatte aber das Gefühl, dass es irgendwie jetzt so das geile,
große, neue Feature ist von diesem Mario Kart.
Ist das cool?
Oder ist das lame?
Also dafür habe ich es vielleicht noch zu wenig gespielt, um da jetzt irgendwie
eine abschließende Meinung zu haben.
Also ich habe mich ein bisschen gefragt, so was motiviert mich jetzt im Kern,
diese ganze Welt erkunden zu wollen. Die ist halt schön gebaut.
Dann rück sie doch einfach raus, die Switch 2. Also wenn du mit Mario Kart nichts
anfangen kannst, dann kipp das Ding doch einfach erstmal ab.
Dann teste ich das mal ordentlich.
Ja, das musst du aber nicht mit mir, sondern mit meinen Rackern verhandeln.
Und da hast du, glaube ich, einen schweren Stand.
Naja, wieso? Sagen wir mal so. Ich würde sagen, wir fahren vier Grand Prix.
Und dann wissen wir ja, wer auf Platz 1 ist.
Ja, dann komm doch einfach mal bei uns vorbei.
Ja, das werde ich mal durchtesten.
Dann machen wir das doch mal. Wir werden berichten.
Okay, gut. So, dann würde ich sagen, können wir den Teil auch abschließen. Oder?
Ja, es gibt noch andere Sachen mit irgendwie Chat und sowas,
aber alles noch nicht ausprobiert, das kann ich dann nicht machen.
Machen wir dann nächste Sender.
Können wir nochmal nach.
Genau. So, kommen wir zu dir, Luca.
Du warst ja, Themenwechsel, du hast ja, erzähl doch mal.
Was du gemacht hast. Ich war auf Reisen. Ja, du hast ja schon erwähnt,
dass ich auch bei der Elixir-Conf war. Die war ja in Krakau.
Genau.
Das war jetzt vor ungefähr einem Monat. ein bisschen mehr als ein Monat her,
da habe ich meinen Urlaub verlängert,
Ich habe ein paar Urlaubstage dran gehangen an diesen Besuch und bin dann von
Krakau mit der Bahn nach Lviv gefahren, also in die Ukraine.
Die Stadt, die im Westen ist, ist das direkt so zwei, drei Stunden hinter der Grenze mit dem Zug.
Würde ich sagen. Der Gateway in den Westen eigentlich.
Genau, da sind auch viele Leute aus dem Osten jetzt hingekommen,
also kriegsbedingt natürlich aus dem Osten geflohen, jetzt eher in den Westen.
da war ich. Und um zu erklären, warum ich da war, muss ich, glaube ich,
ein bisschen nochmal ausholen.
Ich habe über Freunde hier in Hamburg, die ich habe, die aus der Ukraine kommen,
habe ich irgendwie vor einem Jahr oder etwas länger her, anderthalb Jahren mal mitbekommen.
Es gibt so verschiedene Projekte, an denen kann man sich als Zivilist,
beteiligen, um der Ukraine zu helfen. Das geht über Geldspenden hinaus.
Also es geht tatsächlich darum, konkret Sachen zu machen, wie wir 3D-Drucken
jetzt einfach mal Sachen, die die ukrainische Armee benutzt oder benötigt.
Da gibt es ein Projekt, das heißt Druckarmee. Da habe ich angefangen, 3D-Sachen zu drucken.
Das kann alles Mögliche sein, was sie da in Auftrag geben.
Druckarmee heißt das?
Druckarmee. Oder Droids.
Ich kann den Link auch nochmal in den Chat werfen.
Ja, mach mal.
Aber ja, es ist Druckarmee, so ein bisschen halb ukrainisch geschrieben.
Das ist so ein Projekt, wo im Prinzip die Ukraine, die verschiedenen Bataillone
und so weiter, die es da gibt im Militär, ihren Bedarf anmelden an Sachen,
die gedruckt werden müssen.
Die werden sozusagen gecrowdsourced und wenn man sich dort registriert,
teil wird von dieser Community, dann sagt man halt, ja, ich habe jetzt hier
irgendwie zwei Drucker stehen und kann euch tausendmal dieses Teil hier drucken.
und dann verschicke ich das am Ende und kriege dann noch Feedback dazu von wegen,
wie war die Qualität? Musst du irgendwas noch ändern?
Das ist schon sehr cool gemacht. Ist glaube ich nicht so weit verbreitet unter
Nicht-Ukrainern, weil da gibt es schon so Sprachprobleme.
Die Seite ist zum Beispiel, die gibt es auf Englisch, die ist auf Englisch benutzbar,
aber die Inhalte dann, die Beschreibungen von diesen Sachen,
die man druckt, die sind dann meistens nicht in Englisch, sondern nur auf ukrainisch,
also da muss man immer sich zu helfen wissen.
Das war so mein Einstieg in diese Geschichte.
Was dann später hinzu kam ist, ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau wie das dazu kam,
einer der Freunde hier aus Hamburg, mit dem ich das jetzt mache,
hat angefangen Drohnen zu bauen.
Also diese FPV Drohnen, die auch jetzt viel in den Nachrichten sind oder jedes
Mal eigentlich beteiligt sind, wenn die Ukraine wieder irgendwelche militärischen Aktionen startet.
Wie jetzt zum Beispiel die letzte, bei denen sie die ganzen Bomber zerstört haben von Russland.
Das sind jetzt konkret bei dieser Aktion waren das jetzt, glaube ich,
FPV-Drohnen von einer ukrainischen Firma.
Aber letzten Endes sind es auch die gleichen Bauteile da drin,
glaube ich, wie die, die man auch als Hobby ist, sich kaufen kann und dann einfach
zu Hause eine Drohne sich zusammenbaut, die man einfach zum Spaß fliegt.
Da sind keine besonderen militärspezifischen Bauteile drin.
Es ist einfach eine stinknormale FPV-Drohne, die aus ein paar Teilen besteht.
Die kauft man sich bei AliExpress oder wo auch immer. Also bestellt man in der Regel direkt aus China.
Das ist am günstigsten und die kommen ja eh daher, die Sachen.
Die Dinger kannst du zusammenbauen. und dann bei zum Beispiel Plattformen wie
Social Drone oder anderen Projekten in die Ukraine kommen lassen.
Social Drone. Kannst ruhig mal ein paar URLs droppen in den Chat.
Das ist so ein Projekt. Also ich werfe erstmal hier den Druckarmy-Link in den Chat.
Und dieses Drohnenbauen, das machen wir jetzt halt in einem,
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht genau, was der Status ist.
Ich glaube, es gibt Beschreibungen jetzt tatsächlich einen Verein hier in Deutschland
zu gründen für die Drone Aid Collective.
Also eine Kollektive, die halt in Gruppen Drohnen baut und auch Workshops gibt,
wie man diese Drohnen baut.
Und das Ziel ist im Prinzip humanitäre Hilfe damit zu leisten,
also auf zivile Art der Ukraine zu helfen,
auch deren Verteidigung zu sichern, indem man Drohnen baut und sie der Ukraine zukommen lässt.
und Drone Aid Collective Hamburg ist jetzt unser wie nennt man das, unser,
Abzweig davon da haben wir angefangen das haben wir irgendwann dieses Jahr angefangen,
uns mal regelmäßig zu treffen, wir bestellen diese Drohnenteile treffen uns
dann, im Moment machen wir das in einem Büro von ehemaligen Arbeitskollegen,
wir haben jetzt keine dedizierte Werkstatt oder so Wir treffen uns,
gucken, was wir gerade für Drohnen haben, die angefangen sind,
die sich gerade im Bau befinden,
stellen die fertig, fangen neue an, sammeln die und schicken sie dann irgendwann los.
Und wo schickt ihr die dann genau hin? Ich will jetzt nicht die Adresse hören,
aber wer ist dann sozusagen der Verteiler?
Also bei uns schicken wir sie, glaube ich,
ich war da nie dran beteiligt bis jetzt, ich glaube unsere gehen halt tatsächlich
zu Drone 8 Collective in Lviv und was die dann konkret damit machen,
kann ich gar nicht genau sagen,
also über welche Wege das dann wohin kommt, weiß ich nicht genau.
Und in Deutschland gibt es halt noch Drone Aid Collective Berlin und auch München. Das sind Gruppen.
Ich werde auch gleich mal einen Link dazu in den Chat werfen.
Da gibt es nämlich eine schöne Sache, nämlich Spenden. Man kann dafür spenden.
Diese Drohnen kosten natürlich was. Also wir machen das auf Spendenbasis.
Beziehungsweise wir kaufen auch selber von unserem eigenen Geld.
Okay, Tim, ich sehe, du hast den Link da schon reingeworfen. Sehr gut.
Das ist nochmal der Hamburg-Link. Auf Spenden sind wir angewiesen,
weil die Drohnen, die sind jetzt nicht arschteuer, wie so irgendwie Militärgerät.
Im Vergleich sind die halt tierisch günstig.
Die kosten so 300 bis, oder ich würde sagen 200 bis 300 Euro.
Vielleicht auch 350, je nachdem.
So für eine Drohne. Aber wenn man ein paar mehr zusammenbauen möchte,
dann läppert sich das natürlich sehr schnell und das ist dann natürlich so ein
bisschen ein limitierender Faktor.
Ja genau, wir haben angefangen diese Drohnen zu bauen und haben uns dieser Drone
Aid Collective angeschlossen und als Teil dieser sind wir dann zu einem Hackathon
gefahren, der war in VEVE.
Das war ein Defense Hackathon, der veranstaltet wird vom European Defense Tech Hub.
Das ist ein kleines Start-up, das ist vielleicht das beste Wort,
die regelmäßig, tatsächlich sogar sehr häufig Hacker-Fonds in ganz Europa stattfinden lassen.
und das Ziel ist halt einfach Leute in diese Branche reinkommen zu lassen,
und es ist halt ein sehr großer Fokus auf Verteidigung in der Ukraine.
Also darum dreht sich da im Prinzip alles.
Na klar.
Es geht halt um Europas Sicherheit, Europas Souveränität und da ist halt gerade
die Ukraine natürlich der Brennpunkt.
Und erzähl doch mal, wie das so war, da hinzufahren, wie geheimnisgrimmerisch war das.
Was kannst du uns sagen, was kannst du uns nicht sagen?
Ja, was kann ich euch sagen. Also, ich wusste den konkreten Ort,
wo das stattfinden wird, nicht bis am Abend zuvor, vor dem ersten Tags Hackathons.
Wir wussten halt nur, es findet in Wiev statt.
und ziemlich spät haben wir dann den konkreten Ort mitgeteilt bekommen und dann hieß es auch ja,
fahrt da nicht direkt mit dem Taxi hin oder wenn ihr da mit dem Bolt oder was
auch immer ihr da nehmt, lasst euch irgendwie ein paar hundert Meter vorher
absetzen also es war schon ein bisschen,
geheimnisgrämerisch, weil das halt Militärgelände ist und wir nicht,
Fotos von dem Gelände und so machen sollten,
also das wurde halt dort mit veranstaltet von dem 3rd Assault Battalion,
Die könnten einem ein Begriff sein, wenn man sich irgendwie mit dem Krieg in
der Ukraine ein bisschen beschäftigt hat.
Es ist halt eins von den vielen Bataillonen, die es da gibt,
die halt irgendwie recht viel Drohnenkram machen, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Ich habe mich damit jetzt auch nicht so genau auseinandergesetzt.
Die haben immer verschiedene Abteilungen, unter anderem halt auch Drohnen,
aber bei denen gibt es diverse Drohnengruppen, ich glaube drei oder vier oder
so, waren da irgendwie dabei.
Naja, okay. Was zu denen halt auch gehört, ist so ein Ding, so eine Drohnenflugschule im Prinzip.
Die nennen sie, meine ich, Killhouse FPV.
Das konnte ich jetzt auch nicht so konkret nachvollziehen, wie das funktioniert.
Da gibt es natürlich eine Website zu, aber die ist nur auf Ukrainisch.
ich weiß, dass man auch als Zivilist da sich so einen Kurs buchen kann,
also für Geld kann man halt dort lernen, Drohnen zu fliegen,
keine Ahnung, was diese Kurse beinhalten, wie das aussieht aber solche Sachen
machen die dort und die waren auch mit auf diesem Hackathon,
und die Leute, die von denen da waren die waren dann auch als Mentoren da um
die Leute bei ihren Projekten an denen sie arbeiten, irgendwie zu beraten um
tatsächlich irgendwie so Berichte und Ratschläge aus erster Hand geben zu können.
Kannst du sagen, wie viele Leute so ungefähr da waren?
Ja, das waren bestimmt schätzungsweise so 150 Leute, denke ich.
So die Teilnehmer, die Hacker, die teilgenommen haben.
Das waren halt am Ende, meine ich, 30 Gruppen, die präsentiert haben,
wovon die Gruppen so zwei Leute bis fünf Leute groß waren.
Ich habe die Präsentationen von den ganzen Hack-Projekten leider nicht zu Ende gucken können.
Ich musste nach Hause gehen und packen, musste irgendwie nach der Hälfte gehen.
Aber da gab es schon interessante Sachen. Da kann ich natürlich auch nochmal
ein bisschen zu erzählen, was da so der Fokus war bei diesen Projekten.
Ein großer Fokus ist tatsächlich Drohnen. Ich habe es ja schon erwähnt,
Drohnen ist ein Riesenfokus.
Die Ukraine werden halt jede Nacht angegriffen von Drohnen aus Russland.
Und so die Verteidigung ist halt darauf angewiesen, dass man die Drohnen zum
einen gut erkennen kann, früh erkennen kann und dann auch irgendwie halt zerstören kann.
Und das war halt ein großer Fokus dort.
So visuelle, also mit mehreren Sensortechniken Drohnen erkennen,
also nicht nur visuell, sondern auch Ton mit dazunehmen, weil die Drohnen sind ja auch sehr laut.
über verschiedene Sensordaten einfach eine genaue Ortung von Syndronen zu finden,
zu machen zu können oder vielleicht auch aus der Luft das machen zu können oder,
es gibt viele Möglichkeiten, also da gibt es Anregungen und auch tatsächlich,
wir haben sie das genannt, Objectives oder ich weiß nicht, wie sie das genannt haben,
Ziele einfach, ja Ziele, ja genau, Ziele, die du irgendwie dir überlegen kannst
in deinem Projekt, wie setze ich das um, habe ich da eine Idee zu und,
da gab es schon sehr, sehr viele coole Projekte.
Aber es ist schon jetzt primär so Defense und so weiter orientiert gewesen, kann man sagen?
Ja, total. Also es ist halt Defense Tech, das sind dort sehr viele junge Leute
gewesen als Hacker, ist mir aufgefallen, Studenten, auch relativ viele aus Deutschland tatsächlich,
die tatsächlich einfach in diese Branche jetzt einsteigen wollen.
Aber die meisten waren aus der Ukraine oder wie?
Nee, ich glaube, ich hatte irgendwo gehört, es sind ein bisschen mehr Ausländer gewesen als Ukrainer.
Ah ja, okay. Also jetzt von überall her?
Was war jetzt, dass Deutschland jetzt gut vertreten ist, wundert mich gar nicht
mal so sehr, aber was war da noch? Polen wahrscheinlich?
Ja, da waren Leute aus den Niederlanden, aus Frankreich, aus Polen.
Also wirklich von überall aus Europa habe ich da Leute gesehen.
Ja und wir waren dort nicht als Hacker, sondern wir waren als Mentoren dort.
Also ich und noch zwei Leute von dieser Drone Aid Collective.
Wir hatten auf unseren Badges dann Mentor draufstehen. Ganz cool.
Was hast du denn Mentor? Ja, wir haben am ersten Tag, das war bevor das Hacken
losging, also am ersten von den vier Tagen, die das stattfand,
gab es nämlich eine Reihe von Workshops, die gehostet wurden.
Also es gab von Killhouse FPV mehrere Workshops zum Drohnenfliegen.
Es gab so ein Combat Medic Training.
Es gab viele Sachen, die habe ich jetzt nicht mehr alle auf der Kette.
Aber von uns gab es einen Drohnenbau-Workshop.
Weil da sind viele Leute, die überlegen sich halt, ja, wie kann man sich gegen
diese Drohnen verteidigen? Was kann man damit machen?
Haben aber vielleicht noch nie so eine Drohne mal richtig zusammengebaut und
auseinandergenommen, angeguckt, in der Hand gehabt.
Und da hilft das, glaube ich, wenn man einmal irgendwie so ein Ding zusammenbaut from scratch.
Und das haben wir gemacht. Wir hatten da irgendwie, ich glaube,
16 Sets an Drohnenbauteilen.
Die waren vorgelötet. Also wenn man so eine Drohne zusammenbaut,
hat man ungefähr, würde ich sagen, das über den Daumen peilen,
irgendwie 20 bis 30 Stellen, die man löten muss.
Das dauerte halt am längsten, gerade wenn man das noch nie gemacht hat.
Und da waren halt schon alle Sachen vorgelötet, so mit Steckkonnektoren vorbereitet.
Dauert trotzdem ein bisschen. Also ich glaube, wir haben schon irgendwie drei
Stunden damit verbracht, bis dann alle fertig waren.
Ja, das war so der Grund, weshalb ich da war.
Also ich glaube, ansonsten hätte ich nie die Idee gehabt, da mal hinzufahren.
Aber jetzt hat sich das halt ergeben über diese Drone 8 Collective Geschichte.
Also wie vielen Teilen besteht so eine Drohne, die ihr da gebaut habt?
Wenn man das quasi jetzt so vor sich auf den Tisch verteilt hätte.
Also du hast einmal den Rahmen. Das ist meistens ein Deckel, ein Boden und vier Arme.
Dann hast du natürlich vier Motoren. Dann hast du einmal eine Kamera vorne dran.
Dann hast du zwei PCBs, wovon einer der ESC ist.
Der steuert die Motoren, also der Electronic Speed Controller,
beziehungsweise vier Electronic Speed Controller sind da drauf.
Dann gibt es noch den Flight Controller. Da läuft im Prinzip die Firmware, die die Drohne steuert.
Und dann hast du einen Videosender und einen Empfänger für die Steuerung. Das war es im Prinzip.
Die Rotoren hast du vergessen.
Ja stimmt, die Propeller und Antennen gibt es natürlich auch noch.
Im Wesentlichen sind es vier bewegliche Teile.
Deshalb sind die günstig und auch robust.
Die Kameras, wie sind die bei solchen Modellen aufgebaut? Weil da gibt es ja
unterschiedliche Philosophien, ob man beweglicher hat oder welche mit einem
extrem weiten Fischei, wo du dann nur in der Mitte einen Ausschnitt rausnimmst
und den dann dafür verschieben kannst, um quasi woanders hinzugucken.
Also bewegbar sind die Dinger nicht. Du stellst einen Winkel ein.
Also du kannst den einfach von, ich gucke direkt nach vorne bis ich gucke ein
bisschen nach oben oder ich gucke einfach ganz nach unten. Das kannst du so
statisch einstellen, indem du die Schrauben löst und dann die Kamera ein bisschen drehst.
Das Field of View von den Dingen ist, ich schätze mal so um die 110 bis 120 Grad.
Sowohl horizontal als auch vertikal oder so R-Cinema Scope breit?
Also ist es quasi quadratisch?
Das hat eine Seite von 4 zu 3 normalerweise.
Okay, also relativ quadratisch. Es gibt auch welche.
Die machen 16 zu 9, aber das ist dann einfach ein gecroptes 4 zu 3.
Okay.
Und die Drohnen, die wir bauen, die benutzen ein analoges Videosystem.
Das heißt, da wird einfach ein analoges Videosignal von der Kamera über die Luft geschickt.
Und das kann dann tatsächlich auch jeder sich anschauen, der so eine Videobrille
hat oder irgendein anderes System, das lesen kann.
Wie ist dann die Reichweite davon, von denen?
Das hängt so ein bisschen von verschiedenen Faktoren ab, aber 20 Kilometer ist möglich.
Also da gibt es natürlich auch noch so Sachen wie Relay-Systeme und wie bessere
Sender, bessere Antennen, dies, das.
Aber man kann schon sehr große Distanzen damit hinkriegen.
20 Kilometer ist auch derzeit so an der Front ungefähr so der als überwacht geltende Bereich.
Aber es gibt einfach viele Faktoren, die das deutlich schlechter machen.
Also nasses Gras reicht schon oder nasse Blätter von Bäumen.
Wasser dämpft das Signal halt tierisch.
Und also wenn man hoch in der Luft fliegt und auch noch direkten Blickkontakt
sozusagen hat zur Drohne, dann kann man echt sehr, sehr weit fliegen.
Ich bin vor zehn Jahren mal ein bisschen mehr Drohne geflogen,
so verschiedene Sachen. und am Ende auch D.O.D.I. und sowas.
Aber das war eine komplett andere Welt.
Das ist nicht zu vergleichen mit dem, was da jetzt unterwegs ist.
Was mich jetzt so ein bisschen wundert, wenn das ein analoges Videosignal ist,
dann ist das doch relativ leicht zu jammen, oder?
Ja, das ist so. Das ist einfach ein Teil davon.
Es gibt viele Electronic Warfare-Maßnahmen.
So nennt sich das da. Aber was im Prinzip heißt, er wird jammen jetzt hier diese Signale.
Also digitale Signale sind auch genauso leicht zu jammen.
Aber die Steuerung ist digital, oder?
Die Steuerung, das ist ein digitales Protokoll.
Wir benutzen Express LRS, das ist so das gängigste Protokoll- und Funksystem,
was auch eine super Reichweite hat.
Ich muss dir übrigens widersprechen, nein, digitale Signale,
je nachdem wie man sie aufbereitet, sind deutlich schwerer zu jammen.
Also so ein Spread-Spectrum kriegst du wirklich nur schwer gejammt.
Aber Luca, wenn ich dich jetzt richtig verstanden habe, ist es ja defensiv ausgerichtet.
Das heißt also ja dann doch auch über dem eigenen Flugraum, Luftraum,
wo dann einfach mal tiefer im Land mit Jem wahrscheinlich dann doch nicht so
viel Problem unterwegs sind.
Wahrscheinlich nicht, aber diese Drohnen sind halt vielseitig einsetzbar.
Wenn du sie rein defensiv einsetzt, kannst du sie natürlich benutzen,
um einfach Surveillance zu machen. zu gucken, ist hier jetzt irgendwo gerade,
ist hier irgendwie feindliche Bewegung oder so.
Ja, die Drohnen werden auch als Medical Versorgungssystem oder um Leute einfach
mit Nahrung zu versorgen, jetzt kann ich mal nur an der Front sein,
auch irgendwie Leute, die noch irgendwo noch in Häusern sind,
in bedrohten Bereichen.
Also die Dinger sind so universell.
Ich war ja auch, in der Ukraine habe ich ja schon mal berichtet,
da war ich ja auch bei so einer Firma, so einen von diesen Startups,
die da halt Drohnen bauen.
Die habe ich halt auch gefragt, wegen Analog und Kamera und so weiter.
Digital macht da keiner, weil Analog hat halt auch einfach den Vorteil,
es ist halt unmittelbar und da kann weniger schief gehen.
Das ist dann halt auch sofort kompatibel. Du hast da nicht irgendwelche komischen
digitalen Protokolle, bei denen irgendwas schief geht.
Du brauchst halt aufwendige Empfänger und so weiter.
Kein Pairing. Ja, Pairing, all diese ganzen Aspekte.
Also das ist halt einfach da in so einer Kriegssituation Da ist so ein analoges
Signal einfach praktisch.
Der Nachteil ist natürlich, jeder kann es sehen. Jeder kann sehen,
da fliegt jetzt eine Drohne auf mich zu.
Ob dir das jetzt was hilft, diese Info, das ist was anderes,
weil diese Drohnen sind einfach verdammt schnell.
Und klein.
Hier Frage aus dem Chat. Hattet ihr auch irgendwo was mit Glasfasersteuerung,
dass sie also so ein super dünnes Glasfaserkabel hinter sich herziehen?
Nee, sowas habe ich noch nie in der Hand gehabt. Würde mich aber mal interessieren.
Ja, das ist natürlich jetzt sehr verbreitet, gerade in der Ukraine, auch bei den Russen.
Das ist eine echte Seuche, weil du damit natürlich erstmal die Electronic Warfare
natürlich verhindernst. Aber das andere Problem ist, dass natürlich jetzt in
diesen Kampfgebieten ist halt das ganze Land mit Glasfaser übersät.
Also es gibt so Fotos von Feldern, wo einfach alles voll mit diesen Glasfasern ist.
Und was das sozusagen noch für Auswirkungen hat, diese ganzen kleinteiligen
Glasbruchteilchen auf die Umwelt, das wird sich noch zeigen.
Es gibt sogar Fotos von Vogelnestern, die zur Hälfte aus Glasfasern bestehen.
Ja, das ist alles nicht schön.
hast du noch so einen Eindruck von deinem Aufenthalt? Kannst du noch irgendwas?
Ja klar, also ich habe jetzt nicht super viel Zeit gehabt, mir die Stadt anzuschauen
dort, aber ich fand das da echt ganz angenehm.
Man muss natürlich sagen, Wiev ist so weit im Westen, dass die nicht so sehr
betroffen sind von den Angriffen.
Da passiert relativ wenig.
Aber du warst doch auch im Keller, oder?
Genau, es gibt allerdings trotzdem noch Air Raid Alarme, die da losgehen.
In der letzten Nacht, oder was, in der vorletzten, die ich da war,
da gab es halt um drei Uhr nachts einen Alarm.
Der ging dann mit Lautsprechern draußen los und mein Handy ging auch in einer
tierischen Lautstärke, von der ich nicht wusste, dass die Dinger das überhaupt können, los.
Ich hatte nämlich so eine App installiert, die da alle benutzen,
die heißt glaube ich Air Alarm.
Die ist eine ukrainische App, die kann einen halt benachrichtigen von wegen,
ja hier gibt es jetzt gerade bei dir einen Alert, bitte begib dich in einen Shelter.
und was man dieser App dann auch erlaubt, ihr kennt das ja, dass eine App fragt,
so darf ich Notifications senden und dann sagst du ja oder nein.
Eine App kann auch fragen, darf ich ich weiß nicht genau wie die das nennen,
kritische Notifications oder so senden.
Das heißt das Ding kann dich immer benachrichtigen, auch wenn du do not disturb
und so weiter und so fort anhast.
Also so ein Notification Modus, der einfach alles über override,
und das ging dann halt um drei uhr nachts los tierisch laut und dann sind wir
auch tatsächlich in die garage gegangen von dem apartment komplex in dem wir da waren.
Ich habe gerade.
Geguckt habe doch.
Drauf ja das ist das ist eine besondere erlaubnis die man bei apple anfragen
muss und die sie dann auch im review prozess nachprüfen ob.
Du das.
Wirklich haben darfst,
Aber ja, die ist laut. Die ist laut. Die ist wirklich laut.
Also gut, nachts, wenn man schläft, ist alles laut, was plötzlich losblökt. Aber ja.
Wenn du das für dich eine extra Erlaubnis von Apple bräuchst,
dann hätte jede scheiß Essensliefer-App das.
Bitte erlaub uns, dich zu nerven.
Jetzt 5% Rabatt, wenn du sofort bestellst.
Ja.
Ja, was man ansonsten in VIV noch so mitgenommen haben kann, ist,
wir sind immer so, nachdem wir durch waren mit dem Hacken dort,
nachdem die Veranstaltung ein bisschen für uns zumindest für den Tag vorbei
war, die anderen Teams haben dann noch viel gehackt, auch nachts durch.
Wir sind dann irgendwann abends immer in die Innenstadt gegangen, in eine Bar oder so.
Mussten dann allerdings schon um 11 wieder gehen, weil die Bars schließen um 11.
Es gibt eine Ausgangssperre ab 12. Das heißt, da ist so das Nachtleben dann
auch so ein bisschen vorbei.
Es gibt da auch Speakeasies und so oder wie auch immer sie das nennen.
Bars, die dann halt inoffiziell lange aufhaben.
Habe ich mir jetzt nicht angeschaut, aber gibt es.
War aber trotzdem eine ganz schöne Erfahrung dort. War ganz nett.
Würde ich gerne wieder hin.
Und wenn jetzt Leute Bock haben, sich eurem Droid Aid anzuschließen,
also das ist ja in drei Städten lokalisiert, Berlin, Hamburg,
was war das dritte, München?
München, genau. Und auch noch in anderen Ländern übrigens.
Also es gibt da auch noch in Portugal Gruppen und in den Niederlanden und natürlich
in der Ukraine. aber das, also drone8.de ist schon mal ein guter Anlaufpunkt.
Da gibt es halt auch Kontaktdaten zu den verschiedenen Gruppen.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie das bei den anderen Gruppen aussieht,
ob die jetzt gerade Bedarf haben, dass da Leute kommen und mithelfen können. Das weiß ich nicht.
Vielleicht kann man da einfach mal fragen, wenn man Interesse hat.
Alright. Super. Interessanter Einblick.
So, ein bisschen Kleinkram. Hier auf Phonik, ihr kennt es ja.
Also mein bevorzugter,
Audiodienst, in dem ich seit langer, langer Zeit eng verbunden bin und den ja
auch hier fleißig für meine eigenen,
Produktionen benutze und ich verfolge das jetzt auch nicht immer so daily,
aber ich bin immer wieder beeindruckt, was die alles so raushauen,
weil die ja irgendwie die Ersten waren, die so diese ganzen AI,
Machine Learning basierten Audiobearbeitungstools eigentlich in die Welt gebracht
haben und sie bleiben da auch weiterhin ganz gut dabei.
Mittlerweile gibt es glaube ich sogar so einen AI-automatisierten Schneideeditor
und was nicht alles, aber was ich mir vor kurzem nochmal angeschaut habe,
war ihre Verlautbarung, dass sie jetzt auch einen neuen Ansatz haben,
um alte Aufnahmen zu verbessern.
Ein sogenanntes Bandwidth-Extension-Feature.
Wenn ihr also Aufnahmen von irgendetwas habt, also so uralte Audioaufnahmen,
was weiß ich, aus den 50er oder 60er Jahren.
Es gibt hier so ein Beispiel mit Präsident Nixon und so, schlechtes Mikrofon.
und sie haben halt irgendwie so AI-basiert, so ein bisschen wie man das aus
diesen Bildverbesserungstools kennt oder so Super-Resolution,
ziehen sie einfach die abgeschnittenen Frequenzen im Höhenbereich,
die meistens bei diesen Aufnahmen nicht mehr da sind,
die ziehen sie sich irgendwie aus der Nase und generieren die quasi aus dem Audio, was da ist.
Und ich habe jetzt kein eigenes Material getestet, auch wenn ich sicherlich
noch irgendwas habe aus alten Zeiten, was nicht so toll ist.
Das müsste ich mal ausprobieren.
Ich habe mir jetzt nur die Demos angeschaut, aber ich fand es ziemlich bemerkenswert, die Vergleiche.
Warte mal, ich kann das vielleicht sogar mal kurz anspielen, wenn ihr möchtet.
Das macht doch mal, wir sind doch ein Audio-Podcast.
Wir sind ja ein Audio-Podcast, genau.
In so hoher Qualität, dass man den Unterschied noch hören kann.
Wir werden noch so viel über Dinge reden, die wir sehen heute,
dass so ein bisschen was hören doch mal.
Ja, genau.
Das Beispiel wollte ich, was ist denn das Beispiel mit dem Nixen hier? Genau, End of Vietnam.
Und zwar gibt es jetzt hier quasi drei Varianten. Das erste ist die Originalaufnahme, Low Bandwidth.
Dann gibt es die verbesserte Variante.
Und dann nochmal die verbesserte Variante und nochmal das Denoising.
Ja, ich hoffe, das ist jetzt hier. Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Das war falsch. Ich weiß auch schon, warum.
Bitte hold the line, hold the line. So.
So, und jetzt das Ganze in Extended.
At 12.30 Paris time today, January 23, 1973,
Special Advisor Lee Docto on behalf of the Democratic Republic of Vietnam.
Und jetzt nochmal mit Dieter Neuser. At 12.30 Paris-Time today, January 23, 1973,
and Special Advisor Lee Ducteau on behalf of the Democratic Republic of Vietnam.
Nochmal zum Vergleich, das Alter. At 12.30 Paris time today,
January 23, 1973, the agreement.
Docto on behalf of the Democratic Republic of Vietnam. Also es klingt besser,
aber ich habe das Gefühl,
wenn ich da genau reinhöre, Das S und das F ist in der Originalaufnahme besser
zu unterscheiden als in der verbesserten Variante.
Ja, also man hat schon ein bisschen Schärfe drin.
Also irgendwas an Artefakten kommt schon ein bisschen rein. Ich finde,
der Dinoiser ist einfach irre, den die mittlerweile haben.
Der ist wirklich Weltklasse, topnotch. Also das ist wirklich perfekt.
Auch den Hall und so.
Auch den Hall, wir sie den rauskriegen. Aber wir kennen ja auch die Jungs und Mädels.
Es ist schon noch ein Weg zu gehen. Stellt euch vor, wie der gute oder nicht
so gute Nixon denn klingen würde, wenn er jetzt hier bei uns im Studio eins
unserer Headsets aufhätte.
Das ist eben der Goldstandard, gegen den man eigentlich benchmarken muss.
Sie machen es jetzt schon sehr viel besser, aber es ist halt immer noch nicht
so, als ob er jetzt hier bei uns im Studio sitzen würde. Und vielleicht erleben
wir noch, dass man auch dorthin kommt.
Ich frage mich ja, wie originalgetreu klingt die Stimme eigentlich?
Ist sie so ein bisschen verfremdet durch diesen Prozess oder klingt sie noch, wie er wirklich klang?
Genau, also das ist ja quasi die Frage nach Ground Truth bei solchen Verfahren immer.
Also was ist das Original, das verlässliche Original?
Und es wird mit Sicherheit von Nixon hervorragende Tonaufnahmen vor super teure Mikrofonen geben.
Das heißt, mit ziemlicher Sicherheit haben wir Ground Truth von Nixon und ich
könnte mir vorstellen, wenn man die eine Woche dransetzt, hier von Auphonic,
dass sie ein Modell direkt darauf auf Nixon tunen, dass man durchaus dann schon
da in Schlagweite kommt.
Aber das ist natürlich überhaupt nicht praktikabel, weil das kannst du ja nicht
verallgemeinern auf andere Studio-Setups und andere Stimmen und so weiter.
Von daher ist es dann halt, hast du keinen Ground Truth für das,
was da an Material anfällt.
Ich.
Frage das, weil.
Ich habe vor ein paar Tagen mal von Nvidia deren Software Broadcast getestet,
die aktuelle Version, die haben halt so eine Windows-Software,
die macht dir halt in Realtime so ein neues Echo, was auch immer,
Removal von Audioeingang und Ausgang.
Und da haben sie irgendwie so ein neues Feature drin, wo die sagen,
ja, wenn du das anklickst, dann klingt das so, als ob du es professionell im
Studio aufgenommen hast, deine Stimme.
Es klingt wirklich gut mit meinem crappy Gaming-Headset, aber es klang nicht, als ob ich rede.
Als ob du redest, ja. Also daran versuchen sich gerade ja echt viele.
Das war eine andere Person.
Die redet. Also viele Softwarehersteller probieren gerade automatisiert,
das halt besser klingen zu machen. Wir haben in Ultraschall ja auch das eine
oder andere drin, EQ basiert, neues Filter und so weiter.
Aber es geht halt derzeit nur bis zu einem gewissen Grad und meistens kaufst
du dir entweder Artefakte ein oder es klingt halt gut, aber nicht nach dir selber.
Wobei das, wie man selber klingt, ist ja auch irgendwie sehr relativ.
Hatten wir auch schon ein paar Mal hier und im Lautsprecher,
dass dadurch, dass man sich selber ja ohnehin anders hört als alle anderen auf
der Welt einem hören, weil der ganze Kopf,
der ganze Knochenaufbau als interner Resonanzkörper wegfällt für die Außenwelt
und man dann immer schockiert ist, wie scheiße man über Mikros klingt.
Ja nee, so hört die Welt euch.
Ihr selber hört euch nur immer geiler, weil ihr noch so viel Bassresonanz in eurem Körper habt.
Das ist deine Stimme. Wobei meistens ja noch crappy Mikros sind.
Dann ist man zu Recht erschrocken.
Alles nicht so einfach mit diesem Audiokram.
So, Kultur, Ralf.
Kultur, genau. Ich mache mal, was eher ungewöhnlich ist, normalerweise feiere
ich ja hier immer ganz gerne Kultur und heute will ich mal eine explizite Warnung aussprechen.
Schaut nicht diesen Film.
Denken Sie jetzt nicht an ein großer Elefant.
Also wovon rede ich? Von der teuersten Netflix-Filmproduktion aller Zeiten.
die, man kann nur fassungslos staunen, wirklich 320 Millionen Euro gekostet hat.
Es gibt eine Seite irgendwie, die ausrechnet, wie viele tolle Filme man damit
stattdessen hätte produzieren können.
Unter anderem die komplette Herr-der-Ringe-Trilogie nur verfilmt,
das hätte dafür gereicht.
So, was ist passiert? Netflix hat ein Buch genommen, das habe ich auch mal mitgebracht
ins Studio, weil ich dachte, wir können ja auch mal über Bücher reden.
Also The Electric State von, jetzt wird es schwierig, Simon,
ich glaube Stollenhag, so wird er glaube ich ausgesprochen, das ist ein Schwede.
Stollenhag.
Stollenhag, danke. Und das ist ein Buch mit Bildern, also ein Bilderbuch,
allerdings halt dezidiert nicht für Kinder, sondern das ist schon also ein Erwachsenenbuch
und man erkennt eigentlich den Grafikstil von dem sofort.
Das ist der, der immer sonderbare technische Aufbauten in tristen,
traurigen, depressiven Landschaften irgendwie zeichnet.
Also wenn man einmal, genau, das ist Science Fiction, aber immer sehr im Hier
und Jetzt verortet, so alternative Zeitlinien, was wäre gewesen,
wenn, oder was passiert in ein paar Jahren.
Und wenn man mal ein paar von den Bildern gesehen hat, erkennt man die sofort wieder.
Der hat da so einen ganz eigenen Zeichenstil einfach.
Und dazu hat er dann eben auch ein Buch geschrieben, dieses The Electric State.
Was so als Gesamtkunstwerk finde ich, ist das schon sehr cool,
aber es zieht einen auch sehr runter.
Es ist schon eine sehr dystopische Zukunft, die er da beschreibt und insbesondere,
wenn man danach seine Apple VR aufzieht, fühlt man sich auch richtig schlecht,
weil das ist so eine der Kernthemen, die es darum geht,
dass also in Zukunft die Menschheit halt nur noch in solchen VR-Entertainment-Systemen
unterwegs ist und dann stil und ergreifend verhungert und verdurstet,
weil sie halt so mit immersiven Impulsen getriggert werden die ganze Zeit,
dass sie selbst das Essen und Trinken irgendwie vergessen.
und völlig weggedriftet sind und dann mehr oder weniger die gesamte menschliche
Gesellschaft kollabiert.
So, das ist im Wesentlichen die Geschichte dieses Buches mit noch ein paar Facetten.
Und das hat Netflix verfilmt. Da denkt man sich, ja, cool, das kann ja was werden.
Vor allem diese ganzen Settings mit diesen riesigen Robotern und so.
Das kann doch gut werden.
Und dann haben sie halt jetzt einen Film gemacht. Und wir haben in der letzten
Folge hier über den Minecraft-Film geredet. Und da hattest du ja sehr harsche Meinungen zu Tim.
Ja, der war einfach scheiße.
Ja, du warst, schlimmster Film aller Zeiten und so, du warst da sehr explizit,
dieser Film hier, der unterbietet das so um den Faktor 3.
Es ist glaube ich wirklich das Dümmste, was ich am Film seit sehr langer Zeit
gesehen habe. Die Optik, visuellen Effekte, das ist alles irgendwie tadellos.
Das ist von den Machern hier der von Endgame und den anderen Dingensfilmen von Marvel hier.
Wie heißt diese Truppe? Avengers, genau. Genau.
Das heißt also Effekte, Special Effekte können die. Ob die Story können,
ist dann immer eine andere Frage, aber jetzt irgendwie so die letzten Endgame
und sowas, das war ja alles gar nicht so schlecht.
Das heißt also das Ganze sieht schon gut produziert aus, aber was sie aus diesem
Buch gemacht haben, ist also wirklich komplett verstörend auf wahnsinnig vielen Ebenen.
Und ich möchte ihm jetzt hier auch gar nicht viel Raum einräumen.
Ich wundere mich schon gerade, warum das überhaupt so einräumen.
Also haltet euch fern von diesem Film. Ich habe sechs Anläufe gebraucht, um ihn durchzugucken.
Du hast ihn zu Ende geguckt.
Ich habe ihn zu Ende geguckt, weil ich dachte, vielleicht passiert noch irgendwas,
vielleicht ist es irgendwo etwas. Ich opfere mich jetzt auch für euch alle da draußen.
Tut es mir nicht nach, ignoriert das einfach.
320 Millionen einfach komplett vaporisierter.
Das, was wohl Mini Bobby Brown mitspielt.
Ja, das ist...
Also ich habe gerade festgestellt, ich habe den, ich glaube ich habe 15 Minuten
oder so durchgehalten und danach verdrängt, dass ich den Film geguckt hatte.
Ganz furchtbar. Komplett lieblos.
Ja, es wird einfach halt so dem, eine Sache, die mich besonders verstört ist,
du erinnerst dich hier im Minecraft-Film an diesen einen Retro-Gamer-Typen,
der hier so mit Mantamatte und so Prollig und Jeansjacke und sowas.
Der war sehr drüber.
Exakt denselben Charakter haben wir in diesem Film quasi auch.
Also es gibt gerade irgendwie da so ein Revival von Manta, Mathe,
US-Proll, wo ich auch schwer, also das gibt es alles in dem Buch nicht,
ja keine Sorge, wo ich auch denke so, warum? Warum?
Es gibt doch wirklich Archetypen, die man sich gerne irgendwie da rausholen würde,
aber so diese prolligen Schnauzertragenden, das ist auch nicht irgendwie cool,
wie jetzt irgendwie so die 70er und was man da irgendwie so zeigen könnte,
das ist wirklich schlimm,
ganz schlimm, geht weg davon.
In dem Minecraft-Film ist wenigstens witzig gemeint, die Überzeichnung.
Also ob das jetzt witzig ist, muss jeder für sich entscheiden,
aber ich glaube, das soll lustig sein.
Tja, also finster.
Stimme ist, es gibt dann Leute, die finden das auch lustig.
Ja, gut, vielleicht fehlt uns ja der kulturelle Kontext, mag sein.
Naja, ich meine, wir haben ja jetzt auch schon so Real-Life-Idiocracy am Start.
Vielleicht ist das jetzt die neue Coolness und wir kriegen das nur nicht vernünftig decoded.
Das kann schon sein. Ganz ehrlich, die Realität gerade, die sitze ich gerne aus.
Das ist so wie Butterfly Keyboard und irgendwie Notch. Da muss man dann einfach überstehen.
Ja, zum Beispiel durch Maßnahmen im Heim.
Ich wollte kurz nachtragen, dass ich bei mir jetzt zwei weitere Puzzletelefone
installiert habe. Ihr erinnert euch?
Die guckt mich fragend an.
Das, wo Wasser rauskommt.
Genau, das, wo Wasser rauskommt. Puzzletelefon. Ich kann es ja nochmal kurz
hier einspielen, dass wir das nicht vergessen.
Nennt sie das so?
Ja.
Ich stehe komplett auf dem Schlauch.
Ja, das ist schlecht.
Dann kommst du nicht an die richtigen Stellen mit dem Ding.
Das ist schon mal ein guter Ansatz. Ich habe Ideen, aber mein Webbrowser wehrt
sich gerade Ach Gott, kann man dieses Web ist einfach echt nicht mehr zu benutzen.
Das ist ein bisschen kaputt.
Meine Güte, Gott. Alter, fuck, ey.
Wer hat sich den Mist ausgedacht?
Das ist wirklich zum Heulen. Früher machte man Webseiten einfach auf und gut
ist. So, jetzt probieren wir das nochmal aus.
In Finland we have this thing called Käsisuhku.
A.k.a. Pussy Telephone. This is why we are so happy.
Because we have so clean assholes. Why doesn't every country have this? You know, the.
Using these. They are very handy when you have the squirts.
Ich könnte mir das stundlang immer wieder und immer wieder anschauen.
Das ist einfach so großartig.
Dank des Adapters.
Dank des Adapters und es ist so einfach. Ich hätte jetzt sozusagen eine neue
Wohnung zu bestücken und da muss ich dann erstmal nachrüsten.
Aber ich wollte das nochmal sagen, es gab sehr viel positives Feedback.
Ich hoffe, von verschiedenen Leuten gehört, dass sie jetzt auch so ein Telefon installiert haben.
Du hast doch das Thema jetzt nur aufgebracht, damit du das Video nochmal abspielen kannst.
Das hängt alles ein bisschen miteinander zusammen, aber ich fand auch einfach
das Wort, ich weiß nicht, ob sie wirklich Pussy Telefon sagt,
aber ich will das jetzt einfach glauben, dass es das ist, was sie sagt und weil
die Sache passt einfach super.
Man hat das so in der Hand wie so ein Telefon, aber halt für den speziellen Bereich.
Und das ist der Grund, weshalb sie so glücklich ist.
Ja, und ich auch. Ja, also das macht auf jeden Fall eine Menge aus.
So, wenn er richtig glücklich sein wollt, dann müsst ihr natürlich bei Ralf arbeiten.
So ist es.
Jetzt gibt es einen kurzen Werbeblock.
Genau, kann keiner den Werbe-Jingle einfügen.
Freakshow.
Pimp my Mac. Nein, Pimp my Arbeitsplatz.
Pimp my Arbeitsplatz, genau.
Na komm.
Also, wir starten bei uns an der ZLB gerade ein. Ich würde sagen Moonshot.
ZLB ist?
Zentral- und Landesbibliothek Berlin. Teil des FÖB, Verbund öffentlicher Bibliotheken Berlin.
Hast du noch ein paar Abkürzungen?
Ja, Steko, ständige Kommission.
Föp ist sowieso eine scheiß Abkürzung.
Ja, ich wollte das Thema.
Egal.
Das hatten wir schon. So, dort machen wir jetzt aber ein schönes Moonshot-Projekt,
an dem ich seit etlichen Jahren tüftel und jetzt machen wir es einfach mal.
Und da habe ich zwei Stellen zu besetzen, wo ich denke, dass bei den Hörerinnen
und Hörern da draußen vielleicht der ein oder die andere sich angesprochen fühlen könnte.
Ich werde jetzt gar nicht so sehr ins Detail gehen. In der Beschreibung steht einiges drin.
Wenn ihr Interesse habt, kontaktiert mich. Das müssen wir jetzt hier nicht in
der Bremsung, in der Sendung breit tragen.
Aber ich habe zum einen eine UX-Stelle zu besetzen. Und zwar so ein bisschen
in der Schnittstelle von UX, Design und so quasi einfachen CSS-Theming und Coding.
Und das andere ist eine Produktmanager- Innenstelle.
Also nicht Projektmanagement, sondern Produktmanagement. Und die ist insbesondere
interessant, weil das eine E14-Stelle ist, was im öffentlichen Dienst ungewöhnlich ist.
Und was noch ungewöhnlicher ist, ist, dass die ohne Personalverantwortung ist.
Das heißt also, die ist einfach so an sich eine E14, was sehr,
sehr selten ist, auch im deutschen Bibliothekswesen.
Das heißt also, das sind zwei coole Stellen in einem saukolen Projekt direkt bei mir.
Und wenn ihr Bock darauf habt, diese Welt zu einem besseren Ort zu machen und
in Berlin richtig was zu rocken, dann guckt euch das mal genauer an.
Es ist allerdings wirklich, man muss in Berlin sitzen. Das ist nicht,
weil wir irgendwie daran glauben, dass Homeoffice nicht funktioniert oder sowas,
sondern weil es gerade die Verdrahtung und Verschweißung von digitaler Welt
und physisch-realen Bibliotheksstandorten bedeutet.
Das heißt, man wird dann auch viel zu echten Bibliotheken in Berlin reisen und
dort vor Ort mit Leuten was Digitales machen.
Und darum muss man schon dafür sich nach Berlin begeben. Das ist quasi der einzige
Hake und es ist zwei Jahre befristet, aber wenn das Ganze gut läuft,
bin ich sehr optimistisch, dass man das auch verstetigen kann, das Ganze.
Ja, dann klingt sozusagen auch der Arbeitsplatz wie eine Freakshow,
sozusagen so eine Dauerbeschallung.
Ja, gucken wir mal.
Also wenn ihr da draußen irgendwo Leute kennt, die gerade was suchen und auf
die eins dieser beiden Profile hier passt, schaut euch das mal genauer an. Reicht es weiter?
Ich bedanke mich und über das Projekt selber, wenn das ein bisschen ins Rollen
kommt, werde ich dann hier sicherlich nochmal ausführlicher berichten,
weil wir haben da Wildes vor.
So, jetzt kommen wir gleich auf das Apple-Thema. Kurz vorher wollte ich nochmal
darauf hinweisen, dass Bill Atkinson verstorben ist.
Das erfüllt mich jetzt nicht mit großer Trauer, weil er war ja auch alt und
hat sein Leben sicherlich ausreichend gelebt.
Dann muss man nicht mehr trauern, oder?
Ja, also ich kannte ihn ja jetzt nicht persönlich.
Aber es hat mich sozusagen dann daran erinnert, was er denn der Welt so hinterlassen hat.
Und Bill Atkinson war irgendwie so irgendwas in der Größenordnung 40-Star Mitarbeiter
bei Apple, also relativ früh mit dabei und hat also den Macintosh ganz entscheidend mitgeprägt.
Unter anderem ist er für die Software MacPaint verantwortlich. Verantwortlich.
Er hat auch das Grafik-Subsystem Quickdraw wohl im Wesentlichen vorangetrieben.
Aber wo ich ganz persönlich was der Grund war, warum ich das erwähnen möchte,
er war ja auch der Autor von Hypercard.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr mit Hypercard mal gearbeitet habt.
Aber du hast es geschrieben.
Müsst spielen gilt nicht, als mit Hypercard gearbeitet haben.
Ne, was hat denn das?
Müsst war in Hypercard geschrieben.
Wow.
Müsst war in HyperCard geschrieben?
Müsst war in HyperCard.
Oh, das stimmt. Da wurde mithilfe von HyperCard entwickelt, heißt es hier.
Also das ist jetzt die Rantam von, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Ja, doch, doch.
Okay, wie auch immer.
Also das Original natürlich nur auf Mac und dann wurde es portiert und so weiter.
Ja, aber es war,
Und insofern finde ich, also es ist,
HyperCard wäre damit jetzt nicht gearbeitet, also wie gesagt.
Uralte Software, aber ich habe auch nicht so viel damit gemacht,
aber was ich immer mochte war, dieses Programmieren von Anwendungen ohne jetzt
irgendwie groß mit Programmiersprachen zu arbeiten.
Und das hat HyperCard sehr früh geschafft.
Das heißt, man hatte einfach eine visuelle Umgebung, konnte sozusagen mit Karten
arbeiten und dadurch einfach coole,
kleine Anwendungen bauen und ich mag einfach die Idee, dass man einfach auch
visuell interaktiv selber Sachen machen kann.
Ich habe dann später sehr viel mit FileMaker gearbeitet, das gibt es ja auch
immer noch und mit FileMaker war ich auch extrem glücklich, weil das eben zumindest
so in nicht vernetzten Zeiten,
es gab einfach keine einfachere Methode mit Datenbanken zu arbeiten.
Und bei FileMaker hattest du quasi so deine Oberfläche im Fenster,
dann hast du halt gesagt,
hier Edit, dann hast du dein Layout bearbeitet, hast irgendwelche Felder in
deiner Tabelle angelegt und die
dann einfach so als Layoutfelder auf den Bildschirm geklebt und sagst so,
ja hier will ich das jetzt eingeben und dann sagst du, zack,
Return und dann hast du automatisch quasi ein Edit-Fenster für Datenbank gehabt.
Und mit HyperCard war es halt auch ähnlich.
Also Hyper, auch im Sinne von Hyperlinks, du konntest halt irgendwie Buttons
machen, von dort nach dort sprengen und so visuelle Anwendungen machen.
Und das ist, glaube ich, auch eine Erwähnung wert, dass jetzt hier quasi jemand
von uns gegangen ist, der so ganz maßgeblich so die Softwareentwicklung auf
vielen Ebenen, speziell eben die grafische Seite vorangebracht hat.
Unglaublich, du hast recht, FileMaker
gibt es immer noch. Und es gibt die Firma Claris auch immer noch.
Die auch immer noch Apple gehört, aber die so ihr eigenes Ding macht.
Weil FileMaker ist so ein eigener Business-Bereich.
Es gibt Leute, die nutzen das einfach, weil es halt einfach besser funktioniert
jetzt, als irgendwie alles in Excel abzulegen.
Wenn das etwas ist, was viele Leute machen.
Ja, wobei, also interessant fand ich ja das Statement zu Excel,
Excel ist ja wahrscheinlich die am meisten verbreitete funktionale Sprache.
Was ist denn daran bitte funktional?
Ja, alles. Also es sind ja nur Funktionen.
Ja, schon. Aber du kannst den Wert jeder Speicherzelle jederzeit ändern.
Da ist ja nichts funktional dran.
Naja, rein technisch betrachtet schon. Aber müssen wir nicht weiter diskutieren.
Auf jeden Fall ist das für viele Leute auch so die Visual Database of Choice.
Und da kann man dann auch Fileback annehmen.
Naja, anyway, lass uns zu Apple kommen, denn Apple kommt ja zu uns und möchte
uns unsere User-Interfaces wegnehmen.
Es war Worldwide Developers Conference.
Und wie immer haben alle Apple-Apologeten gespannt, um 19 Uhr am Montag dieser
Zeit der sogenannten Keynote gelauscht.
Du auch, Roddy?
Und geguckt.
Und was war so dein Eindruck?
Der Gesamteindruck?
Ja, der Gesamteindruck. In welchem Zustand?
Mein Gesamteindruck war, dass Apple sich so weit mit dem Apple-Intelligence-Zeug
verhoben hat, dass sie jetzt mal echte Features bringen mussten.
Und da sind sehr viele Details drin gewesen, wo ich mir gedacht habe,
das hättet ihr auch vor zehn Jahren schon machen können.
Aber gut, dass sie es wenigstens jetzt macht. Das ist der eine Eindruck.
Und der andere Eindruck ist, ich glaube, sie haben inzwischen verstanden,
dass sie das iPad wirklich pro machen müssen.
Sonst gehen die Verkäufe nicht nach oben.
Und dass der Laptop als solcher eventuell auch am Ende des Produktzyklus ist,
so industrieweit gesehen.
und man bekommt das Gefühl, sie wollen jetzt iPadOS und macOS zu einem Betriebssystem
machen, beziehungsweise ich gehe davon aus, dass sie iPadOS irgendwann aus dem
Fenster werfen und sagen,
das ist jetzt alles macOS und ihr habt jetzt Touchscreen und ob da eine Tastatur
verbaut ist oder nicht, das werden wir dann sehen.
Das war mein Eindruck, besonders nachdem ich die Sachen probiert habe,
aber wir können auch in die Details gehen.
Reif, dein erster Eindruck?
Also ich war viel besser gestimmt als vor einem Jahr.
Wir erinnern uns die Vaporware KI Keynote, wo ich ja damals auch im Team Max
war, dass man wenig davon sehen wird und da fand ich, war das jetzt schon ein
sehr anderer Entwurf, den sie hier gemacht haben.
Ich habe da viele kleine, sinnvolle, schöne nützliche Features gesehen,
werden wir gleich vielleicht auch das eine oder andere ansprechen.
Ich fand, die Keynote insgesamt hatte auch irgendwie einen besseren Flow. Das war alles viel,
praxisnäher. Ich fand das gut.
Ja, und nicht so viele Superlative.
Ja. Also hat bei mir gut funktioniert.
Und naja, über die Designgeschichten müssen wir gleich nochmal separat reden.
Da habe ich natürlich Meinungen zu und ihr wahrscheinlich auch.
Luca, hast du dir das live angeschaut?
Ich habe es mir auch angeschaut. Nicht bis zum Ende, aber ich würde mich da reif anschließen.
Ich fand das jetzt doch deutlich interessanter als erwartet und hatte nicht
den Eindruck, dass es alles Mist ist, was die machen.
Na dann schauen wir doch mal, was so toll war.
Also ich würde sagen, man muss über den Eingangs-Joke sprechen.
Ich fand den weniger cringe als die Jahre davor.
Was meinst du jetzt, diese F1?
Formel 1, Hair Force 1.
Also, ich fand, es ist eine sehr coole Idee, so den,
wie heißt da das ganze Center eigentlich,
das ist, also wie heißt der Gebäude, Apple Park, dieses runde UFO,
einfach zu sagen, so obendrauf ist eine Formel 1 Bahn und mit einem Button können
wir die zwischen Solarpanel und Formel 1 hin und her schalten.
Das war ich dann auch mit am coolsten, muss ich am Ende das wieder auf Solar zurückflippen lassen.
Das einzige Störgefühl, was
ich da hatte und da könnt ihr mich jetzt gerne alle wieder für prügeln.
Ich finde ja Formel 1 ist so ein bisschen aus der Zeit gefallen, oder?
So dieses High Octane und Umweltverschmutzen und laut und schnell.
Ich bin da voll bei dir.
Ob das jetzt so richtig die Apple-Vibes atmet. Also mir ist klar,
die haben da jetzt ihren Film und finden den irgendwie cool und will den promoten und sowas.
Aber eigentlich hätte ich jetzt so Formel 1 und Apple fand ich jetzt nicht so richtig.
Da sehe ich halt eher ein Elektroauto, wenn die jetzt also da die Elektro-Formel 1 gepitcht hätten.
Das haben sie ja hinterher so ein bisschen aufgegriffen, indem man dann da in
seinem Elektro-Bobby-Car irgendwie im weiteren Verlauf durch die Gegend gedüst ist.
Also ich glaube, die haben die Ebene schon auch irgendwie geahnt.
Aber es hat mich jetzt auch nicht total rausgezogen und da war ich jetzt auch
nicht so vogue, dass ich gesagt habe, das geht ja gar nicht und ich schalte
jetzt diese Keynote aus, aber ein bisschen strange fand ich das,
dass jetzt Formel 1 kommt.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich sehe das genauso. Also Formel 1, die Autos sehen scheiße
aus, sie klingen scheiße, sie sind einfach nur fürchterliche Dieven.
Ich meine Heizdecken für die Reifen.
bitte dich. Ein Rennauto, das eine Heizdecke braucht, was ist denn das für eine Rennsportart?
Ja, man kann sich das ja immer schönreden mit, da werden dann doch wieder die
Durchbrüche, ja ähnlich wie in der Raumfahrt, du brauchst halt irgendwie so
diese völligen Cutting-Edge-Sachen, damit das dann irgendwie der Fortschritt
auch zu uns Normalsterblichen runterringen.
Die touchieren sich ein bisschen und dann bleiben von dem Auto irgendwie nur noch Kleinteile übrig.
Dann ist der Kram halt auch irgendwie hart reguliert und es ist alles gespeckt,
so das hier darf nur so viel Gramm wiegen und so weiter und so fort.
Also ich sage nicht, dass die Formel-1-Fahrer nicht wirklich Exzeptionelles leisten, ganz sicher.
Aber den Sport an sich, nein.
Und sie fahren immer nur am Kreis.
Ich liebe bei Mario Kart auch so. Nicht bei Mario Kart.
Also die sportliche Leistung ist sicherlich...
Nein, die stelle ich nicht in Abrede.
Ich auch nicht. Die ist sicherlich da. Das heißt ja nicht gleich,
dass man den Sport interessant finden muss.
Ich finde ihn vor allem so ich finde ihn sowohl als Vor-Ort-Sport als auch als
Fernsehsport unfassbar langweilig.
Also es ist einfach ein Formel-1-Rennen zuzuschauen. Also da kann man sich auch
in den Garten setzen und den Blumen beim Wachsen zuschauen.
Naja, alle warten ja nur auf die Crashs, was ich okay finde.
Naja. Also ich oute mich mal, es gab eine Zeit, da habe ich ganz gerne Formel 1 geguckt.
Warum?
Das war so in der Mittelfase von Michael Schumacher, würde ich mal sagen,
wo also wirklich noch nicht klar war, so wird er immer gewinnen und ist er jetzt
der Beste oder nicht und so.
Und wenn man dann eine Zeit lang diesem Thema folgt und so über ein,
zwei Saisons mehr oder weniger alle Rennen guckt, dann kommst du halt auch wie
bei anderen Sportarten auch dann halt auf so eine Ebene,
dass du schon oh, das ist ein taktischer Fehler hier mit dem Tank,
das hätten sie mal besser nicht gemacht und da dauert der Reifentext zu lange
und war das jetzt hier nicht ziemlich unfair, wie er da gerade aus der Boxengasse
wieder rausgefahren ist.
Also der Sport hat mit Sicherheit genug Komplexität,
dass man sich da gut unterhalten lassen von kann, jenseits von dieser rein,
alles ist schnell und laut und aufregend Mechanik.
Also der Sport als solches ist schon sehr komplex.
Und wie bei allen komplexen Dingen, als Nerd kann man daran Freude haben.
Ich finde das nicht langweilig.
Aber du brauchst halt ein bisschen Einarbeitung, damit man diese ganzen Ebenen,
wie beim Fußball auch, 2.29 mit dem Ball hinterher, was soll denn daran jetzt irgendwie cool sein?
Und dann musst du denen halt erstmal abseits erklären.
Jetzt machst du ja den Fass auf.
Aber Tim, können wir uns darauf einigen, dass eigentlich bei jedem Sport dann
doch irgendwo eine Komplexitätsebene ist, die sich dem Laien nicht sofort erschließt
und der dann Dinge langweilig findet,
die dann Fans des Sportes überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen können,
was daran langweilig sein soll. Das ist doch alles hochspannend.
Das ist doch bei jedem Sport so.
Wir verzetteln uns direkt gleich vor dem Thema.
Ich sag mal, schade, dass wir
nie zu viel Medizin kommen, weil wir einfach über Formel 1 reden müssen.
Ja, mit so einem persönlichen Vorlieben und wie man das jetzt empfindet, das ist ja das eine.
Ich will es mal kurz auch mal wieder auf den Kontext dieser Keynote bringen.
Was mich halt persönlich so ein bisschen aneckt, ist halt, naja,
okay, sie promoten halt jetzt ihren Film.
Sie promoten halt ihr Apple TV, was ich ja ehrlich gesagt als Service ganz schön
gut finde. Ich hatte ja hier ausführlich über die Severance und so weiter und
auch einige andere Serien.
Also es ist schon so ein Premium-Produkt, was sie am Start haben und dass sie
jetzt so eine Developer-Kino damit dann so verbinden, ist halt wieder so ein
weiteres Ding mit Hallo,
herzlich willkommen zur Entwickler-Konferenz, die Veranstaltung,
wo es um eine Menge geht, aber nicht um Entwickler.
also ja meinetwegen ist nach zwei Minuten vorbei war auch ganz lustig ich fand
es letztes Jahr lustiger sie geben sich da eine Menge Mühe.
Passt schon ich sag mal so, wenn ich mir vorstelle wie ein Microsoft oder ein
Nvidia oder ein Google so eine Werbe Preview gemacht hätte, dann muss ich sagen,
war das völlig in Ordnung,
Anyway Anyway.
Lass uns zum Inhalt kommen, dessen was vorgestellt wurde, damit wir hier überhaupt mal vorankommen.
Und zwar ging es los relativ klar von Anfang an mit wir bauen alles um.
Liquid Glass ist jetzt sozusagen unser Thema und wir werden sowohl iOS, iPadOS, macOS,
TVOS und WatchOS umbauen und naja auch VisionOS, aber man muss sagen von VisionOS,
VisionOS betrifft es noch am wenigsten, weil das sah ja auch schon vorher so
aus, also im Wesentlichen zumindest,
da hat sich jetzt auch nicht so viel getan. ähm.
Vielleicht können wir kurz mal definieren, wie sie eigentlich jetzt auf dieses
Liquid Glass gekommen sind oder was so quasi der visuelle Grundgedanke davon ist.
Und das finde ich, das haben sie wirklich sehr Apple-Style schön gemacht.
Also in der Sache wahrscheinlich totaler Quatsch, aber es sah einfach cute aus.
UX-Labor, dieses Design-Labor, was es mit Sicherheit so nicht gibt.
Nein, und das gibt's jetzt, weil sie es für den Film gebraucht haben.
Für die Fernsehteams, die sie da jetzt durchschleusen können.
Und dann waren dann halt diese ganzen quasi Nutzeroberflächen so auf großen,
schönen Aufdrucken auf den Tischen und dann haben sie echte,
Glaselemente darüber geschoben, die dann halt irgendwie so Linsenfunktionen hatten.
Und dann konnte man sehen, ah, wenn ich jetzt also eine Riesenlupe habe,
die so ungefähr diese Form hat, so verschiebt sich das dann.
Und dann konnte man quasi eben die Verbindung herstellen.
Und genau diese Physik, die es in echt gibt, hier seht ihr es ja,
hier ist das Labor, in dem wir sowas testen.
Und genau diese Physik haben wir jetzt ins Digitale übertragen,
dass jetzt also auch alles nach Glas aussieht und optische Effekte eintreten, wie Glas sie hat.
Also Verstärkung, Verzerrung, Abschattung,
Milchglaseffekte und das Liquid kommt dann noch rein, dass dieses Glas dann
halt seine Form verändern kann, wenn es gebraucht wird und aus der einen Search Bar in...
Und hier ist Spotlight, werden dann plötzlich mehrere Bubbles,
weil dann dieses flüssige Glas sich dann halt abspaltet davon und man dann viele kleine Bubbles hat.
Das ist letztendlich so die visuelle Grundgeschichte, die sie da erzählen.
und als ich das gesehen habe, dachte ich so das ist ja schön,
ihr kommt wieder zurück zu Aqua, da hatten wir das alles schon Aqua zu neu.
Aqua war halt alles vorgerendert, da hat es halt genau diese Bubbles und genau
diese Elemente und die waren natürlich alle hart gecodet in Pixeln,
damals glaube ich auch noch keine Vektoren, so und jetzt haben sie halt die
Hardware, dass sie das Ganze halt in Echtzeit und wir tun nicht so, als ob,
das jetzt wie Glas eine Brechung machen würde, sondern das ist jetzt in echt.
So, diese Geschichte fand ich erstmal ganz cool.
Kann man machen. So, und dann haben sie es halt für verschiedene Betriebssysteme
runtergebrochen und da glaube ich, bin ich jetzt sehr unterschiedlich zufrieden
mit dem, was da jetzt schon in den Betas zu sehen ist.
Aber da können wir jetzt ja mal gucken, wer was auf welchem Gerät hat und vielleicht
schmeißen wir das ein oder andere dann auch mal auf den Beamer und versuchen das...
Damit die Hörer das nicht sehen können.
Versuchen das zu beschreiben, was uns da stört oder gefällt.
weil ich habe so ein paar Punkte, wo ich echt Fragen habe.
Ich auch. Ja, vor allem Beamer, also Luca kann den Beamer jetzt nicht sehen,
das ist jetzt eine weitere Herausforderung. Komplexitäts-Ebene.
Also doch Screenshots in den Chat.
Wir machen das jetzt nur, naja, ich meine, bleiben wir vielleicht erstmal bei
dieser Philosophie und was wir sozusagen davon halten. Ich muss sagen,
abgesehen davon, dass ich den Eindruck habe, dass ich das auf den unterschiedlichen
Plattformen sehr unterschiedlich.
Niederschlägt, sagen wir es mal so, ist natürlich eine dieser,
Philosophien, die da so hintersteckt, ist ja, Glas hat ja den Vorteil,
dass man ja den Content darunter sieht und wir wollen ja irgendwie ganz viel
Content, dass ja dein Content und überhaupt und überall Content und Content und Content.
Und das nimmt ja irgendwie an, das steckt ja sozusagen in dieser Aussage mit
drin, dass das gut ist, dass überall der Content dahinter ist und das User-Interface
so da drauf liegt, aber du überall diesen Content noch siehst.
Weil den Content sehen willst du ja eigentlich nicht, weil du hast ja ein User-Interface-Element,
wo was anderes drauf ist.
Trotzdem möchtest du aber, dass der Content irgendwie da ist.
Er soll aber auch nicht da sein und da sein gleichzeitig.
Das ist ja irgendwie erstmal ein Widerspruch und die klassischen User-Interfaces
sind halt irgendwie opak.
Dann hat man eben mit verschiedenen Ansätzen das über die Jahre probiert und
Apple hat ja auch mehrfach schon,
wir hatten das, gut Aqua war jetzt nicht durchsichtig, aber wir hatten ja so
ähnliche Allüren im User Interface in der Entwicklung auch schon gehabt,
dass eben so Transparenzen mit reinkommen, dass der Hintergrund auch bei so weißen Finder Fenstern,
irgendwie zu sehen ist und dann haben wir das immer gehabt, neues Betriebssystem, erste Beta.
Viel zu viel von allem und zwei, drei Versionen spätestens beim,
also zwei, drei Developer-Versionen später oder eben spätestens beim Release
war das dann alles so weit wieder zurückgefahren,
dass davon eigentlich fast kaum irgendwas übrig bleibt.
Ja, nicht während den Betas, aber durch die Major-Releases hindurch.
Immer mal wieder hier weniger und da weniger und dort weniger.
Auch das, aber auch schon vorher.
Und Aqua hatte durchaus transparent, also die Titelleisten der Fenster waren
transparent und die waren am Anfang auch wirklich viel zu transparent.
Man hat gar nicht gesehen, welches Fenster ist denn jetzt selektiert.
So transparent waren die.
Genau. Also immer stellte sich sehr schnell heraus, dass das einfach Probleme
hat im, wie heißt das so schön, im UX.
Also meine User Experience und ich will jetzt nicht Benutzererfahrung sagen,
weil dieses Wort gehört einfach in die Tonne.
Benutzererfahrung.
Ja, Benutzererlebnis ist aber auch ein Scheißwort. Benutzer ist auch ein Scheißwort.
In Deutschland haben wir überhaupt nur...
Ist besser als Bediener.
Oder Anwender.
Anwendererlebnis ist alles, es funktioniert einfach alles nicht.
Deutsch gibt nicht genug her für die moderne Welt.
Anwendererlebnis hast du, wenn du mit der Bahn fährst und dir diese Umfrage stellen.
Darf ich Ihnen Fragen stellen hier zum Anwendererlebnis?
Naja, okay. So macht man seine Erfahrung sozusagen mit dem Erlebnis.
Worauf wollte ich jetzt hinaus? Ach ja, dass so ein Problem ist und wo man es
halt besonders merkt und wo man das auch schon war das letztes Jahr oder vorletztes
Jahr, da haben sie doch auch schon mal probiert den Safari,
so den Content da oben mit reinzuschieben und alle nur so habt ihr sie noch
alle und das war das, was dann wirklich kurz vor dem Final Release noch gekillt wurde.
Genau, das war würde ich sagen, ein der wenigen Fälle, die sie während der Betas
noch wirklich rausgemacht haben.
Ansonsten bin ich eher bei Roddy, dass sie in den Betas noch relativ wenig eigentlich
anpassen, das macht mir gerade auch Sorge und dann in den nachfolgenden Minor-Releases
nachgeschoben haben. Aber wir werden sehen.
Was hier passiert. Ja, wir werden uns ja alle anzuschreien. Und ich muss sagen,
der Safari, so wie sie ihn jetzt wieder auf Macintosh haben,
hat wieder genau dasselbe Problem.
Also so geht es einfach überhaupt nicht. Aber bleiben wir vielleicht nochmal
kurz beim Design-Konzept an sich.
Wo ich mitgehe, ist, dass sie halt viele Animationen, also dieser Liquid-Aspekt,
also User-Interface-Transitionen Positionen auch als solche zu sehen sind und
dass sie das so generisch gemacht haben,
und in diesem Bubble-Effekt und mit diesem was weiß ich, Kontextmenü wird aufgerufen,
dann woppelt das noch so ein bisschen.
Einerseits also diese Liquidität, das finde ich gut, weil das macht die Sache,
nachvollziehbar, nachforschbar, nach, ja, auch so.
Ein bisschen spielerischer, nahbarer.
Spielerisch finde ich halt,
kein gutes Argument, aber wir kennen das alle, wenn jetzt so ein User-Interface
so knallhart ist und du drückst irgendwas und es sofort ist irgendwie alles
anders, dann weißt du gar nicht, oh Gott,
war das eben auch schon so? Wo kommt denn das jetzt irgendwie her?
Und wenn Dinge einfach auch Weg haben, Zeit brauchen, Fenster sich langsam öffnen,
schon der allererste Macintosh, wenn du eine App gestartet hast, hast du so dieses.
Rechteck, was sich was so hoch gewachsen ist.
Und das macht es erfüllbar, was dahinter jetzt tatsächlich passiert.
Und jetzt hast du das eben auch bei diesen kleinen User-Interface-Veränderungen.
Das finde ich gut. Und diese optische Komponente mit dem Glas,
wie gesagt, problematisch finde ich dieses Durchscheinen von Content.
Nice finde ich aber eben so dieses Ding mit,
dass das Licht sich einfach so komplex in diesen Dingern bricht Und du da also
wirklich so realistische Glasreflexionen auf einmal hast,
mal von den Verzerrungen mal abgesehen, aber so allein diese Lichtkanten und
dass das Ganze dadurch einfach so eine Griffigkeit,
so eine Physikalität bekommt.
Und das ist auf jeden Fall ein Zeichen, dass sie hier mal wieder so alles auf
11 drehen und dass sie alles rausholen, was sie mit ihrer Plattform derzeit auch so leisten können.
Ob das dann for the better ist, das muss ich dann im Detail entscheiden.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich hatte ja, es wurde ja vorher schon gerüchtet,
dass es ein großes Redesign geben wird und ich hatte ja ehrlich gesagt Angst,
dass wir wieder in so eine iOS 7 Situation laufen.
wo plötzlich alles anders ist, alles minimalistisch und sie auch ganz zentrale
User Experience Momente über Bord geworfen haben.
Das haben sie ja alles rückgebaut. Zwar sehr langsam, aber das haben sie ja alles rückgebaut.
Und aus der Warte muss ich sagen, okay, ich kann damit erstmal leben,
da muss man sich dran gewöhnen.
Besonders wie das Zeug auf dem Mac aussieht. Also ich finde diesen Tab View,
Also du hast irgendwie die etwas größeren Bubbles, wo die User Elefmente drin
sind und hast da drunter die etwas kleineren Bubbles, die irgendwie die Tabs
darstellen, also Safari zum Beispiel,
das, keine Ahnung, irgendwie das schmerzt mir in den Augen, also dass sie da
so mehrere Kurvenradien so gegeneinander gehauen haben, das passt irgendwie
für meine Augen nicht, aber vielleicht ist das jetzt auch.
Also ich habe es jetzt bisher nur auf macOS hier installiert und ich habe vor
allen Dingen ein Problem mit Konsistenz,
weil ich finde egal, was du jetzt so an Designänderungen machst,
du musst es halt irgendwie konsistent über verschiedene Apps machen,
sodass du eigentlich überall denselben Look und Feel und dieselbe Logik hast.
und da habe ich jetzt einfach hier mal ein beispiel wo ich denke was was zur
hölle und ich glaube ich schon hilfreich wenn zumindest wir drei es sehen können
ich gucke mal ob ich mich jetzt hier auf den beamer verbinden kann und zwar ist das apple mail,
Was ja nun nicht so, die, kannst du mal, ich müsste jetzt eigentlich verbunden sein, sagt er mir hier.
Was mit meinem Apple TV, das ist gerade nicht aktiv hier.
Achso, ich bin jetzt auf Beamer drauf hier.
Ja, aber wir schauen nicht, ja der heißt Beamer, aber das ist nicht der Beamer.
Der Beamer ist jetzt hier mein weiterer Macintosh Content, aber ich kann,
Iris habe ich noch zur Auswahl hier. Nee, nee, nee, bleib mal bitte, bleiben Sie bitte dran.
Ich kann das hier mal hochholen.
So, also zwei Programme, die ich jetzt hier mal kurz besprechen möchte, ist Apple Mail.
Das kennen wir wahrscheinlich alle, die Apple nutzen und das andere sind Apple Notizen.
Also zwei Programme, die nun mal echt irgendwie bekannt sind und die vor allen
Dingen von ihrem Grundlayout her extrem ähnlich aussehen.
Und wenn wir gleich hier auf dem Beamer sind, würde ich diesen Punkt auch machen.
Jetzt erzähl doch erst mal so, Luca kann das sowieso nicht sehen und die Hörer
auch nicht. Du mal mit deinem visuellen.
Also beide Programme haben eigentlich exakt dasselbe Grundlayout.
Man hat links eine Spalte, in der man Ordner hat.
Bei Apple Mail sind es halt die verschiedenen Posteingangsordner und bei Notizen
sind es links irgendwie die iCloud Notizen und neue Ordner, die man sich anlegen kann und ähnliches.
Ja, das Ding heißt Zeitbar oder so.
Also diese Sidebar-Links, genau. Dann ist rechts daneben die nächste Spalte,
die auch bei beiden sehr ähnlich ist.
Bei Notizen hat man dort die einzelnen Notizen, jeweils von dem Ordner,
der links ausgewählt ist.
Und bei Apple Mail hat man die einzelnen Mails, die halt von dem Ordner links
ausgewählt. So und rechts daneben ist dann der eigentliche Content-Bereich,
in dem also der Inhalt angezeigt wird, entweder der Notiz oder halt der E-Mail.
Also wirklich eins zu eins eigentlich dieselbe Grundlogik.
Gut, konsistent, hurra, Daumen hoch.
So und jetzt guckt man sich aber an, wie jetzt dieser neue Liquid Glass-Bereich.
Diese Design-Philosophie auf diese beiden Apps gelegt ist und dann sieht man
komplett unterschiedlich.
Das heißt, in Notizen habe ich oben eine feste Kopfleiste, in der die ganzen
Icons drin sind und diese Kopfleiste selber ist kein Stück transparent.
Das heißt, da ist noch nicht mal irgendein Milchglaseffekt.
Und wenn ich also den Inhalt der Notiz unten durchschiebe, verschwindet die
einfach unterhalb dieser Kopfleiste, so wie es bisher auch immer war.
Die einzelnen Buttons in dieser Leiste sind dann allerdings wie jetzt so eine
Liquid Glass Bubble halt so oben drüber gemalt.
Aber dadurch, dass sich unten drunter der Content nie ändert,
weil ja die Kopfleiste stabil ist, habe ich diese ganzen fancy 3D-Effekte gar nicht.
Das heißt also, ich habe überhaupt gar keine Rückmeldung, dass es irgendwas
mit Glas zu tun haben könnte, dass sich der Untergrund nie ändert und ich nie eine Animation habe.
Das heißt, es ist einfach eine statische Buttonleiste.
Gut zu sehen, aber halt ein bisschen langweilig, halt so wie bisher.
So und bei Mail ist es komplett anders.
Da habe ich quasi dieselben Icons an derselben Stelle, aber ohne diese Leiste unten drunter.
Das heißt also, die sind dann halbtransparent und dort habe ich dann diese ganzen
Glaseffekte mit den ganzen Verzerrungen und da spiegeln sich Dinge und so weiter.
Und wenn ich jetzt auch so einen Mail-Inhalt durchschiebe, dann sehe ich den durch die Buttons.
Bis hin dazu, und das finde ich ehrlich gesagt eine totale UX-Katastrophe,
wenn plötzlich mal ein dunkler Abschnitt in meiner E-Mail ist,
switcht das System quasi vom Night-Mode in den Dark-Mode um und die Icons werden schwarz.
So. Also, hier weiß. Das heißt also, ich habe plötzlich, obwohl ich nur,
Bin ich jetzt da drauf?
Ich habe es gerade unter iPadOS auch mal nachgeguckt, da scheint es mir konsistenzer zu sein.
Also wir müssen jetzt vielleicht auch noch dazu sagen, es ist nun mal die erste Beta.
Es ist die erste Beta, es kann sein, dass sie das alles noch reparieren.
So, okay, jetzt bin ich zumindest hier auf dem Beamer schon mal drauf.
Tim, jetzt kannst du auch hier nachvollziehen, das ist jetzt die Leiste,
wie wir sie in Notizen haben.
konstanter Hintergrund, Buttons einfach oben drüber mit ein bisschen Schatten
so und genau derselbe Aufbau in Mail und hier habe ich halt jetzt diesen ganzen,
Foo mit dem Durchschein und hier haben wir den Effekt.
Ja, ich glaube den Hintergrund und es switcht in den Night Mode um.
So und das und sowas habe ich an zig Stellen, wo ich den Eindruck habe,
da ist jetzt, eigentlich haben sie eine Designphilosophie, aber die ist überhaupt
nicht konsequent über die Apps ausgerollt.
Ja, aber das liegt glaube ich daran, dass die Notizen-App ist eindeutig eine
iOS-App, die sie auf macOS portiert haben, als iOS-App.
Und die Mail-App, ich meine, die ist aus Next-Step-Zeiten.
Das ist keine Multi-Plattform-App wahrscheinlich, im Apple-Sprech.
Nee, also keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel Aufwand es ist,
die nochmal ordentlich in Swift UI nachzuprogrammieren.
Das werden sie früher oder später tun.
Aber du kannst davon ausgehen, dass die beiden Apps wahrscheinlich in unterschiedlicher
Technologie entstanden sind und deswegen sie das mit der Konsistenz noch nicht
hundertprozentig haben.
Aber ich würde auch davon ausgehen, dass sie wahrscheinlich,
also jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass sie in macOS weniger Aufwand reinstecken
als in iOS und iPadOS, hat man so das Gefühl in letzter Zeit,
dass sie das noch nachziehen. Vielen Dank.
Wir werden sehen. Das zweite Grundproblem, was ich habe mit dem ganzen Design,
ist diese totale Kontrastlosigkeit der einzelnen Elemente untereinander.
Also hier diese linke Seitenleiste bei beiden Apps, die ist eigentlich ein ganz
leicht anderer Farbton als dann die anderen Spalten, damit sich das so ein bisschen abhebt.
Aber das ist so ein Müh, dass also an dem Beamer hier sieht man jetzt überhaupt
keinen Unterschied, weil die ja meistens sowieso ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten haben irgendwie.
Aber selbst jetzt hier auf meinem MacBook Pro High-End Monitor muss man also
wirklich, müsste man eigentlich mit einem Pixel-Selektor rangehen,
um zu gucken, wie viel Nuancen Unterschied da jetzt der Farbwert hat.
Und ich finde, dadurch nehmen sie sich die Möglichkeit, die ganze GUI,
wenn sie jetzt ohnehin schon mit Ebenenlogik arbeiten, hätte man da die einzelnen
Ebenen noch einfach nochmal deutlich klarer herausarbeiten müssen.
Jetzt hat man so angedeutete Doppelstrukturen plötzlich überall,
die die Sache komisch machen.
Ralf, ganz ehrlich, es ist ein bisschen müßig, jetzt wirklich über diesen aktuellen
Stand dieser Developer-Meta 1 irgendwas festzumachen.
Ich denke, das Einzige, was sich hier lohnt, sind die konzeptionellen,
generellen Entscheidungen, die sie gefallen haben, dass man die jetzt bewertet.
Weil ob jetzt irgendwie die Farbe dann in der nächsten Version ein bisschen
besser gedimmt ist und dann gefällt dir das wieder, weißt du,
also das führt uns jetzt… Ja.
Aber wie lange haben sie daran jetzt schon geschraubt und sie bringen es jetzt
raus und eigentlich sind das Dinge, die sehen alles. Also alle schreiben dieselben Punkte.
Das machen sie, aber es ist nicht raus, sondern es ist eine Entwicklerversion
und sie wissen natürlich, dass sie jetzt erstmal Feedback von Entwicklern bekommen
und sonstigen Freaks wie uns.
Das Ding ist, wenn du eine Entscheidung machen musst,
Du weißt, generell wollen wir aber in diese Richtung. Und wie lieferst du das jetzt aus?
Dann lieferst du natürlich erstmal die extremste Variante.
Tone Down geht immer noch. Und das war eigentlich immer das,
was wir jetzt in den letzten Jahren gesehen haben.
Und von daher mag ich diesen aktuellen Zustand von Farbtönung ehrlich gesagt nicht bewerten,
weil das bringt uns nirgendwo hin, sondern wir müssen uns über die konzeptionellen
Ideen generell unterhalten und was ich für ein Problem habe,
generell mit dem Ansatz von Liquid Glass, habe ich schon gesagt,
dieses Dogma mit mehr Raum für Content.
Dass der Content und das User-Interface, also die Grundidee ist ja, alles ist gelayert.
Layer, Layer, Layer. Sogar die Icons sind jetzt gelayert.
Also dieses Betriebssystem-Release von macOS zwingt ja jetzt alle,
nicht nur von macOS, sondern generell, alle müssen ihre Icons neu machen.
Aber die finde ich geil, die Icons. Das dachte ich eigentlich gerade.
Ich finde, das ist konzeptionell eine der Sachen, die mir richtig gut gefallen. Die Icons.
Ja, aber so groß ist die Änderung nicht.
Die Änderung ist massiv.
Nein.
Aber hallo.
Das Icon mal eben neu machen, ist für einen guten Designer kein.
Hast du dir das mal angeschaut, wie das jetzt läuft?
Ja, es sind mehrere Leeres, klar.
Es sind mehrere Leeres.
Die haben einen Icon-Composer, so eine digitierte App. Ja, ich weiß.
Aber das ist, wenn du das Icon vorher ordentlich designt hast,
dann gehst du in dein Programm, in ein Vektorprogramm, packst die Sachen auf
die verschiedenen Ebenen, exportierst sie, packst sie in deinen Icon-Designer fertig.
So einfach. Also klar, wenn du das nicht ordentlich designt hast und das hat
jemand irgendwie als Ölbild verfasst.
Dann ist das schwierig. Geht schon noch ein bisschen weiter,
weil das Ding ist, es ist halt, wie sagt man so schön, meinungsbehaftet.
Vorher hattest du so ein Canvas und das Einzige, was vorgegeben war,
war rounded rectangle und dann mach mal irgendwie da deinen Blues.
Und man hat eben sehr unterschiedliche Styles.
Klar, es gibt so einen generellen, so wie Apple das macht, Stil,
aber den musst du halt nicht machen.
Jetzt das neue Icon-Modell drückt einem eine ganze Menge auf,
was so vorher gar nicht da war.
Du musst diese Layer machen, das muss durchsichtig gut aussehen,
der Dark Mode und so weiter.
Das ist nicht deine Design, also das ist schon deine Designentscheidung,
aber wie der technisch funktioniert, ist vorgegeben.
Ja, aber den Dark Mode hattest du vorher auch und den Tinted Mode hattest du
auch. Also das ist jetzt kein Argument.
Ja, aber inwiefern war der automatisch?
Gar nicht.
Eben.
Du musstest ein Dark Mode Icon machen.
Genau, aber jetzt ist er automatisch. Jetzt ist sozusagen diese Änderung von
so sieht es Dark, so sieht es Transparent.
Du machst nicht das Icon dreimal, sondern du machst es einmal auf eine Art und
Weise, dass es in diesen drei Modi automatisch dargestellt werden kann.
Also es ist schon eine fundamentale Änderung der Herangehens.
Ich sage nicht schlecht oder so. Ich sage nur, es ist etwas,
wo Apple einem jetzt sozusagen mit diesem User-Interface auch noch sehr viel
mehr auflädt, als die Fenster sehen anders aus, sondern es ist schon eine ganz
grundlegende Änderung in der Herangehensweise.
Naja, die Änderung an der Herangehensweise, die eigentlich so grundlegend ist,
ist, dass du Bereiche deiner App,
deiner App-Screen nicht mehr viereckige Blöcke sind und darunter hast du jetzt
den Content und darüber sind jetzt deine Buttons und du konntest dich darauf
verlassen, dass wenn du hochscrollst, dann scrollt es unter den Bereich,
wo die Buttons sind und dann ist es weg, weil du hast da deine Vierecke,
sondern du hast halt mehr so dieses, du hast einen kontinuierlichen Content
und da packen sie dir halt dann die verschiedenen Elemente oben drauf und dass
sie das jetzt Glas gemacht haben, also ich glaube ja persönlich,
dass es nicht zu sehr nach Android aussehen sollte,
also haben sie da dieses Glasgedöns gemacht, aber im Großen und Ganzen ist es halt einfach,
wir machen jetzt keinen großen Balken mehr dahin, sondern nur noch einzelne Buttons.
Aber was hat das eben für Auswirkungen? Und ich finde,
gerade, dass ich keine Kontrolle mehr darüber habe, ob ich jetzt einen Dark-Mode
oder einen White-Mode habe, sondern dass mir das Betriebssystem das vorgibt
und zwar innerhalb von einer Webseite im Wechsel.
Das finde ich einfach übergriffig. So, ich mag halt.
Ja, dann benutzt du einen anderen Browser.
Ja gut. Aber in Mail ist es ja ganz genau so, habe ich ja gerade eben gezeigt.
Wenn du halt eine dunkel formatierte Mail hast, dann wird plötzlich mal einfach
dein Mailheader in Dark Mode umgeschaltet.
Ich habe jetzt hier drei Webseiten offen, alle drei in Safari,
Spiegel, Auphonic und irgendwie hier eine Wikipedia-Seite.
So, nur bei der Wikipedia-Seite ist es weiß, wie ich es eigentlich eingestellt habe.
So, Auphonic wird mir in Dark Mode geschaltet, weil oben der oberste Header-Bereich
von Ophonic Dark ist, die ganze GUI im Safari wird auf schwarz geschaltet und
bei Spiegel wird alles auf rot geschaltet mit einer echt ekligen Lesbarkeit,
was die einzelnen Rottöne angeht, weil der Header vom Spiegel halt rot ist.
Ich finde das übergriffig Ja.
Das geht gar nicht,
Also das geht wirklich überhaupt nicht, weil ich will auch einfach an diesem
Chrome, an dem bisschen Chrome, was da ist, auch die Apps als solche wieder erkennen.
Ich will nicht nur die Webseiten erkennen, ich will auch sehen, das ist ein Browser.
Also ja also ich habe eher Probleme damit, was du vorhin ansprachst dass es
einfach nicht genug Kontrast hat und man einfach auch nicht genau sieht, was ist wo und,
dass man jetzt in den Tabs so komische so komische abgerundete Dinger sind,
so Pillen und dass man nicht genau sieht, welche ist jetzt ausgewählt und so,
das nervt mich eher, aber gut egal.
Gut, kommen wir weg vielleicht von Liquid Glas und ich wollte,
mal jetzt so vorgehen, dass wir vielleicht die einzelnen Betriebssysteme,
jetzt mal die diskutierten Features und was euch vielleicht sonst noch aufgefallen ist.
Kannst du den Beamer wieder, glaube ich, umschalten.
Dass wir,
sozusagen durchgehen, was uns
jetzt da aufgefallen ist, also was bemerkenswert ist. Dagen wir es mal so.
Und fangen wir doch mal mit iOS an.
Das ist jetzt auch, sagen wir mal, in Ihrer Reihenfolge, wie es die Keynote gemacht hat.
Ja, Sie haben so ein paar Sachen vorgestellt. Nicht alles, was jetzt hier in
den Notizen ist, muss vielleicht diskutiert werden, aber das hatte ich jetzt hier mal so notiert.
Ja, Sie haben einiges von Android übernommen.
Ja, natürlich. Ich meine, Sie übernehmen einiges von Android.
Android übernimmt einiges von Ihnen. Also das wäre noch schöner,
wenn Sie das nicht machen würden.
Finde ich jetzt auch nicht schlimm, ehrlich gesagt.
Ob es funktionieren wird, wird man sehen. Also so ein Warteschleifen-Detektor
finde ich ehrlich gesagt ein ganz interessantes Feature. Ich bin mir nur nicht
so sicher, ob das funktioniert.
Ihr müsstest aber kurz erzählen, worum es eigentlich geht.
Die Telefon-Applikation hat jetzt sozusagen eine Möglichkeit,
wenn man auf Hold gelegt ist.
Und die Warteschleifen-Musik kommt.
Und das ist halt, sagen wir mal, vor allem ist ja nicht so, dass einem das Telefon-Netzwerk
sagen würde, man ist jetzt auf Hold. Sondern das ist ja etwas,
was man nur daran merkt, dass, tja, sie reden halt von Hold Music.
Nur hast du ja heutzutage ganz oft nicht nur Hold Music, wenn du in der Warteschleife
hast, sondern kennen sie schon unsere tollen Angebote.
Da müssen sie aber unbedingt mal und jetzt, wo wir sie sowieso 30 Minuten haben,
dann quatschen wir ihnen doch mal ein richtiges Ohr ab und dann können sie auch
nochmal hier auf unserem Webseite gehen und wussten sie, dass wir auch eine
eigene App haben. Ja, wirklich, ganz toll.
Also, ob die Telefone in der Lage sind, solche Warteschleifen zu erkennen,
da habe ich echt mal in Zweifel.
Nein.
Könnte schneller gehen, als du denkst.
Aber nice try.
Gib mal einen Weg, das rauszufinden. Ich werde es auf jeden Fall testen.
Also die Telefon-Warteschleifen gehen einfach gar nicht.
Ne, die gehen überhaupt nicht. Also was man noch dazu sagen muss,
also die Idee ist, das Telefon erkennt die Warteschleife, erkennt dann auch,
dass die Warteschleife beendet ist, also man sozusagen den Operator hat,
auch wenn es eine halbe Stunde dauert.
Man legt das Telefon einfach beiseite und wenn diese Person sich dann meldet,
also man quasi sich mal wieder auf diese Verbindung konzentrieren sollte,
dann klingelt das Telefon nochmal neu.
Und das ist schon irgendwie eine interessante Idee. Mal gucken,
ob das funktionieren wird.
Was ich mich frage ist, wie sich das von der anderen Seite aus anfühlt.
Das heißt also, der Operator bekommt dann ja irgendwie so eine Robotikansage so.
Achtung, ihr Kunde ist gleich für Sie da. Das heißt also, Dick kriegt ja quasi
so eine Art Warteschleife dann.
Und dann klingelt ja dein Telefon und dann musst du auch erstmal drangehen.
Das heißt, da werden auch irgendwie fünf bis zehn Sekunden vergehen.
Und da frage ich mich, ob die dann die Gegenseite sagt, naja,
da schalte ich doch zum nächsten, das ist mir doch jetzt hier nicht gefallen,
dass ich jetzt hier eine Warteschleife plötzlich.
Oder kann ich eine Warteschleifenmusik auswählen für die?
Bitte warten Sie, der Anrufer ist sofort für Sie da.
Also, dass wir hier ein realweltliches Problem haben, was gut ist,
wenn das mal gelöst wird, nämlich diese unsäglichen Warteschleifen mit ihrer
Zeitvernichtung, die ja teilweise
wirklich in 10, 20 Minuten auch reichen können bei wichtigen Sachen.
total dafür. Ich werde mich freuen, wenn das gut funktioniert.
Ich bin es gespannt, ob es auch gut funktioniert.
Ja, dann gibt es halt live übersetzen. Das ist natürlich ganz interessant,
auch wenn das mit so Delays verbunden ist.
Aber ich denke, warum nicht dafür sorgen, dass sich alle besser verstehen miteinander?
Ich fände das deutsche Beispiel ein bisschen cringe, aber gut.
Ja, weil das war ganz offensichtlich nicht von einer echten Person gesprochen,
sondern das war schon einmal durch die AI gejagt. Ich fand das...
Das, was sie da als Original ausgegeben hat, ja, das fand ich wirklich passend.
Aber gut, maybe it's better than we think und ich meine, wenn man jetzt so im
Ausland ist, ich werde auch gleich nochmal was, wenn wir zu Visual Intelligence
kommen, was dazu sagen, da kann sowas natürlich auch extrem hilfreich sein.
Ja, du wirst was ins Telefon und der übersetzt es dir Genau.
Also während des Gesprächs halt, also wenn du da irgendwo keine Ahnung,
wo in China stehst und willst jetzt sagen, dass dein Motorrad kaputt ist,
könnte das schon hilfreich sein Ja.
Das nächste darüber habe ich mich in der Tat gefreut, was hier steht,
nämlich Visits in Maps. Sie haben Foursquare wieder entdeckt.
Erinnert sich noch jemand an Foursquare?
Ja, aber bei Fosquare war das auch explizit, explizit ging das auch jetzt schon.
Also was haben sie eingebaut in Apple Maps? Apple Maps merkt ja eh,
wenn du an einem Ort bist oder warst.
Also das ist ja klar, sie checken die Location, also nicht im Sinne von sie
schreiben es mit, aber natürlich weiß das Telefon,
dass ich mich eine Weile irgendwo aufgehalten habe und dann kann man ja auch
mal zu Bewertungen befragt werden und so weiter, aber vor allem werden jetzt diese Orte, wo man war,
als solche dann auch in der Liste vorgehalten und man kann die halt dann jederzeit
wieder aufrufen und sagen, das sind dann sozusagen spezielle Orte.
Und wenn man jetzt einen Ort sucht, ist halt die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass man irgendwo hin will, wo man schon mal war, sehr viel größer ist,
dass man irgendwo hin will, wo man noch nie war und von daher macht das durchaus Sinn.
Also ich denke eh, in Maps ist so viel noch zu holen.
Ich fand das mit dem den Weg, den ich immer nehme wird mir dann auch als,
Navigation angezeigt das klingt ein bisschen sinnlos weil wenn ich den eh immer
nehme, weiß ich wo ich langfahren muss Stau beispielsweise das fand ich irgendwie
so brauche ich das wirklich.
Aber gut,
ja
in USA machen sie halt schon jetzt irgendwie Passwort und so weiter und Führerschein
gibt es ja auch schon eine Weile, das wird hier so nicht kommen.
Ja, was ist noch interessant? Also diese Visual Intelligence,
also das ist ja quasi, das haben sie ja auch relativ ausführlich demonstriert.
Visual Intelligence, wie es bisher war, ist ja in der Kamera.
Du kannst die Kamera anmachen, kannst auf irgendwas zeigen und dann sagt dir die AI,
da ist. Unter anderem so wie Google Lens im Prinzip das seit Jahren gemacht hat.
Ja, in Ausnahmefällen. Wenn du das auf eine Blume hältst, dann kriegst du das
Blumensymbol und dann kannst du nachgucken, was das für eine Blume hält.
Tiere, genau.
Tiere.
Bei Apple?
Ja, bei Apple. Aber nicht generell. Ich zeige irgendwo hin und dann sagt er
mir, was es ist. Das macht er ja nicht.
Nee, aber was ich zum Beispiel ausprobiert habe als Alternative zu Google Lens
ist natürlich dieses, wenn man im Ausland ist und man hat eine Speisekarte,
die nicht in einer Sprache geschrieben ist, die man versteht.
Und da muss ich aber dazu sagen, so wie das bisher gebaut ist,
bei Apple taugt es nichts,
weil sie zwar von der Speisekarte den Text erkennen und mir auch anzeigen,
aber nicht in der Originalplatzierung und Formatierung, sodass das herzlich
wenig bringt, weil ich das dann nicht wieder zurückzuordnen kann.
Also ja, es erkennt Sachen gut, es übersetzt Sachen gut, alles prima und generell
ist ihre Texterkennung ja eh ziemlich fein.
Jetzt haben sie das aber erweitert auf, du machst die Visual Intelligence zu,
was auch immer gerade auf deinem Bildschirm ist.
Das heißt, du kannst jetzt irgendwas sehen, woher es auch immer kommt und kannst
dann eben da Actions drauf machen.
Über die Kombo, mit der man auch einen Screenshot macht. Dann kannst du entscheiden,
will ich den Screenshot jetzt weiter bearbeiten oder will ich in Visual Intelligence drüber.
Hat eigentlich einer von euch das schon auf dem iOS-Gerät drauf?
Ich würde erinnern, hat, nebenbei gerne mal ein bisschen rumscrollen.
Was ist das? Visual Intelligence?
Nee, generell.
Scroll mal hier generell rum, das ist einfach ein nacktes Backup-Phone, was ich da mit sage.
Sehr gut, danke.
Da kannst du alles kaputt machen.
Ja, nicht alles.
Ja,
ansonsten, was halt bei iOS jetzt noch mit dazukommt,
ist halt diese AI-Integration, also das, was sie letztes Jahr vorgestellt haben,
war ja quasi nur die Basis für ihre eigenen AI-Anwendungen und das war ja ein ziemlicher Gainer,
weil sie halt dann nur so Sachen gemacht haben wie diesen Image-Playground,
aber jetzt wird es halt interessanter,
nicht nur, weil sie wahrscheinlich auch ihre ganzen Modelle aktualisiert haben,
sondern sie stellen das jetzt einerseits als API zur Verfügung,
Das heißt, du kannst jetzt mit einer iOS-App direkt auf diese Modelle zugreifen
und ein relativ umfangreiches API.
Das heißt, was auch immer sie dort an Modellen haben, also sowas wie Audio-to-Speed,
Audio-to-Text zum Beispiel,
also ein Transkription-Interface und ihre ganzen Image-Sachen oder ich weiß
es nicht ganz genau, was da jetzt noch mit alles dabei ist.
Aber alles, was da ist, kannst du jetzt im Prinzip auch in deiner App kostenlos
lokal auf dem Telefon, mit der Beschränkung, nicht auf ihren Servern.
Das mag vielleicht in der Zukunft noch dazukommen.
Aber mit der lokalen Server-Power kannst du halt diese Modelle mit benutzen.
Und damit hat jetzt quasi jede App die Möglichkeit, so einfache LLM-Funktionen zu benutzen.
Und das ist ganz...
Ja, diese, wie heißen die? Foundation Models, ne?
Foundation Language Models, ja.
Ja, Foundation Model, weil es sind ja nicht nur Language Models.
Da ist ja noch mehr dabei.
Aber ja, das habe ich mir nicht so genau angeguckt. Aber prinzipiell kannst
du alles, was sie an AI lokal machen, halt da drauf zugreifen.
Genau. Es heißt Foundation, Model, Frameworks.
Genau. Meine Arbeitsthese ist, dass das eine der wirklich besseren Schachzüge
von Apple ist, weil sie dadurch ein bisschen aus dieser defensiven Position rauskommen.
Wir kriegen unsere eigenen Sachen nicht an den Start, aber schauen wir doch
mal, was die App-Entwickler so alles schon anstellen können auf dem,
was wir schon unterwegs haben.
Das wäre ein Skandal gewesen, wenn sie das jetzt nicht gebracht hätten.
Naja, aber du konntest ja eigen, selbst gezimmerte Modelle schon seit Jahren
auch lokal laufen lassen.
Ja, aber du ziehst ja nicht dein eigenes LLM hoch.
Also da bin ich auf jeden Fall gespannt, was da passiert. Da kann ich mir vorstellen,
dass das für das Ökosystem sehr hilfreich ist.
Das ist sehr gut, aber vor allem ist es ja interessant im Zusammenhang mit diesen UpIntents.
Das ist ja etwas, was sie letztes Jahr angekündigt aber nicht geliefert haben
und was da schon seit langem im Raum steht,
dass jetzt Apps den Siri oder was auch immer sozusagen in dem Moment die Intelligenz
ist, die aktiv ist und wie auch immer sie heißen mag,
aber die Programme können sich quasi als Tool ihre eigene Funktionalität gegenüber
dem System beschreiben.
Also sie können sozusagen Intentionen abgebern.
Das ist so ähnlich wie bei MCP und diesen ganzen Large Language Models, das Tooling sozusagen.
Das ging aber schon länger. Also App Intense ist keine neue Erfindung.
Sie haben es nur deutlich verbessert.
Es war aber nicht verbunden mit Siri und diesem Large Language Model.
Es war mit Siri verbunden, aber Siri war ja auch immer ein Trainwreck.
Aber ja, du konntest App-Intense bauen, mit denen du über Siri dann sagen konntest, bla bla bla.
Mach mal das und das, mach mir mal eine Erinnerung in dem und dem Programm.
Also das ging schon, es war nur super hakelig und es hat auch kaum jemand tatsächlich gebaut.
Und diese Up-Intense haben sie jetzt natürlich deutlich aufgebohrt.
Das ist jetzt deutlich besser geworden.
Aber es ist keine neue Erfindung.
Also es gab das schon, aber es war meines Wissens nicht so sehr integriert mit dem Rest.
Es war auch nicht benutzbar, ganz ehrlich.
Naja, also das werden wir sehen, was dabei rauskommt. Ich bin gespannt.
Ja, und ansonsten Kleinigkeiten. Also ich weiß nicht, iWise mag also natürlich,
im Einzelnen werden wir noch eine ganze Menge Sachen entdecken,
aber mir fällt jetzt nicht viel an. Es gibt eine Games-App. Na okay, hurra.
Ja, aber das ist doch nur das Game, wie hieß das vorher? Game Dings da.
Da gab es ja vorher schon mal eine dedifizierte Meinst.
Du Apple Arcade?
Nee, nicht Apple Arcade, sondern dieses Ding.
Game Center, ne?
Es sieht ganz so danach aus, als wäre das ein aufgebohrtes Game Center, aber nicht viel mehr.
Es ist eigentlich mehr so ein auf Games spezialisierter App Store.
Darum geht es ja, dass du da sozusagen deine Games findest.
Ja, das ehrlich gesagt finde ich das interessant, aber nicht jetzt,
sondern das wird wahrscheinlich in der Zukunft interessant, um kurz ein bisschen auszuholen.
Weiter unten hatte ich das nämlich schon hingeschrieben.
Sie hatten angekündigt, dass man das Game-Porting-Toolkit in einem Modus benutzen kann,
dass man von Windows aus ein Game, was auf dem Mac läuft, remote debuggen kann.
Und das ist mal ein echter Schachzug. Also, dass Apple etwas baut,
was dediziert dafür da ist, dass du es unter Windows benutzt.
Interessant.
Was ist der Vorteil dann davon?
Das Tooling? Naja, wenn du Hardcore-Game-Developer bist, dann benutzt du kein
Linux, dann benutzt du auch kein macOS, du benutzt Windows.
Und die Leute haben eine komplette Windows-Toolchain, um ihren Kram zu machen.
Und das ist dann eine Möglichkeit, das Porting auf macOS einfacher zu machen,
wenn du in deiner Toolchain bleiben kannst.
Okay, ja, das klingt schon schlau, ja.
Und da habe ich auch immer wieder so das Gefühl, auch viele andere Sachen,
was sie so machen im Moment in Sachen Game, Zeug,
ich kann mir vorstellen, dass Apple so eine Konkurrenz zur Switch rausbringt.
Nee, niemals.
Also darüber spekulieren wir ja schon etwas länger. Ich würde es mir wünschen,
aber ich sehe es noch nicht.
Ich finde, dass sich die Anzeichen verdichten, weil das ist ein Markt,
Handheld Gaming Konsolen ist ein Markt, der wird explodieren.
Der ist eigentlich schon am explodieren und Apple kann es sich nicht leisten,
den einfach vorbeiziehen zu lassen.
Apple hat schon die größte Handheld Gaming Plattform.
Haben sie nicht.
Ja doch, das ist ein iPhone.
Ja, aber das ist keine Gaming-Plattform. Das ist vielleicht ein Daddel-Device.
Ja, aber die werden jetzt nicht nochmal...
Ja, Leute gamen da trotzdem drauf.
Ja, Leute gamen da drauf wie blöder und das ist halt einfach Plattform genug.
Also ich meine, du musst eh alles, was im iPhone ist, da einbauen,
damit es eine ordentliche Gaming-Plattform ist.
Vielleicht wird es auch nur ein iPad, wo du zwei Controller rechts und links ran machen kannst.
Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie sowas bringen.
Okay, du kannst dir das vorstellen, ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das passieren wird.
Auf jeden Fall tun sie momentan sehr, sehr viel. Historisch viel für Apple,
damit Games tatsächlich auf Apple-Plattformen kommen.
Na klar, auf alle Plattformen kommen, natürlich.
Um mal einen sehr guten Star-Wars-Podcast zu zitieren. Ich kann mir sehr vieles
vorstellen, aber realistisch ist es nicht.
Ich glaube, dass...
Wir lassen das als Prediction der Chatwürde in 20 Jahren dran essen.
Sie hätten schon so oft die Gelegenheit gehabt, da irgendwie,
also sie müssen sich einfach nur ein paar Studios kaufen, um echten AAA Premium
Content Games exklusiv sich mal zu sichern. Hatten wir alles schon Debatte.
Das Geld dafür haben sie nur wirklich in der Hosentasche. Machen sie nicht.
Du brauchst halt irgendwas in der Größenklasse, Last of Us oder sowas, exklusiv für Apple.
Weil der Markt auch einfach zu klein ist. Also das ist für Apple gar nicht mal so interessant.
Dieser Gaming-Markt, der wird zwar immer viel Heckmeck drum rum gemacht,
Aber das ist jetzt nicht so ein Riesenmarkt.
Wir haben uns gerade darüber unterhalten, dass man die Switch nirgendwo kaufen
kann, was wohl nicht so ganz stimmt.
Aber auf jeden Fall, dass sie nicht genug produziert haben, scheinbar.
Und dann sagst du, der Markt ist zu klein.
Für Apple.
Für Apple ist, also Games spielen natürlich auch eine Rolle,
deswegen tun sie da jetzt auch viel, aber dass sie jetzt eine eigene Gaming-Plattform
aufbauen und sich spezialisieren im Gaming, das ist für sie einfach kein Thema,
weil sie sind irgendwie eine Computing-Bude und das wissen sie.
Lassen wir das offen. Kommen wir weiter zu,
WatchOS, da müssen wir glaube ich nicht viel zu sagen, hat halt auch irgendwie
ganz viel Glas und Bubbly Bub und da ändert sich jetzt nicht so viel und sowas
wie diesen Workout Buddy, den sie vorgestellt haben, dass jetzt irgendwie einem
die ganze Zeit auch noch das Ohr abkaut, während man joggt.
Ich meine, das ist so amerikanisch, ich weiß gar nicht, da will ich gar nicht drüber reden.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass der mir nicht kürzester Zeit royal auf den
Sack geht, der Workout Buddy, kann ich mir einfach nicht vorstellen.
Das ging mir schon auf den Sack, als ich das in dem Video gesehen habe.
Also solange man es ausschalten kann, okay. Aber ja, okay.
Die einzige wirklich wichtige Sache ist, es gibt eine neue Geste, den Wristflick.
Ja, den finde ich.
Mit dem man einfach mal eben eine Notification oder was auch immer da gerade
kommt, wahrscheinlich auch Incoming Calls, einfach so zur Seite meckern kann.
Vom Handgelenk schüttelt.
Luca macht obszöne Gesten, muss ich mal kurz berichten.
Ja, ja, der Wristflick.
Ich denke noch über den Workout-Buddy nach. Also so eine echte Marktlücke wäre
natürlich so ein Drill-Sergeant zu haben, so aus Full-Metal-Jacket.
Du faule Sau!
Ich wusste nicht, dass man Scheiße so hochstapeln kann.
Der andere erstmal so ein Prep-Talk vorne wegschiebt. Junge,
du hast bisher nur gelost. heute ist der Tag.
Der Virtual.
Drill Sergeant oh man.
Dann geht aber die Uhr den Weg den der Drill Sergeant bei dem Film geht, oder?
Ja naja gut also ich meine, vielleicht ist das ja für manche Leute ganz gut,
aber ich denke wenn man das schon braucht, um irgendwie noch zu laufen,
dann sollte man das vielleicht eh besser sein lassen,
TVOS ist glaube ich auch schnell abgefrühstückt, da versuchen sie das eine millionste
Mal die ganzen Apps dazu zu bringen, ihr Single Sign-On mitzumachen, dass man,
wenn man jetzt irgendwie da Dienste aufruft, sich nicht immer wieder schwierig,
schwierig einloggen muss, aber naja, werden wir mal gucken, ob das irgendwie hinhaut,
ansonsten weiß ich nicht, gibt es da irgendwas zu berichten?
Nein, ganz ehrlich, Sign-In ist so kaputt gegangen irgendwie über die letzten zwei, drei Jahre,
weil alle irgendwelche komischen Sign-In-Provider benutzen, die einen dann doch
in der Regel wieder auslocken, wenn man die ab das nächste Mal startet und so.
Also naja. Ja, das originale Apple TV, für das es TV-OS gab, fliegt jetzt raus.
Also meine wird jetzt das Update nicht bekommen, aber dann ist das so.
Ja, was hast du denn noch, so eine Uralte?
Ein Developer-Kit.
Ach so.
Da gab es doch die Möglichkeit, für damals existierende Developer für einen
Euro dieses Ding zu kaufen.
Das habe ich dann gemacht und,
habe es immer noch, habe es nie viel benutzt. Insofern, wenn es kein Update
mehr bekommt, dann weine ich nicht, weil was soll's.
Aber ich werde auch keine neue kaufen. Also das ist wirklich klar.
So, dann macOS. Wir haben schon ganz
viel drüber geredet eigentlich über durchsichtige Menubars und so weiter.
Also ich meine, mit dem Menubar haben wir noch gar nicht drüber geredet.
Sie wollen ja den Menubar töten.
Da muss ich sagen.
Sodass man nur noch den Notch sieht Genau.
Da saß ich so davor Okay, ihr dreht den Spieß einfach um,
Um dich zu foltern Genau, also nach dem Motto Mich stört ja,
dass der Notch im Manubar ist Dann lass mir den Manubar einfach weg.
Dann ist der Notch nicht mehr im Manubar.
Das ist, ich muss sagen Ich bin da so ein bisschen verstummt in dem Moment Und
dachte mir so, das ist jetzt echt.
Hast du es persönlich genommen?
Ja, ich wusste gar nicht, also den musste ich einstecken, weil der war jetzt
irgendwie auch konsequent in gewisser Hinsicht.
Das war ein Kung-Fu-Move.
Und dann habe ich mich gefragt, wie sehr hänge ich an diesem Menubar?
Und wir werden ja gleich bei iPadOS nochmal drüber reden, der ja jetzt das ja
auch einen Menubar erhalten hat.
Aber beim iPad ist halt das Menu in der Mitte. Ja.
Ja, während es natürlich auf dem Mac Gott sei Dank nicht in der Mitte ist, sondern links.
Auch da, wo es hingehört.
Oben, wo es hingehört, genau, wo es auch zu bleiben hat, weil sonst weiß man
überhaupt nicht mehr, wo man hinklicken muss.
Ich finde so, in der Mitte ist eine sehr fragwürdige Entscheidung.
Allein schon, weil es halt inkonsistent ist mit der anderen Plattform etc.
Aber das iPad hat halt auch keinen Notch. auf die Idee würden sie glaube ich
auch nie kommen einen Notch,
beim iPad einzubauen, weil eigentlich einer der großen Vorteile dieser Plattform
weg ist, dass es so clean slate ist weil das ist irgendwie kein slate mehr.
Also ich finde den Notch nach wie vor scheiße ich muss sagen,
ich finde die Optik, die sie jetzt hier eröffnen ganz interessant,
aber das hängt natürlich auch wieder alles von deinen Hintergrundbildern ab,
weil ja hier der Content dann wieder durchscheint.
Und die Lesbarkeit des Menüs, ehrlich gesagt, ist mir schon was wert.
Das muss man jetzt schauen. Wie gesagt, wir wollen ja nicht über Farbabstimmungen
reden, aber das ist definitiv was ist.
Und sie haben das erste Mal seit, ich meine, seit, ich weiß nicht seit wann,
aber sie haben mindestens seit einer Ewigkeit die Form des Mauspointers geändert.
Das ist mir noch nicht aufgefallen.
Ja, haben sie. Und zwar, ich glaube, seit mehr oder weniger seit aus Classic macOS, macOS 10 wurde.
Hast du noch das alte macOS drauf? Dann kannst du mal Ralf beim Vergleich helfen.
Also der Pointer ist etwas abgerundeter.
Er ist nicht mehr so spitz. Naja, also das Schwarze ist glaube ich noch genauso,
aber das Weiße drumherum ist sozusagen runder.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Und Zoom doch auch mal hier in der Control und zwei,
du hast es gar nicht konfiguriert was hast du für einen komischen Rechner ich
wollte hier gerade die Bildschirmlupe aktivieren.
Ich bin blind, aber so blind bin ich noch nicht.
Okay, aber ich ahne was gemeint ist ist ein bisschen gerunden Ja.
Aber auch die ich vergrößere ein Fenster das ist ja auch so ein Ding mit so zwei Pfeilen Ja.
Das ist größer.
Da ist jetzt die Mittelverbindungsdings weg, es sind nur noch zwei Dreiecke.
Finde ich aber besser, muss ich sagen.
Ich habe ja nicht gesagt, dass ich das scheiße finde, ich sage nur,
es sieht jetzt anders aus.
Es sieht jetzt anders aus, genau. Also das sind so hier wieder so ein paar visuelle Sachen.
Und man kriegt diesen justen Mauszeiger auch auf dem iPad jetzt.
Ja, genau.
Das ist jetzt nicht mehr dieser komische Punkt, der da rumfliegt,
sondern es ist ein richtiger Zeiger.
Das finde ich gewagt. Aber da kommen wir gleich zu. Continuity Features,
also es gibt jetzt irgendwie auch diese Live-Activities, die es beim Telefon gibt, beim iPhone.
Also dass so eine App sagen kann, Pizza Delivery läuft gerade, dein Uber kommt.
Das kann man sich jetzt irgendwie auch auf dem Mac anschauen lassen.
Sie portieren auch diese Telefon-App, was ich bemerkenswert finde.
Das finde ich sehr gut, muss ich sagen, weil ich wollte schon,
wenn man so mit dem Mac verbunden ist und so, dann einfach nur fürs Telefonieren
immer aufs Telefon zu gehen.
Jetzt kann man sein Telefon einfach irgendwo hinlegen und dann einfach ein Rohr
auf dem Mac telefonieren, das ist gut. Ich telefoniere jetzt nicht so oft,
aber es ist an sich sehr konsequent.
Ja, und dann scheinen sich eine ganze Menge bei den Shortcuts gemacht zu haben.
Das ist auf jeden Fall sehr intelligent und das lässt sich auch mit diesen ganzen AI-Features nutzen.
Das könnte ganz spannend werden. Zum Thema Menübar und Menüs nochmal.
Ist dir aufgefallen, dass jetzt extrem viele Menüpunkte noch Icons vorne haben?
Oh ja, das stimmt. Ganz viel.
Nee. Wo?
Gehe ich jetzt zum Beispiel?
Auf dem Mac.
Auf dem Mac nahezu alles. Also wenn du jetzt in so einen Finder gehst und die
Punkte dir anschaust, also neues Fenster, neuer Ordner, neu,
intelligenter Ordner, neuer Tab, öffnen, Fenster schließen, alles,
das ganze Ablagemenü hat durchgehend Icons vor den Befehlen.
Das macht es ein bisschen noisy.
Und vor allen Dingen ist irgendwie der Look jetzt auch irgendwie so gar nicht
classy, weil das ist weder transparent noch Glas noch irgendwas anderes, das Kontextmenü.
Ja, das wäre jetzt auch noch schöner. Das Kontextmenü, wir sind beim Menübar.
Bei der Menübar. Ich bin ja bei diesen...
Nee, nee, ich habe von der Menübar geredet.
Ja, okay, da sind auch diese kleinen Icons. Aber jetzt reden wir gerade über
die Icons und nicht über die Optik.
Aber da habe ich keine Texte.
Hauptmenü, nicht Kontextmenü.
Nein, du hast die Menü.
Das Ding oben in der Menü.
Das Menü. Okay, das stimmt.
Du hast doch da auch das, was du dir gerade angeschaut hast,
das ist doch für jeden Eintrag auch ein kleines Symbol.
Ja, ja, ist richtig. Nur also, warum ist jetzt wieder die, ich weiß nicht,
aber warum sind jetzt die Dropdowns von dem Menü transparent und die Rechtsklickmenüs nicht?
Weil es nicht fertig ist.
Okay, ich mache eine Wette. Worum wollen wir wetten? Dass es so geschippt wird
mit den Transparenzen. Dass es nicht angefasst wird. Nicht konsistent wird.
Das kann passieren, aber ich glaube nicht.
So, wir werden zur Release-Date drauf gucken.
Leute, lasst uns nicht über diese Details reden. Wir sind bei den Features.
Ich bin komplett raus. Also Shortcuts, ich habe es mir ehrlich gesagt nicht
genau angeschaut, was man da alles Tolles machen kann.
Mir ist nur aufgefallen, dass sie halt auch Zugriff auf die LLM-Funktionen bieten.
Das heißt, man kann den Mac jetzt unter Umständen sehr intelligent skripten über diese Shortcuts.
Ich benutze sie nicht so viel, weil bei mir ist es immer das Gleiche.
Immer wenn mir was einfällt, was ich mal automatisieren will, dann geht es doch nicht.
Ja, ich finde diese Shortcuts, die sind auch echt nicht einfach irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, um Albert Einstein zu zitieren, make it as simple as possible.
But no simple.
Entschuldigung, wenn ich gerade ein bisschen nöckelig werde,
aber warum ist im Fenstermenü kein einziges Icon vor den Einträgen?
Du, keine Ahnung.
In allen anderen sind es viele.
Vielleicht, weil es noch nicht fertig ist.
Ach so, weil es noch nicht fertig ist. Vielleicht aber auch einfach,
weil denen gerade mal so ein Designschiff fehlt, der auf Konsistenz irgendwie guckt.
Ja, oder der hat Urlaub gehabt die letzten sechs Wochen. Kann ja mal passieren.
Bei Shortcuts denke ich ja, das große Problem ist da die UI.
Also diese Abzweigung und so. Es ist ja so ein visueller Code-Editor eigentlich.
Es funktioniert nicht gut, das so auf Biegen und Brechen linear darzustellen.
Das muss eigentlich so Notbasiert sein, denke ich.
Notbasiert? die Note.
Weil du so ein 2D-Canvas hast, auf dem du so Graphen hast.
So vielleicht wie ein Unreal Engine oder ein anderer.
Genau, Unreal Engine macht das eigentlich ganz gut.
Aber ja, genau das ist der Punkt. Also ich bin damit einfach überhaupt nicht klar gekommen.
Okay, anyway, dann Spotlight ist das erste Mal überarbeitet worden.
Man kann also jetzt das auch so ähnlich benutzen wie Launchbar und andere Launchertools,
indem man halt so dreibuchstabige, zweibuchstabige Sachen eingibt und sich dann
vermutlich merkt, ich habe das jetzt noch nicht so viel ausprobiert,
aber scheint irgendwie eine Option zu sein.
Der Vorwurf des Sherlocking wurde da schon in den Raum geworfen.
Ja, das halte ich aber für Unsinn. Also, wenn das Sherlocking ist,
ich meine, wie lange gibt es diese Launcher jetzt? Seit zehn Jahren?
Nein, 20, locker.
Launchbar? Was war denn der erste?
Quicksilver.
Quicksilver, richtig. Quicksilver, genau. Wann ist Quicksilver auf dem Mac rausgekommen?
Keine Ahnung, den gab es vielleicht sogar bei Next Step schon.
Also ich habe den bei 10.2 oder 10.3 das erste Mal verwendet.
Quicksilver wurde 2007 veröffentlicht.
Also 18 Jahre.
Seit 18 Jahren gibt es Launcher.
Ja, es gibt wohl einen ganz bestimmten Launcher, der dem sehr,
sehr, sehr ähnlich aussieht, was Apple gebaut hat. Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Spotlight.
Nee, ja, das neue Spotlight sieht so aus wie dieser Launcher. MKHD hatte den erwähnt.
Ist das eventuell Raycast, den du meinst?
Ja, genau, so hieß der, Raycast. Du, keine Ahnung, das hat er behauptet.
Ich habe nur gesagt, dass dieses im Raum steht.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass dem so ist.
Der Vorwurf steht im Raum.
Nee, da gibt es einfach, das ist einfach Quatsch. Also erstmal sieht Raycast
überhaupt nicht aus wie Spotlight und zweitens sieht Spotlight ja immer noch
so aus, wie es immer aussah. Da hat sich ja gar nichts dran geändert.
Und naja, da ist wieder kein Unterschied.
Also das ist schon irgendwie anders und dann poppen da noch Apps auf und hier
passiert dieses und da passiert jenes. Also gut, ich habe es jetzt nicht so oft benutzt.
Ja, oh mein Gott. Also wenn sie nach 18 Jahren jetzt so zwei,
drei Features von irgendwelchen Launchern mal ins Betriebssystem übernehmen,
dann kann ich nur sagen, wird ja mal höchste Zeit. Ich meine,
das war ja nie zu benutzen, dieses Spotlight.
Ich wäre schon mal froh, wenn es einfach mal zuverlässig Dateien finden würde.
Du, ich verteidige den Vorwurf gar nicht. Ich habe nur gesagt, dass er im Raum steht.
Ja, der steht im Raum. Da steht er gut.
Sehr gut. Weiter.
Ja, Clipboard-History gibt es in dem Zusammenhang auch.
Da alle so, yeah.
Benutzt ihr das?
Ich benutze derzeit noch mein eigenes vorheriges Clipboard und habe mich noch
nicht ganz umstellen können. können.
Unter anderem deshalb, weil ich relativ viel mit Screen-Copy Sachen arbeite,
wo ich also irgendwie halt einen Ausschnitt vom Screen für was auch immer für
Annotationen brauche und die sind dann halt in meinem als Vorschau viel besser
zu sehen, als jetzt diese kleinen Mini-Icons hier in Spotlight.
Ich vermute, das wird es mir vergellen.
dass ich das intensiver nutze.
Also Clipboard History, Clipboard Manager habe ich nie wirklich benutzt.
Einmal im Quartal denke ich mir, jetzt wäre ein Clipboard Manager gut und dann
verpufft der Gedanke auch wieder.
Also ich benutze das täglich. Also ich benutze Raycasts Clipboard Manager, einfach permanent.
Vielleicht kopiere ich einfach nicht genug.
War mehr Copy-Pasten beim Coden, Rodi.
Das mache ich falsch.
Und es war selbst. Anfänger.
Also, ich weiß, ich muss sagen, ich fühle mich ein bisschen schuldig und schmutzig,
weil ich dieses Feature Clipboard-Manager nie ernst genommen habe,
aber trotzdem am Laufenden Mittag immer Kotze, wenn ich irgendwie das,
was ich vor drei Dingen im Clipboard hatte,
da wieder darauf zugreifen möchte, aber ich habe mich nie so richtig dazu gebracht,
das zu machen, weil immer wenn ich ein Tool installiere, was so Clipboard Manager
einfach bei Default anhatte,
bin ich wahnsinnig geworden, weil mir dieses Behavior auf einmal dazwischen
kam und mein Rechner nicht mehr so funktioniert wie vorher und dann habe ich
das immer gleich ausgeschaltet und habe das immer gehasst, aber ich habe mir
nie Zeit genommen, es mal wirklich mir mal,
zurechtzulegen und irgendwie gezielt zu benutzen.
Was haben die denn an Behavior geändert?
Na, indem sie erstmal Command-Copy und wenn ich zweimal Command-Copy mache,
dann geht er in der History zurück und ich mache aber manchmal einfach zweimal
Copy, weil ich einfach sicher sein will, dass er das auch gemacht hat.
einfach, weil ich ärgerlich bin und jetzt unbedingt was kopieren möchte und
manchmal die Erfahrung mache, dass Programme nicht richtig kopieren,
und dann hatte ich auf einmal irgendeinen Dialog in der Nase oder stand halt
einfach was anderes drin, als ich dachte und dann habe ich es auch gemacht.
Keine Ahnung, wenn ich nichts installieren muss, vielleicht benutze ich es dann
irgendwann, weil ich mich dran gewöhnt habe und denke mir, wie habe ich die
letzten 20 Jahre ohne zugebracht.
Aber hey, man soll ja solchen Zeiten nicht nachweinen.
verpassten Chancen und so. Aber übrigens, das aufgebohrte Spotlight,
die Clipboard-History und auch das, was ich als letzten Punkt da reingetan habe,
24-Bit-Color-Terminal stand auf irgendeiner Folie.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was dahinter steht, aber dass sie das Terminal erwähnen,
dass das jetzt ein neues Feature hat, finde ich ein extrem gutes Zeichen.
Das zeigt, dass sie relativ viel kleinen Kram endlich mal gefixt haben.
Relativ viel auch so Liebe zum Detail an Features, ich rede jetzt nicht von Dingstar Glass,
dem System zugutekommen lassen. Also das finde ich sehr positiv, muss ich sagen.
Weiß ich nicht, ob ich das je brauche, aber dass sie sich darum kümmern,
nach gefühlt zehn Jahren unverändertem Terminal irgendwas am Terminal zu machen,
finde ich super. Vielen Dank.
Kann man schon machen. So, kommen wir zu meinem Lieblingsthema in diesem ganzen Kontext.
Ja, dann erzähl mal. Ich bin da ein bisschen weggepennt an der Stelle.
Bei VisionOS, ja genau. Wenn man so ein Ding nicht hat, dann interessiert man
sich natürlich da nicht für, aber ich habe ja so ein Ding und deswegen habe ich das heiß erwartet.
Ich muss sagen, von allen Plattformen hat VisionOS eigentlich am meisten profitiert.
Also da ist richtig viel passiert. Die neue Version, die bringt ganz neue Dinge
auf und das ist echt cool.
Aber abgesehen davon, dass jetzt auch dieser ganze Apple Intelligence Kram da
Einzug hält, muss man nochmal schauen, was das für Vorteile hat,
haben sie jetzt auch Widgets untergebracht.
Wir sprachen darüber, warum kann ich mir nicht eine Uhr an die Wand hängen?
Ja, jetzt kannst du die Uhr an die Wand hängen.
Ja, und alles andere auch, was man als Widget baut.
Und vor allem, du kannst dir nicht nur eine Uhr an die Wand hängen,
sondern jetzt hast du auch die Persistenz für Apps.
Das heißt, du kannst dir dieses Widget an die Wand hängen und das Gerät merkt
sich, wo und an welche Wand.
Und du kannst das ausschalten und wieder einschalten und wenn du dann im selben
Raum stehst und er erkennt den Raum, dann ploppt auf einmal dieses Ding auf
und das funktioniert auch echt gut.
Das ist schon sehr Cyberpunk.
Das ist in der Tat wirklich bemerkenswert und gibt diesem ganzen Drinnensein,
also wenn man das Ding nicht nur mal so kurz ausprobiert, sondern wirklich mal
so ein paar Stunden auch damit arbeitet, eine ganz andere Dimension.
Also das ist wirklich ziemlich irre. Vor allem, weil sie, das habe ich noch
nicht so getestet, aber ihre Spatial Awareness ist jetzt auch so erweitert worden,
dass wenn da, sagen wir mal, eine Wand davor ist und du den Ort, wo dein Widget ist,
gar nicht sehen kannst, dann ist es halt auch in der virtuellen Darstellung jetzt verdeckt.
Also sie berechnen jetzt auch die Verdeckung durch Wände. Das war vorher nicht so?
Das war so vorher nicht so, weil dann siehst du das zwar an derselben Stelle,
aber du schaust quasi durch deine ganze Wohnung durch.
Okay.
Man merkt, dass sie jetzt daran arbeiten, diese Awareness des gesamten Raums zu haben.
Sie hatten diese Informationen in gewisser Hinsicht immer schon beziehungsweise
Programme konnten es machen.
Ich weiß nicht, hast du mal dieses Magic Room ausprobiert, was ist?
Das ist ja eine der bemerkenswerteren Anwendungen, auch wenn es irgendwie keinen großen Nutzen hat.
Ich durfte die ja nur drei Tage testen, dann hast du sie mir hier entrissen damit um die Welt und so.
Ja, genau. Das war auch eine gute Idee von mir. Magic Room ist so eine App,
die benutzt einfach diese LIDAR-Abtastungstechnik der Brille.
Du weißt ja, wo die Wände sind und der erkennt deinen Raum und alles und dann
hast du dieses AR-Kit und Apps können sagen, hier ist eine Tischfläche und so weiter.
Der Raum bildet sich ab.
Und wenn du dieses Magic Room startest, dann wird diese erkannten Flächen werden
dann mit so einem bunten Gitternetz überbunden.
und das sieht total spacig aus ich such mal nach einem schönen Screenshot vielleicht,
hier genau Magic Room, hier ist ein Video, da kann man das irgendwie,
ganz gut sehen, also es wird sozusagen alles so übermalt und bleibt dann aber
sozusagen persistent und dann kannst du durch deine Wohnung rennen,
und siehst auch einfach alle Räume, die du schon durchlaufen bist.
Du kannst auch ins andere Stockwerk gucken und deine ganze Wohnung wird sozusagen,
den Ton wollte ich eigentlich ausschalten.
Das sieht ja aus wie bei Matrix.
Ja, und es gibt auch explizit einen Matrix-Modus, dass es halt wirklich so aussieht wie bei Matrix.
Aber vor allem merkst du eben, während du durch die ganze Wohnung läufst,
langsam alle Objekte mit diesem Gitternetz übergossen werden und das bleibt
dann halt auch und dann kannst du überall alles durchschauen.
Also das Gerät hat einfach einen Langzeitspeicher für die komplette Umgebung, in der du dich bewegst.
Ich weiß nicht, wo dieser Speicher endet, wodurch der limitiert ist,
wie lange diese Persistenz ist, das weiß ich nicht, aber diese Funktionalität
ist halt mit drin und das ist halt, sagen wir mal, schon eine relativ wichtige
Aspekt dieses Spatial Computings.
Naja, auf jeden Fall benutzen sie das jetzt eben für diese Persistenz der Widgets. Und das ist ganz gut.
Ich habe das neue User-Interface noch nicht so ganz gecheckt.
Es gibt jetzt unter den Fenstern auch so einen Locking-Mechanismus,
der glaube ich das gleiche machen soll, aber der taucht irgendwie nicht immer auf.
Das habe ich noch nicht so ganz begriffen.
Aber es sind noch eine ganze Menge andere Goodies mit dabei.
Jetzt gibt es auch noch diese Spatial Scenes. Ich glaube, das hast du ja auch ausprobiert.
Man kann normale Fotos, könnte man ja in so einen 3D-Modus bringen.
Also du kannst ein Foto machen, kannst du sagen, so machen wir mal 3D und dann
hat er so ein bisschen dran rumgerechnet und dann war das so ein bisschen 3D-effizient.
Mal besser, mal schlechter.
Genau und davon haben sie jetzt so eine neue Version gemacht,
da habe ich noch nicht so viel mit rumgespielt, aber das ist deutlich besser
geworden, weil sie jetzt richtig so eine dreidimensionale Tiefe machen,
indem sie sozusagen auch hinter den Objekten irgendwas inferieren.
Also da bin ich mir noch nicht so klar, wie groß da die Fehlerrate sein wird,
aber das sieht ganz bemerkenswert aus.
Und was halt auch komplett neu ist, ist dieses Personas-Feature.
Also mit dem neuen Version musste man dann auch wieder eine neue Persona aufnehmen.
Also Persona ist dieser Avatar, der, wenn du quasi mit FaceTime rausgehst, erscheint.
Und ganz am Anfang war das ja nur so ein mushy Head, dann hatten sie in der
zweiten Version so ein bisschen mehr vom Körper, aber es war immer noch alles
so ein bisschen so, und jetzt sieht das halt richtig crisp aus.
Hast du das ausprobiert? Sieht das so crisp aus, wie es in der Demo war?
Ich kann die Brille ja mal kurz aufsetzen und dich anrufen und dann kannst du
mir mal sagen, wie ich aussehe.
Ein einfaches Ja hätte mir auch gereicht.
Ich bin ja nicht derjenige, der das beurteilen kann, weil man weiß ja selber
nicht so richtig, wie man aussieht.
Achso, dann nehme ich den.
Das ist ja immer so ein bisschen das Problem. Jetzt muss man kurz gucken,
ob hier Headset und Dings Das geht glaube ich auch.
Und Brille.
Und Brille, genau, das funktioniert sogar. Achso, warte mal.
Sieht abenteuerlich aus.
Ich muss erstmal einen Akku ran machen, das Ding ist ja aus.
Ja, das ist natürlich ein Thema.
Sag mal was.
Ich sage was.
Ja, man sieht, wie Tim jetzt versucht, seine Brille auszusetzen.
Nein, du sollst was anderes sagen, während ich hier die Zeit vertreiben muss.
Zu dem Thema kann ich nicht so fürchterlich viel sagen.
Er sagt doch was zum anderen Thema.
Wir können mal die Accessories vielleicht besprechen. Da gibt es irgendwie so
einen Logitech-Stift, womit man irgendwie in die Luft malen kann.
Den fand ich so eigentlich ganz geil. Und man kann irgendwie Playstation-VR-Sense-Controller pairn.
Die von der Zweier-Version?
Die von der Zweier-Version. Irgendjemand hatte in diesem Internet behauptet,
die könne man gar nicht einzeln kaufen. Ich weiß nur nicht, ob das stimmt.
Das ist richtig, die kann man noch nicht einzeln kaufen, aber ich vermute mal,
dass man jetzt die demnächst einzeln kaufen können wird.
Das wäre zumindest sinnvoll, weil sich noch eine Sony-WA-Brille zu kaufen,
nur damit man die Controller dann...
Da wäre so viel Geld schon mal rausgegeben. Aber klar, das öffnet halt prinzipiell
jetzt nochmal eine echte Tür in Richtung VR-Gaming.
Aber ich glaube, die VR2 von Sony, die hat sich auch nicht so rasend gut verkauft.
Die Einzel ja auch schon nicht.
Du meinst, eBay ist voll davon?
Müssen wir also echt mal gucken, wie viele Geräte da überhaupt so auf dem Markt
sind. Aber klar, wenn man die Einzel kauft, wäre das nochmal eine Option.
Ob dann die Software nachzieht? Tja, mal schauen.
Also ich denke, Controller ist überfällig. Dass Apple den jetzt nicht selber
baut, das kann man so oder so sehen, mir ist das egal.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass Apple es irgendwie schafft, VR-Gaming zu mehr als
einem Gimmick zu machen.
Also ich habe irgendwie vor Ewigkeiten mir das erste Mal so ein VR-Headset gekauft,
weil ich dachte, das Gaming wäre total geil, aber...
Es gibt ein Spiel, was ich spiele. Das andere fühlt sich irgendwie wie Gimmick an.
Jetzt musst du aber auch sagen, was das eine Spiel ist.
Beat Saber. Beat Saber, kennst du? Habt ihr schon mal gesehen, gehört?
Beat Saber habe ich tatsächlich selber auch schon mal gespielt.
Das ist ein bisschen anstrengend.
Und dann gibt es dieses Spiel, wo die Personen da auf dich zukommen und die
bleiben stehen, wenn du selber aufstehen bleibst.
Superhot ist das, ja.
Superhot ist ganz cool.
Aber das spielst du und dann hast du es irgendwann mal durch.
Und dann spielst du es nicht mehr wieder.
So, Tim ist fettisch.
Jetzt ruft der Tim an.
Ich guck mal hier rum.
Was gibt's denn da zu lachen? Das sieht doch total super aus.
Entschuldigung, ich muss auf jeden Fall einen Screenshot machen.
Du musst erst mal deinen Ton ausmachen.
Ja, das sagst du mal so eben.
Ohne dir zu nahe treten zu wollen, ich finde, du siehst ja noch zehn Jahre älter aus.
Das Ton aus, ist das aus?
Ich sehe zehn Jahre älter aus als wer?
Als hier dein Avatar. Der Avatar sieht zehn Jahre älter aus als du.
Und als hätte er noch mal zehn Kilo mehr drauf.
Also ich finde, er sieht sehr realistisch aus, aber er ist nicht besonders schmeichelhaft
gerendert, um es mal so zu sagen.
Naja, okay.
Da hätte man jetzt so KI-technisch noch so eine leichte... Hast du mich dick
genannt? Ich habe deinen Avatar dick genannt.
Mach doch mal den Lautsprecher aus, bitte.
Body Shaming.
Ja, wie?
Na, dein Telefon.
Das geht nicht.
Oder deinen Macintosh, einfach den Lautsprecher aus.
Bitte stellen Sie Ihr Radio leiser.
Warte mal, rechts hoch.
Du weißt nicht, wie du in deinem Rechner...
Das ist nicht der Rechner, das ist Telefon.
Was habt ihr jetzt mit dem Telefon?
Kannst du auch den Lautsprecher leise machen?
Nee, ist doch jetzt leise, oder? Sag was.
Er hat es jetzt auf Null runtergedreht. Roddy macht ja alles richtig.
Also auf jeden Fall, finde ich, siehst du so ein bisschen aus wie Yoda,
aber nicht in grün und auch nicht mit eckigen Ohren.
Aber du siehst, dass es deutlich besser ist als vorher. Also es ist vielleicht
jetzt noch nicht perfekt, aber...
Du hast ein schwarzes T-Shirt an, dabei trägst du in real ein rotes.
Ja, weil ich mich halt mit dem Hoodie aufgenommen habe. Das war halt mein erster Try.
Aber ich werde jetzt versuchen, das nächste Mal etwas jugendlicher auszusehen.
Ich beende das jetzt mal hier.
Ich glaube, ihr musst die jetzt hochladen, ansonsten fühlt sich die Live-Hörerschaft
jetzt hintergangen. Ich auch.
Ihr ratet das jetzt bitte im Chat.
Luca hatte das jetzt noch gar nicht gesehen. Luca, soll ich dich nochmal anrufen?
Ja, mach das.
Ja, dann kannst du ja vielleicht auch mal was dazu sagen. Achso,
warte mal, aber wenn ich dich jetzt anrufe, dann klingelt ja dein Telefon und
dann geht deine Kamera aus.
Dann passt dir ein schlimmer Bild an.
Roddy lädt die jetzt einfach in den Chat hoch hier.
Aber du kannst es auch auf deinem Mac annehmen, ne? Ich mach das jetzt einfach mal trotzdem.
Ich kann das auf meinem iPad vor allem annehmen. Mach mal.
Ja, genau. Vielleicht kriegst du das ja mit dem Ton besser hin als Roddy.
Hallo, hallo. Also ich muss sagen, es ist ein bisschen, man merkt natürlich,
dass du so eine gewisse Regungslosigkeit da noch mit drin hast in diesem Avatar.
aber es sieht halt einfach deutlich besser aus, es ist definitiv ein Schritt
nach vorne und man merkt einfach, dass sie eine ganze Menge da rein investieren,
so warum gehst du nicht ran Luca?
Weil du nicht anrufst Wie.
Ich rufe nicht an, ich rufe die ganze Zeit hier an,
In der Zeit rufe ich dich an. Na egal.
Oh, jetzt ist FaceTime abgestürzt.
Dann kannst du mich ja mal anrufen.
Das habe ich gemacht. Dabei ist FaceTime abgestürzt.
So, guck mal, Roddy ist jetzt aber am Start hier, was die Screens sind.
So, jetzt siehst du mich.
Nee.
Was, du siehst mich nicht?
Warte mal, muss ich hier noch... Waiting.
Massiv kaputt.
Das stimmt. Waiting steht hier. Irgendwie kriegen wir uns gerade nicht verbunden.
Großartig. Naja, egal. Komm, wir lassen das.
So, es ist im Chat jetzt zu begutachten. Ich glaube, das ist ein guter...
Im Slack, genau.
Im Slack-Chat.
Wo Bild, da Bild.
Ach ja, so, was gibt es denn noch? Toll ist, es gab noch ein paar andere bemerkenswerte
Dinge. Und zwar kann man jetzt auch mit seinen anderen Vision OS Pieps kann
man jetzt sozusagen auch Windows sharen.
Ja, also man ruft einfach alle seine Freunde an, die auch so ein Dings haben
und dann kann man sich gemeinsam Filme anschauen und jeder hat so scheiß Brille auf.
So stellt sich Apple das vor. Also wir wollten uns schon kein Multi-User irgendwie
beim iPad geben, dass man das mal gemeinsam benutzen kann.
Jetzt muss man ja auch noch irgendwie mehrere Vision Pro kaufen.
Nee, aber zu den Personas nochmal, also der Qualitätssprung ist deutlich.
Man muss sagen, das ist nicht mehr so creepy, sondern das ist workable, würde ich es mal sagen.
Ja, das ist sogar auch gut genug, weil wenn man mal ehrlich ist,
du starrst ja jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit diese Person an.
Irgendwann gewöhnst du dich dann eben auch, dass es eine Repräsentation ist,
aber die Repräsentation ist halt
so gut, dass du ja sogar Gefühlsausdrücke darüber drüber bringen kannst.
Also lächeln, Zunge rausstrecken und so weiter, das geht ja alles.
Ich bin ehrlich gesagt beeindruckt, was sie alles abnehmen können,
nur indem sie mein Gesicht ja in den Augen beobachten und mit den Kameras nach unten,
Ja, also damit nehmen sie die Zunge und alles ran und ich kann auch so die Zunge
in die Ecke machen und so und das wird alles perfekt getrasst.
Es ist einfach crazy, was sie damit hinbekommen.
Was auch noch sehr viel besser geworden ist, ist der Gästemodus,
auch wenn wir jetzt hier gerade ein bisschen Setup-Probleme hatten,
aber grundsätzlich funktioniert das schon mal ganz gut, weil man kann jetzt
jemanden aufsetzen und man kann dann auf dem iPhone,
also man kann ein Device zuordnen und sagen, iPhone, iPad, was auch immer,
darf bestimmen, ob der Gast dann zugreifen kann.
Dann kann ich das auf dem Telefon bestätigen und dann ist das Setup schneller.
Und man muss dann zwar halt immer noch diese Händeerkennung und Augenjustage machen,
aber man wird das dann, vorausgesetzt, wie wir heute festgestellt haben,
man hat sein Telefon dann auch schon aufs neue Betriebssystem aktualisiert,
kann man dann sein Gäste-Setup auf das eigene Phone abspeichern.
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool. Das heißt, wenn man dann irgendwo wieder auftaucht,
wo eine Vision Pro rumliegt, muss man diesen ganzen Hackback nicht gleich wieder
machen, sondern man kann sich das Ding aufsetzen,
Telefone hinhalten und lockt sich damit quasi mit seinem kompletten Setup,
mit seinem ganzen Hände- und Augen-Justage-Setup ein und ist dann relativ schnell
am Start. Also das ist schon ganz geil.
Und ja, was ich dann noch besonders bemerkenswert fand, also du hast ja schon
diese Accessories erwähnt, da müssen wir mal gucken.
Also ich werde mir wahrscheinlich diese Playstation-Controller,
wenn es die einzeln gibt, die werde ich mir wahrscheinlich holen,
weil ich natürlich die Hoffnung habe, dass ich damit dann endlich mal irgendwie
Google Earth ordentlich steuern kann.
das wäre schon sehr geil dieser Stift, den sie da vorgestellt haben von Logitech,
diese Muse gut, so für Direct Manipulation aber ich weiß nicht,
das ist wahrscheinlich nicht so mein Ding naja.
Um auf ein virtuelles Whiteboard zu malen oder so ja, aber sowas mache ich halt
nicht nö, aber ich kann mir vorstellen dass das sinnvoll sein kann also ich
benutze inzwischen den Stift von dem iPad auch relativ viel ja,
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, wird sich zeigen. Es gibt bestimmt eine Anwendung, aber ich glaube,
mich erreicht das jetzt erstmal nicht so.
Aber wo ich dann wirklich begeistert war, und das habe ich auch ausprobiert,
soweit ich Dateien gefunden habe, sie unterstützen jetzt die nativen Dateiformate,
von der GoPro, von der Insta360 und von einer, was war das dritte?
Omega Sigma, wie heißt die?
Ne, Canon Kameras. Also die haben alle so 360 Grad Kameras, beziehungsweise
Beispielsweise, es geht nicht nur um 360 Grad, sondern es geht auch um 180 Grad
und es geht auch um Weitwinkel.
Und mit Weitwinkel-Videos, das kennt ihr ja wahrscheinlich auch von euren Telefonen,
wenn man so ein 0,5 Setting hat,
das macht man manchmal so, aber dann zerrt sich natürlich die Realität dann
auf den Screen so weit runter, dass das dann halt nicht normal aussieht.
Ist ja auch klar, weil es ist ja Weitwinkel und es ist nicht der normale Blickwinkel,
den man jetzt normalerweise mit der Kamera hat.
Oh, für Landschaften mit viel Himmel und so, das kann man schon mal machen.
Ja, man kann das machen, man macht das ja auch mal, aber es ist halt nicht richtig,
in Anführungsstrichen.
Und ich habe jetzt mir GoPro-Videos genommen, die mit so Weitwinkel aufgenommen
sind und habe die einfach über iCloud Drive in Division Pro reingeworfen und
da kann ich die dann einfach öffnen,
kriege da einen Player für und dann ist wirklich das Video vor dir so gebogen,
dass es eben quasi diesen Weitwinkel wieder rausrechnet sodass du also mehr
oder weniger in deinem Video stehst du kannst dann links und rechts du siehst
schon noch die Kanten also irgendwo ist da halt auch zu Ende,
wenn du 180 Grad Content hast, dann ist es halt 180 Grad und bei 360 Grad sollte
es dann im Idealfall eben komplett drum rum sein und jetzt wird es halt wirklich
spannend weil es gibt natürlich relativ günstige Sachen schon,
also wie heißt das Ding GoPro Max ich weiß gar nicht, haben wir gleich geguckt, was kostet sie.
Die so 360 Grad Video auch macht, die auch relativ kompakt ist, 350 Euro ungefähr.
Also in diesem Bereich kriegst du jetzt relativ kompakte 360 Grad Kameras,
die könnte ich mir jetzt irgendwie oben auf meinem Motorradhelm draufkleben
und durch die Gegend fahren und dann könnte ich mir danach,
den kompletten Fahrtmitschnitt,
anschauen und während ich ihn mir anschaue, überall...
Ordentlich kotzen.
Glaube ich nicht, dass das ein Problem ist. Ich kann, wobei es kann schon sein,
dass es ein Problem ist. Ich hatte...
ein Video von so einem Mountainbiker mir angeschaut und es gab so eine Szene,
die so ein bisschen grenzwertig war, aber das ist kein großes Problem.
Habe aber auch nicht so viel Zeit damit verbracht. Aber das ist einfach mal
von der Aspekt des Aufzeichnens her und der Wiedergabe irre.
Also Klassiker und ist glaube ich auch, muss sagen, einige, bin ganz froh mit
meiner ursprünglichen Einschätzung.
Wofür ich glaube, wofür man die Brille unter Umständen gut gebrauchen kann,
die ich hier abgegeben habe, ganz zufrieden war.
Ich glaube, das passt irgendwie alles. Das ist so eine davon.
Wenn man so Location-Scouting macht, für Veranstaltungen zum Beispiel,
und du machst dann da irgendwelche Fotos, danach hast du immer das Problem,
das, was dich wirklich interessiert, hast du dann nicht fotografiert oder nicht
im richtigen Winkel, aber du kriegst auch nicht so richtig einen Eindruck und
du musst, wenn du es anderen Leuten erklärst, permanent so klar,
du kannst so ein Video-Walksroom machen, aber da kannst du halt immer nur an eine Stelle gucken.
Jetzt kannst du halt mit so einer 360-Grad- Kamera da einfach mal einmal überall
langlaufen, kannst du das quasi auf Repeat anschauen und dir jederzeit immer
wieder irgendeinen ganz anderen Blickwinkel geben und kriegst auch wirklich
das Gefühl, dass du da drin bist.
Du hast ja jetzt gerade mal die Brille auf gehabt, ich habe mir diesen 3D-Simulator,
den wir hier gerade machen, gezeigt.
Das ist ja schon auch was anderes, oder?
Mich brauchst du dann nicht zu überzeugen. Ich fand es schon gut,
bevor ich hier regelmäßig in diesem Podcast war.
Ja, aber du wolltest ja immer mit Games, Games, Games, Games.
Nein, nein, nein. Also was du jetzt gerade beschreibst, das habe ich ja mit
der, ich weiß gar nicht, hatte ich da die Quest 2 schon, während Corona,
du erinnerst dich, Eskapismus.
Irgendwie Urlaubsvideos, andere Leute 360 Grad angucken.
Nachts einsam auf der Couch. so, keiner konnte irgendwie im Lockdown draußen
vor die Tür, aber du kannst dir die Wunder der Welt irgendwie trotzdem angucken.
Das hat damals und auch heute auch noch, finde ich das eine total coole Anwendung
davon. Hat nichts mit Games zu tun.
Also ist jetzt nichts, was jetzt gerade die Vision Pro jetzt gerade erfunden hätte.
Nein, nein, aber das ist halt, die Qualität ist halt einfach gut.
Da jetzt einen guten, schnellen Fahrt zu haben von eigener Aufnahme und schnell
und einfach in die Kamera rein, ja, Daumen hoch. gar nichts dagegen.
Aber, und das enttäuscht mich natürlich maßlos, es gibt immer noch kein Apple Earth. Tja.
Das verstehe ich einfach hinten und vorne nicht, weil Google lässt sich ja ordentlich bitten.
Ich meine, es gibt nach wie vor keine YouTube-App, es gibt keine Netflix-App,
die Plattform wird komplett boykottiert von den großen anderen Content und Plattform-Providern.
Die gehören halt.
Ja, aber Disney hat doch garantiert Geld dafür genommen, dass sie das machen.
Die werden wahrscheinlich auch eine Kooperation haben und da Know-how.
Das meine ich ja. Eine Kooperation.
Ja, ja.
Geld in die eine Richtung, Features in die andere.
Genau.
Also ja, keine Ahnung.
Also nach wie vor ist es keine Plattform, die so viele User hat,
dass Google da tätig werden müsste.
Insofern wir haben auch gerade mal andere Sorgen. Also Google hat gerade echt ein Thema mit KI-Suche.
Aber das müssen wir uns mal genauer in der Sendung angucken,
was das gerade alles für Disruption nach sich führt.
Genug 3D-Brille, die keiner hat. iPad OS, letzter Punkt.
Und dann kann man auch langsam hier WWDC abschließen.
Also meiner Meinung nach ist das das große Feature der WWDC gewesen.
Das sehe ich aber genauso. Jetzt haben sie das endlich mal hinbekommen mit dem
Multitasking und man merkt es irgendwie
sofort da dran, dass es sich so selbstverständlich anfühlt, finde ich.
Oder? Also wer es nicht mitbekommen hat, dass iPad, was ja klassischerweise Fullscreen-Apps hat,
Man kann jetzt einfach bei jeder geöffneten Anwendung rechts unten den Finger
ranhalten an die Ecke und dann einfach das Ding in so ein Fenster ziehen und
hat ein richtiges Windowing.
Wie schon erwähnt, es gibt jetzt auch ein Menü, eine richtige Maus.
Man kann im Wesentlichen mit diesen Fenstern auch so arbeiten wie auf macOS.
Es gibt sogar die Ampel-Buttons, also es ist schon wirklich ziemlich Mac-mäßig.
Trotzdem ist es aber auch irgendwie immer noch ein iPad.
Es gibt noch den Stage-Manager, aber diese Slide-In-Geschichte und so weiter.
Den habe ich ja nie verwendet, den fand ich ja schon immer nervig.
Ich auch nicht, aber es gibt Leute.
Die tun das. Ich mag den gerne.
Ja, es gibt so Leute.
Ja, aber das ist jetzt wirklich sehr interessant. Also das, vor allem wie beim
macOS Classic Finder, bleiben die Fenster halt dann auch da,
wo du sie hingelegt hast.
Wenn du die App später wieder aufrufst, öffnet die sich an derselben Stelle.
Das ist also sehr viel mehr wie Classic macOS.
Insofern ganz spannend.
Ich finde also gerade dieses Windowing auch mit dem Stift, wenn man den Stift
hat, macht das richtig Laune, weil man damit halt auch einfach viel besser und
genauer agieren kann. Das ist ja fast wie ein Mauszeiger.
Luca wedelt hier schon mit dem Stift.
Ja, ich habe den hier die ganze Zeit in Benutzung. Ich habe hier meinen Second
Screen, mein iPad mit der Beta drauf. Schon ganz cool.
Manche Dinge funktionieren nicht. Das ist ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Also zum Beispiel, um an die Menübar zu kommen, muss man von oben swipen.
Dann kommt sie reingerauscht.
Aber das geht nicht mit dem Stift aus irgendeinem Grund.
Stimmt.
Das ging auch früher nicht.
Keine Ahnung. Also manche Dinge gehen halt nicht, aber das ist auch kein großes Problem.
Diese Buttons sind super. Also ich bin begeistert.
Man hat das Gefühl, ja, Apple nimmt das iPad jetzt plötzlich ernst.
Pro heißt nicht nur, dass es teuer ist, sondern vielleicht auch,
dass man was damit machen kann.
Und es wird ja noch besser, Ja,
dieses Files-App irgendwie, die Dateien-App, ja, verhält sich jetzt vielmehr
wie so ein Finder und man kann jetzt so Sachen machen wie OpenWidth,
dass man mal sagen kann, womit eine Datei dann geöffnet werden soll.
Das ist ja das, was für mich das iPad komplett rausgenommen hat,
dass man einfach auf dieser Ebene überhaupt nicht flexibel mit Dateien arbeiten kann.
Das haben sie uns jetzt mal gespendet. Es gibt eine Preview-App,
das heißt, man kann sich jetzt auch mal PDFs ordentlich anschauen.
Obwohl die Preview-App ganz ehrlich ja auch nur eine Ausgründung des PDF-Viewers
in der vorherigen Dateien-App ist.
Also ich habe ja vorher die Dateien-App immer so… Also die kann.
Keine Bilder anzeigen, doch.
Die Dateien-App kann die Bilder anzeigen? Also vorher konnte die Dateien-App,
da bist du auf den PDF gegangen, hast du das PDF gesehen, wie in einem normalen
PDF anguck, sonst sowas.
Jetzt gibt es halt die Preview-App, aber die kann dann, also ich wüsste nicht,
dass sie jetzt deutlich andere Sachen kann.
Ja, wahrscheinlich kann sie mehr Sachen, aber zumindest ändert sich da jetzt
die Vorgehensweise erstmal nicht. Also jetzt so als Erklärung,
ich benutze das iPad inzwischen immer beim Core, so als...
um die Noten zu haben, als, keine Ahnung, Notenmappe.
Das ist insofern ganz schön, weil die Noten sind selbstleuchtend.
Das kann in schwierigen Beleuchtungssituationen kann das sehr viel bringen.
Und man kann sie auch vergrößern mit einer Pinch-Geste, was man mit so einem
normalen Notenblatt eher nicht kann.
Im Zusammenhang mit dem Stift, wo man halt da einfach reinpinseln kann,
wie man will, ist das auch sehr geil.
ein bisschen doof ist, dass er immer auf Biegen und Brechen versucht,
jeden Strich, den man auf irgendein Papier setzt, irgendwie als Text erkennen zu wollen,
und da auch gerne mal sehr falsch liegt. Also das nervt ein bisschen.
Naja, aber man kann jetzt Bilder öffnen mit der Vorschau-App,
man kann irgendwie auch exportieren in die Formate, also das ist schon die Preview-App
von Mac natürlich in einer etwas angepassten Version.
Man kann jetzt auch Audio-Eingänge besser festlegen, also so Audio-Video-Ströme
besser definieren, damit ist das Ding einfach auch für Audio und Podcasting
unter Umständen deutlich besser.
Oder überhaupt mal benutzbar.
Überhaupt mal benutzbar. Manche Leute tun sowas ja schon.
Ja, also das finde ich ganz cool. Sie haben auch davon geredet,
dass man so mit den AirPods jetzt so Studio-Quality-Aufnahmen machen kann,
das will ich ja noch mal sehen.
Wenn auch Vornik das kann, aber wir sind es gespannt.
Das fand ich auch ein bisschen übertrieben, ganz ehrlich, ich glaube ich denen
kein Wort, was das anbelangt, aber gut.
Das werden wir sehen. Aber was definitiv der Fall ist, es gibt jetzt Background-Apps
und dann macht es auch mal Sinn, dass es so Apps wie Final Cut Pro auf dem iPad
gibt, wo sich ja alle schon gewundert haben, was das denn jetzt soll,
wo du ja noch nicht mal ordentlich Dateien exportieren konntest,
weil dann irgendwie, wenn die im Hintergrund sind, dann der Export,
Prozess gekehlt wird.
Jetzt gibt es halt sozusagen so eine Definition für Backgrounds und da hat sich
auch bei MacOS was ja geändert.
Wenn du jetzt Apps hast, die sich im Hintergrund weiter bewegen wollen,
dann gibt es jetzt eine Warnung dafür.
Also du kannst jetzt quasi Programme anmerken, wenn sie im Hintergrund aktiv sind.
Also du kriegst dann so hier, One Password läuft im Hintergrund und ist das
okay so? Soll ich das erlauben?
Also das ist jetzt sozusagen neu auf der Seite.
Ich finde das auch okay, weil ich finde, das Betriebssystem sollte mehr Kontrolle
darüber haben, was nun tatsächlich läuft und wann etwas laufen darf.
Dass der User einfach freier bestimmen kann, ja, das ist jetzt auch okay,
ich möchte dem jetzt hier diese CPU-Zeit opfern.
Auf dem Mac ist es natürlich auch eine Sicherheitsfrage, aber auf dem iPad ist
es vor allem natürlich eine Anwendungsfrage,
dass du bestimmte Dinge damit überhaupt erstmal machen kannst.
Ja, da gibt es bestimmt genug Leute, die da Zeta und Mordio schreien, Entwickler.
Also ich meine, die Alternative ist ja so ein komischer Wildwuchs wie unter
Windows, wo einfach free for all ist und du weißt ja.
Was da abgeht. Ja gut, war es ja bisher bei macOS im Prinzip auch.
Also ich meine, du hast da ein, Moment mal.
Ich finde das schon ganz gut, wenn man so ein bisschen Kontrolle darüber bekommt.
Ja, natürlich, natürlich. Also wie gesagt, ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass manche Leute das übergriffig finden und damit nicht glücklich sind.
Für den User ist es natürlich eigentlich besser, wenn er sagen kann,
hey, ein Programm, das im Hintergrund ständig meine Batterie irgendwie leer
macht, das will ich wissen und dem auch Einhalt gebieten können.
Ja, nicht nur Einhaltgebiete, sondern ich müsste vielleicht auch pausieren können,
dass man sagt so, ja meinetwegen, aber halt mal an.
Also es müsste eigentlich sehr viel mehr in so ein Taskmanagement übergehen,
anstatt in so ein Free-for-All irgendwie, ich laufe jetzt einfach mal los und
hole mir die Ressourcen, wie es mir passt.
Das ist halt der klassische Weg, wie es auf so Desktop-Rechnern gelaufen ist,
aber das ist halt eigentlich nicht okay.
man sollte mehr Kontrolle darüber haben und da ist natürlich das iPad schon
immer ich finde das iPad insofern sehr interessant generell als Konzept, weil sie ja,
mehr oder weniger mit macOS und iPadOS irgendwo auf den gleichen Punkt zu steuern.
Das habe ich ganz am Anfang gesagt.
Genau, macOS kommt von Anything Goes, alles gleichzeitig, aber kaum irgendwas
ist reglementiert und das iPad ist sozusagen, alles ist komplett reglementiert,
es gibt beileibe nicht alles,
ja, erstmal nur Fullscreen und jetzt haben wir auch Windows und jetzt auch Background-Task und so.
Sie nehmen es halt nur auf in die Liste, wenn sie wissen, okay,
das passt jetzt auch, jetzt verlieren wir nicht die Kontrolle,
wir verlieren nicht die Kontrolle über die Performance.
In einem dieser Interviews hat Greg Friederigi auch gesagt, warum das jetzt
so lange gedauert hat, haben sie halt gesagt, naja,
das iPad mit seiner Touch und seiner Responsivität, wie man es gewohnt ist,
bestimmte Dinge hielten sie nicht für machbar, ohne diese Responsivität in Gefahr zu bringen.
Und das ist so einer, sicherlich nicht der einzige, aber einer der Gründe,
warum sie das nicht gemacht haben.
Und ich finde die Philosophie okay und nachvollziehbar und es wird spannend
sein zu sehen, wie jetzt über die nächsten Jahre die Systeme sich noch weiter
annähern, aber ich glaube so nah wie jetzt mit dem neuen,
System waren sie sich noch nie und da ist jetzt definitiv so eine,
seismische Verschiebung hat da stattgefunden.
Ja, wie gesagt, also ich erwarte eher früher die Fusion von iPadOS und macOS.
Oh gut, das kann noch zwei Major Releases dauern.
Das kann noch zwei Jahrzehnte dauern.
Keine Ahnung. Das ist ja eine Frage des Wollens, das ist nicht eine Frage des Könnens.
Und ich glaube, wenn sie irgendwann an dem Punkt sind, wo sie sagen,
es macht keinen Sinn, iPad und MacBook zwei Kategorien von Geräten zu haben,
naja, dann geht es halt dahin.
Ja, also ich habe jetzt gerade zum ersten Mal ausprobiert hier auf einem iPad
von Roddy, wie sich das alles so anfühlt mit den Fenstern. Das ist schon gut.
Das fühlt sich sofort richtig und vernünftig und so kann man arbeiten.
Das passt, ne?
Ich glaube, wenn du dann noch ein Trackpad davor hast, dass du wirklich nochmal
in einem Mauszeiger auch operieren kannst.
Gewinnt das Ganze nochmal. Wie nennt sich dieser Modus, dass man den Mauszeiger vom Mac...
Achso, dann so rüberschiebt.
So rüberschiebt und dann kannst du natürlich hier auch alle Sachen machen.
Warum mache ich das eigentlich nicht die ganze Zeit?
Schon hat sich die Sendung wieder gelohnt.
Das ist so ein Feature, ich vergesse immer, dass es das gibt und manchmal entdecke
ich das per Zufall und denke mir, oh geil.
So, was halt noch fehlt, um das iPad wirklich in den Killer-Bereich zu schieben,
ist halt Account-Verwaltung, Multi-User.
Das werden wir aber in diesem Leben wahrscheinlich nie mehr kriegen.
Multi-User ist auch noch so ein Ding und meiner Meinung nach schießen sie sich
selber in den Fuß, dass sie das nicht haben, weil das würde so viel,
weißt du, du hast ein iPad für zwei Leute oder drei Leute und du merkst so schnell,
eigentlich will jeder sein eigenes haben und zack, haben sie drei iPads verkauft.
Ganz, also, naja, egal. Es sind noch so zwei kleine Themen, die sehr dev-lastig
sind. Das eine ist, die...
Einen letzten Satz von mir zum iPad?
Ja.
Ich habe ein iPad Pro von 2018, 11 Zoll, das erste mit Face ID und es ist immer
noch supported mit dem aktuellen Betriebssystem.
2018.
Ja, offensichtlich kann.
Halt Jahre nach Release wird sozusagen noch das aktuelle Betriebssystem laufen können.
Ja, das ist erstaunlich, aber ich habe ein, ich glaube, das iPad Pro davor gehabt,
das hat schon kein, wer ist das noch, aktuelle 18 bekommen. Also ist egal.
Wann sie was rausschmeißen, ist ja auch irgendwie komisch.
Und sie haben jetzt das x86 rausgeworfen, ne? Ne. Habe ich das richtig verstanden? Ne.
Noch nicht ganz.
Das nächste.
26 ist das letzte Release, was noch auf x86 läuft?
Richtig, auf einigen. Nicht mehr auf sehr vielen.
Aber überhaupt mal. Das ist die letzte Warnung an die Hackintosh-Leute?
Ja, 27 ist dann Schluss mit Intel. Das wird natürlich nochmal eine ganze Menge,
ermöglichen, weil das bedeutet, dass sie dann halt einfach auf die neue RAM-Architektur
setzen können und damit ganz andere Dinge tun können.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich gibt es dann Hackintoshes unter Ampere-Prozessoren oder so. Mal sehen.
Genau, zwei Sachen zum Thema Dev. Chat-GPT in Xcode, Native.
Ehrlich gesagt ist das, was sie momentan alle sich bei Cursor abgucken.
Ja, aber es ist noch nicht nur Chat-GPT, sind alle Modelle.
Man kann alle Modelle einbinden, zu denen man irgendwie eine Connection übers Netz aufbauen kann.
Ich habe das jetzt noch nicht hingekriegt mit irgendwas anderem.
Auch lokal. Auch lokal.
Du kannst auch lokal einen Proxy haben, der dich irgendwo anders hinproxiert,
wie auch immer. Also das geht jetzt.
Ich habe es noch nicht wirklich intensiv getestet, ob das auch gut funktioniert, aber es gibt es jetzt.
hatte ich aber auch ehrlich gesagt fest mit gerechnet, dass sie so einen Schritt gehen.
Und was mich tatsächlich sehr gewundert hat, war die Containerization, ganz ehrlich.
Oh ja.
Da dachte ich so, alter Schwede, vor allen Dingen.
Beschreib mal kurz.
Also Stichwort Docker. Docker hat ja damit angefangen.
Was ist Docker? Docker ist im Prinzip etwas.
Wo man… Komplettes Linux in einem Container.
Ja, also der Container ist, also eine App läuft in einem Art Jail-Ton.
Und ist relativ stark von dem Rest des Betriebssystems abgeschottet,
kann nur sein eigenes Dateisystem zugreifen, kann Ports auch nicht in andere
Container so mal eben öffnen und solche Sachen.
Ist also ein relativ abgeschlossenes Ding.
Die Art und Weise, wie die Container gebaut werden, ist auch nochmal speziell,
weil du im Prinzip das Erstellen eines Containers skripten kannst und so weiter.
Das ist so, ja, da kommen wir jetzt so ein bisschen in die Wildnis,
um das jetzt genauer zu beschreiben.
Aber was bei Docker halt wichtig ist, was man wissen muss, es sind einfach nur
normale Prozesse auf einem Unix-System.
was so viel heißt, wie wenn ich ein Kernel-Root-Kit habe, dann habe ich auch
Zugriff zu allen Container-Apps was Apple jetzt gemacht hat und das ist schon sehr spannend.
Die Container, die Lösung, die sie gebaut haben, läuft tatsächlich auf einer
Lightweight VM sprich der ARM Mac macht eine VM,
die wiederum einen x86-Code,
laufen lässt und dadurch können tatsächlich,
also kann der Prozess eines Containers nicht ausbrechen und ist also komplett
in dieser VM gefangen, jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass jede Lösung irgendwie
Lücken hat und gehackt werden kann.
Das finde ich nur sehr spannend. Was sie nicht so ganz, also was ich nicht auf
Anhieb gefunden habe, ist wie benutze ich diese Container denn jetzt in Production?
Also jetzt einfach mal nur einen Container bauen, damit er irgendwo rumliegt,
ist ja jetzt sinnlos, sondern ich muss ja auch den Container auf einem System
deployen und dann will man ihn ja doch auf einem Linux,
deployen, den man irgendwo in einem Rack hat oder den man sich bei AWS geklickt hat oder oder oder.
Und das haben sie jetzt nicht so genau erklärt.
Ich nehme mal an, das kommt noch, weil das sieht auch so ein bisschen aus wie,
wir haben da mal was gebastelt und hier ist das Repo und guckt es euch halt
an und spielt damit rum, aber es ist keine schlüsselfertige Lösung zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Wie gesagt, das ist jetzt so mein, ich habe da mal eine Viertelstunde geguckt
und habe mir auch den Talk dazu angeguckt, aber mehr kam nicht.
Wie ich das verstehe, ist es ja komplett compliant mit diesem OCI-Spec,
diese Open Container Initiative.
Ah, okay.
Das beschreibt im Prinzip, was so eine Container Runtime können muss,
wie zum Beispiel auch Docker.
Also das Ding müsste eigentlich, wenn ich es richtig verstehe,
Drop-In-Replacement sein können für, ich starte mir über Docker meine Postgres-Datenbank
beim Entwickeln oder so.
Also das müsste auch einfach so gehen mit dem, mit diesem Apple-Container-Ding.
Achso, du meinst, so einen fertig gebauten Container müsste man auch dann so deployen können?
Genau.
In irgendeiner dieser Lösungen.
Und auch andersrum.
Ja, so habe ich das halt auch verstanden. Ich meine, du kannst dann halt einfach
irgendein Linux-Docker-Image nehmen und kannst es halt auf dem Mac laufen lassen.
Aber es läuft dann halt in so einem Safety-Contain.
Naja, in der VM, weil das ja meistens x86-Code ist.
Also da waren sie ein bisschen unklar, weil ich meine, es gibt auch jede Menge ARM-Server.
Ja, aber das ist halt sehr praktisch zum Ausprobieren. Man macht halt so ein
Image, aber du kannst das dann halt irgendwie auch lokal.
Ja, aber die Lösung ist auch darauf gebaut, dass du als Entwickler lokal den
Container zusammenbaust, den du dann woanders deployst.
Ja.
So klang es zumindest.
Das kannst du eigentlich immer machen, wie du möchtest, wie du gerade Hunger hast.
Würde ich sagen.
Für mich sieht das halt aus wie im Prinzip so ein bisschen Replacement für Docker
for Mac, was im Prinzip ja ähnlich funktioniert, startet auch eine VM,
wo drin dann Container gestartet werden.
Oder Orpstick.
Oder Colima, oder inzwischen gibt es da tausende.
Ach echt, so viele?
Ja, wirklich viele. Ich finde es aber ganz gut, dass es da von Apple was gibt,
vielleicht kann man da irgendwie mit besserer Integration, Performance rechnen
oder so. Ich habe es noch nicht getestet.
Ja, ich bin gespannt.
Alright, dann machen wir das Kapitel mal zu und jetzt kommen wir zum Spaßteil dieser Veranstaltung.
Ihr freut euch schon richtig, ne?
Endlich mal Spaß.
Endlich mal Spaß haben, ja.
Hitters.
Ich bin echt gestraft mit euch.
Nicht immer nur Schläge.
Auch mal Spaß.
So, aber Luca weiß ja schon Bescheid, aber ihr wisst ja noch nicht Bescheid.
Also, was hatte ich ja vor? Ich habe gesagt, wir müssen mal Tierlisten mal ausprobieren.
dass hier mal ein bisschen Spaß reinkommt hier in die Runde,
ein paar Streitgespräche,
und ihr wusstet alle nicht, was Tierlists sind und wer jetzt das letzte Mal
nicht zugehört hat, hier nochmal so ein Management-Summary Tierlist ist so Internetkultur
man setzt sich halt zusammen, man hat irgendwie eine Liste von Dingen,
die mehr oder weniger aus derselben Domain sind, was auch immer die Domain ist
und es geht darum, diese Dinger zu ranken und diese Ranking-Methode mit den
Tierlists ist man rankt sie halt nicht in einer linearen Liste,
sondern es ist sozusagen in tiers,
also in einzelnen Kategorien, die,
untereinander eine Hierarchie darstellen, abgebildet und klassischerweise macht
man das halt in so mit Buchstaben benannten Tierlists.
Die oberste und beste und tollste Kategorie ist S und dann kommt A,
B, C, D und manchmal kommt auch noch E, aber auf jeden Fall kommt dann F. F.
Das sind die amerikanischen Schulnoten.
Ja, aber darauf basiert es nicht. Das ist ja aus der japanischen Kultur,
weil S gibt es halt nicht in den amerikanischen Schulnoten.
Ja, das wundert ja.
Ansonsten sind es halt einfach Buchstaben. Aus dem Alphabet kennst du die wahrscheinlich.
Die Buchstaben? Ja, die Buchstaben, hast du mal gehört?
Ja, ja.
Genau.
Es klingelt.
Mit S fängt das Alphabet an. Aber sowas von.
So, Und dann dachte ich mir so, okay, wir machen jetzt mal eine Tierlist.
Und dann habe ich mich also aufgemacht und habe das Internet abgegrast nach
dem passenden Tierlistmaker.
Weil man will ja diese Tierlist auch interaktiv in einem Webbrowser erstellen.
Und bin ich fündig geworden?
Natürlich.
Ja, selbstverständlich. Das Internet ist voll mit Tierlistmakern.
Das heißt, wir müssen keinen mehr selber schreiben. Das ist schon mal eine gute Sache.
Und was glaubt ihr, wie viele davon was taugen?
Wenn überhaupt einer.
Ein halber?
Ja, das ist schwierig, ne? Und es gibt die, die halt nichts taugen.
Dann gibt es die, die zwar irgendwie taugen, aber einem irgendwie mit Werbung
oder sonst irgendeinem Kram.
Das heißt, wir müssen erstmal eine Tierlist für Tierlist-Apps anlegen.
Das könnte man auf jeden Fall auch nochmal machen, dass man Tierlist-Maker in
Tierlist einsortiert. Habe ich aber so jetzt nicht gefunden.
Dann habe ich tatsächlich auch was gefunden, was so Open Source ist. Open Tier List.
Wie hieß das nochmal? Open Tier Boy. Ich muss mich raten.
Es war hässlich.
Open Tier Boy. Nein, es ist nicht hässlich. Open Tier Boy ist nicht hässlich.
Open Tier Boy kann man durchaus benutzen und es sieht auch wie schick aus.
Der Name ist ein bisschen weird.
Man sieht hier, man hat hier unten die Liste von Dingen, die man da reindrackt
und man hat hier oben Tier List.
Die kann man auch noch umsortieren und umbenennen. und alles mögliche.
Man sieht.
Man sieht, genau. Aber das Problem dabei ist, das funktionierte dann irgendwie
nur lokal und dann bin ich da bei denen in Discord reingegangen und so,
ja hier, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie die URL von der Tillis aber irgendwie sharen
möchte, dann tauchen die ganzen Images nicht auf.
Ja, das ist so gedacht.
Aha, okay. Warum ist das so gedacht? Ich weiß nicht, ich habe die Diskussion nicht weitergeführt.
Ich wusste nur, auch OpenTierBoy ist leider keine Optionen und ich brauche was anderes.
Und dann dachte ich mir so, pfff.
Da musst du auch Elixier ran. Da musst du auch Elixier ran. Das kann doch kein Problem sein.
Sehr gut, Tim. Okay, dann machen wir jetzt hier aber gleich mal einen WX-Stress-Test.
Das weiben wir uns zusammen. Das war dann so an einem Donnerstagabend.
Da habe ich mich dann irgendwie hingesetzt und habe gesagt, okay,
das kann doch nicht so schwer sein.
So nämlich.
Freitagnachmittag war ich fertig und habe also ganz viel Zeit reingesteckt in
einen Tierlist-Manager.
Sehr gut.
Und dieser Tierlist-Manager hört auf den schönen Namen Rangsy.
Rangsy ist dein Tierlist-Freund.
Wo ist die Banane?
Man kann halt jetzt hier auf Rangsy gehen.
Darf ich schon mal über die Farbkontraste jetzt lästern.
Nein, darfst du nicht.
Das haben wir dir heute schon mal verboten.
Und kriegen wir das hin, dass ich das auch sehe?
Ja, das kriegen wir gleich hin, dass du das auch siehst. Also man kann jetzt
diesen Manager starten, man gibt einen Titel ein und schon hat man irgendwie eine Tierlist.
So, warum muss ich, was ist jetzt sozusagen das geile Feature da dran?
Das geile Feature da dran ist, dass ich für jede Tierlist drei URLs bekomme.
Die erste ist sozusagen für den Owner, da kann man dann alles editieren.
ja und man kann jetzt einfach irgendwelche Bilder von seiner Festplatte nehmen
und die da unten in diese weiße Haltebox in diese Holdingbox reinwerfen und
sich da sozusagen das zusammenbauen die zweite URL ist für Leute die das benutzen
sollen und dort Dinge in tiers einsortieren sollen,
die können das dann zwar nicht mehr ändern oder neue Dinge hinzufügen oder Namen
ändern oder so aber können zumindest das benutzen und dann gibt es noch eine dritte URL,
und bei der dritten URL kann man einfach nur zugucken.
Das ist geil.
Das ist doch mal gut.
Und was auch noch ganz cool ist, ist, dass das Ding natürlich auch noch ein
schönes Admin-Dashboard hat, wo ich dann irgendwie in der Datenbank sofort sehen
kann, was denn so für Tierlisten in meinem System sind.
Und da habe ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel eine,
Tierlist angelegt, die sich mit Programming Languages befasst.
Ich habe das ein bisschen groß gemacht, muss das hier mal so ein bisschen 75%
runtersoomen und du siehst, hier gibt es irgendwie eine Liste,
wo ganz viele Programmiersprachen mit ihren Logos schon bereitgelegt sind und
ich könnte jetzt hier eine nehmen und die irgendwo hinziehen.
So, oder auch wieder zurückziehen und so kann man das ranken.
So, und jetzt sind wir hier in diesem Use-Modus und was ich jetzt mache ist,
ich schmeiß das jetzt in den Chat, weil wir wollen uns ja über Interfaces unterhalten,
aber wir wollen jetzt erstmal zugucken, wie der Chat meine App kaputt macht.
also werfe ich jetzt diese URL Du willst.
Das Internet brennen.
Sehen Ich will das Internet brennen sehen und ich will jetzt sehen,
wie das jetzt irgendwie funktioniert, weil das ist halt auch ein sehr schönes
Beispiel für so eine Real-Time Multi-User Anwendung in Elixir,
das ist natürlich alles in Phoenix Live View geschrieben Wie.
Lange hast du daran gebaut, an dem was ich jetzt hier sehe?
Nach 24 Stunden war ich fertig ich habe aber auch geschlafen zwischendurch.
Was ich hier bisher sehe. Ich habe jetzt gerade mal eine Tierlist Depeche Mode
Albums gemacht mit Drag & Drop aus Google Coversuche raus. Das ist schon ein
sehr schön, Tim. Das sieht gut aus.
Und vor allem, es funktioniert auch mit Touch. Also ich habe das sozusagen nicht
nur auf dem Desktop mit Drag & Drop, sondern auch mit Touch Events hinbekommen.
Mit dem Scrolling ist das sozusagen noch so eine Sache. Aber wir sehen jetzt
live hier auf dem Beamer gerade.
Achso, du hast auch die URL angeklickt, Luca. Siehst du das auch?
Ich sehe das auch. Aber vor allem sehe
ich, das Admin-Dashboard hat keine Authentifizierung. Was ist denn da los?
Doch, hat es.
Nee.
Wie, du bist da jetzt so reingekommen? Echt? Ich hab doch da eine Authentifizierung drauf.
Irgendjemand räumt alles nach F. Na gut.
Jetzt macht mir mal nicht mein System hier kaputt.
Security und Vibe-Coding.
Nee, ich hab da eine Basic Authentication drauf eigentlich. Wieso ist die denn
nicht da auf einmal? Äh...
Tatsache. Wieso ist das denn?
Das ist ein schickes Endment, der Sport. Das ist cool.
Ja, das ist cool. Aber jetzt muss man den Chat natürlich bitten,
hier mal nichts kaputt zu machen.
Ich frage mich jetzt nur gerade, warum das so ist.
Da war ich jetzt nicht drauf vorbereitet. Wieso findest du diesen Fehler jetzt erst?
Ich habe das ja vorher noch nicht gesehen.
Das habe ich dir doch gezeigt, das Teil.
Du hast mir davon erzielt.
Ich habe es dir nicht gezeigt?
Nee. Ich sehe das gerade zum ersten Mal.
Ich hätte ein paar UX-Requests.
Nee, nee, nee, darum geht es ja jetzt nun überhaupt nicht. Ich muss jetzt erstmal
kurz hier schauen, dass das System hier irgendwie überlebt, weil ich frage mich
jetzt gerade, was ich jetzt hier falsch gemacht haben kann.
Mal gucken, vielleicht kann ich das ja hier noch in Echtzeit retten oder ich
bin verloren und dann ist alles ganz schlimm.
Oh, jetzt habe ich so einen Basic-Auth-Dialog. Interessant.
Aha.
Ja, der hat die AI zugehört.
Aber kann das irgendwie mit dem Fly zu tun haben? Mit dem Fly-Deployment irgendwie?
Ah, nee, ich hab's einfach gehackt, Tim. Ich kann dir das nachher sagen,
wie ich da hingekommen bin.
Ja, ich hab das aber auch gerade ausprobiert und hab das auch hinbekommen ohne Authentication.
Okay, gut.
Ja, dann schreib mir mal kurz, was ich dagegen tun kann.
Achso, nee, das weiß ich nicht.
Achso, toll.
Also ja, ich habe da Ideen, das liegt halt irgendwie an der Live-View-Navigation,
die du benutzt Wenn du per Live-View dahin navigierst, anstatt per URL aufs
Admin-Dashboard dann wird die,
Authentifizierung irgendwie nicht gemacht, so scheint es mir.
Warum ist denn hier bei den Programmiersprachen kein Lua dabei? Ich prangere das an.
Lua? Ah, sicher? Okay, das könnte ich natürlich noch nachliefern.
Müsste ich aber ein Icon haben für Lua.
Lua-Logo. So.
Ja, aber das gibt's doch.
Ein heftiger, ja, es gibt einen heftigen Fight gerade hier auch sozusagen,
jetzt ist R auf einmal auf S.
Also der Chat kann sich noch nicht so richtig drauf einigen.
Was ist denn SIG für eine Programmiersprache?
Das ist ein neues C im Prinzip.
Noch nie gehört.
Tim, würde man diesen Modus, so ganz viele Leute wuseln jetzt hier gerade auf
einem und demselben Dashboard quasi rum, würde man das nicht so haben wollen,
dass sich jeder sein eigenes Set macht und dann quasi ein Mittelwert berechnet wird?
Das ist jetzt so die Gruppenwinnerliste.
Das ist doch viel schöner.
Also sowas kann man natürlich machen, Aber,
das ist nicht das, was ich machen wollte.
Mach es mal so.
So, also du wolltest jetzt noch Lua dabei haben.
Hast du gesagt? Bitte darum.
Ja, dann schau ich mal, was ich... Ist dann Ada dabei?
Ada fehlt auch meistens.
Ja? Weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht.
Ada ist...
Es war gar nicht so einfach für Programmiersprachen da eine,
immer ein gutes Logo zu finden, was irgendwie auch funktioniert.
Aber ich sehe, für Logo gibt es ein Logo.
Für Logo habe ich ein Logo gemacht, weil ich dachte mir, ein Logo muss ein Logo haben. Ja, Logo.
Aber jetzt funktioniert für mich auf einmal der Upload auf einmal nicht.
Wieso das denn nicht? Das ist ja auch lustig.
Also wie gesagt, ich habe mir das in 24 Stunden irgendwie zusammengehackt und
jetzt funktioniert es irgendwie auf einmal nicht mehr so richtig.
Aha, ist ja interessant hier wahrscheinlich irgendeine Race Condition zu haben.
Naja, Software muss ja auch erstmal benutzt werden. Dann gibt es jetzt erstmal kein Lua.
Naja, auf jeden Fall sehen wir, es funktioniert und Leute haben Spaß und mittlerweile
ist auch NXCMS hier gelandet, deswegen können wir das Experiment jetzt auch
an dieser Stelle abbrechen.
Und schon weg.
Und wieder da.
Und wieder weg.
Dass das jetzt so ein Fight wird, das war mir natürlich vollkommen klar.
Aber Logo, das kennt ihr da draußen doch gar nicht. Da seid ihr doch alle vier zu jung für.
Das kann natürlich sein. Also ich habe ja auch andere Tests gemacht hier in
der Fußball-Community zum Beispiel.
Welcher Verein ist wie geil und so.
Aber wo ist denn Vorfeld? Bochum. C. Na gut.
Bochum ist C.
Direkt neben Bayern München. Die Bochum-bayerische Fan-Freundschaft.
Aber du merkst schon, Tierlists haben so ein gewisses Feuer.
Also das ist sozusagen, man ist sich nicht immer einig darüber und man kann
halt jetzt hier irgendwie bei Rangsy sehr schön sehen, wie so dieser Fight irgendwie entbrennt.
Je nach Community landet es halt so oder so oder so.
Wobei ich muss jetzt sagen, ich bin jetzt mit den Abstimmungen des Chats nur so begrenzt glücklich.
Also Clojure hat ja nun definitiv nichts in TRF zu suchen.
Ja, aber es gibt nichts Schlechteres.
Clojure ist doch nicht schlecht. Clojure ist hervorragend.
Pearl ist auch nicht schlecht.
Pearl ist definitiv nicht F.
Ja, siehst du schon. So müssen diese Diskussionen geführt werden.
Wir werden das jetzt aber anders machen. Wir werden das jetzt mit,
Interfaces machen.
So, aber nochmal Tim, das ist sehr, sehr schön, was du hier gebaut hast.
Mit 24 Stunden ist das sehr, sehr schön.
Ich kriege ein Lob, ich fasse es überhaupt nicht. Ich bin komplett durcheinander.
So, jetzt machen wir erstmal hier folgendes.
Jetzt gehen wir mal hier Use für unsere Show.
Das ist jetzt hier mal der Link für euch.
Und da kommt jetzt der Link für den Chat. Der Chat kriegt auch einen Link.
Und was ist das jetzt? Das ist jetzt unser Interface Tierlist Spielchen.
Und wie ihr seht, können wir jetzt irgendwie anfangen. Ihr könnt jetzt im Prinzip das auch benutzen.
Müsst ihr aber auch nicht. Wir können das jetzt auch gemeinsam machen.
Man kann jetzt auch darüber geteilter Meinung sein, ob es sozusagen noch relevant ist,
innerhalb eines Tieres eine Reihenfolge zu haben.
Also normalerweise ist es nicht so, dass es eine Bedeutung hat,
aber man könnte das natürlich so interpretieren.
Und ich würde sagen, wir gehen jetzt einfach mal die Interfaces mal durch und
dann schauen wir mal, was was ist, bevor ihr jetzt hier irgendwas reinschmeißt.
Wir sollten jetzt hier mal ein bisschen Konsens haben.
Ich habe die jetzt, ja, die waren irgendwie so ein bisschen sortiert, aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Wer hätte jetzt alle wieder weggegeben?
Naja, wir müssen uns ja auf was einigen.
Achso.
Ja, du solltest nicht einfach da rum fingern.
Sondern Du darfst das jetzt zwar machen, aber du sollst es jetzt nicht tun.
Man muss jetzt erstmal drüber diskutieren und wir können uns danach daran ergötzen,
dass wir hier so eine geile Multi-User-Real-Time-Webanwendung haben.
So viel ist aber nichts mit dem Spaß. Diktatur.
Unsere Tierlist ist Interfaces.
Wobei es ist ein bisschen schlecht formuliert, weil was ich eigentlich meine
ist so Physical Connection Interfaces.
Anschlüsse.
Also nicht Bluetooth, nicht WLAN, Und nicht irgendwie Software-Schnittstellen,
sondern hier geht es sozusagen um Hardware.
Aber es geht auch nicht nur um den Stecker, sondern mir geht es sozusagen um
das Interface als solches.
Also was leistet das Interface, was hat dieses Interface jemals für uns getan?
Und die sind auch fast, fast alle digital.
Und die sind vielleicht auch fast alle digital, wobei das jetzt so ein bisschen,
wieso habe ich denn hier überhaupt ein nicht digitales dabei?
Ja, VGA ist der Anzug.
Ist VGA komplett analog?
Ja.
Es gibt, ja, nee, stimmt.
So inklusive Sense-Pins für Bildschirmauflösungen und so weiter.
Ja. Aber es ist ja egal.
Nee, ja, vielleicht hätte man VGA nicht da reintun dürfen.
Aber wir können es ja weglassen. Wir haben genug Stoff, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Und die eigentliche Fragestellung ist natürlich die, was hat diese Schnittstelle jemals.
Für uns getan.
Und zwar im Kontext der Zeit, in der sie erschienen ist.
Also war es sozusagen ein großer Durchbruch? Hat es irgendwie alles andere ersetzt?
War es irgendwie scheiße zu benutzen? Hat es großartig funktioniert?
Das sind alles so Vektoren. Natürlich kann man, weil das Neueste ist natürlich immer das Tollste.
Du kannst ja sagen, alles ist scheiße und nur USB-C ist S, aber du konntest
in den 80er Jahren kein USB-C bauen und deswegen muss man halt auch immer schauen,
okay, wie gut war es denn jetzt?
Weil manchmal setzen sich die Schnittstellen ja nicht durch,
weil sie gut sind, sondern weil sie einfach zufällig billig sind,
keine Ahnung, was auch immer.
Das VHS-Problem.
Ich habe jetzt hier leider noch nicht so Metadaten, wie man könnte ja zum Beispiel
so eine Jahreszahl oder irgendein Sorting- Kriterium vielleicht noch mit erfassen.
Das habe ich jetzt irgendwie nicht mit drin.
Das kriegen wir auch so hin.
Wir könnten uns jetzt also irgendwas herausruhen. Ich stelle mal kurz die Contender
hier vor. Wie gesagt, in keiner besonders guten Reihenfolge.
Also ich hatte jetzt VGA.
Zentronics, PS2,
V24, V24, genau, das war ja gar nicht VGA, V24, MIDI, Local Talk,
ADB, HDMI, ISA, ATA, Toslink, PCM-CIA.
Und was heißt PCM-CIA?
Na?
Das I steht, glaube ich, für Industry.
People can't memorize Computer Industry Acronyms.
Achso, ja, richtig. Das war's. Ja, ja, richtig. Ich erinnere mich.
Ethernet, USB, SATA, DMX, bisschen neben der Reihe.
SD, ja, Speichermedium, kann man drüber diskutieren.
Apple Dock, also dieser 30-Pin-Stecker DVI, PCI, Nubus, SCSI,
Lightning, Thunderbolt und Firewire.
Das sind so alle, die mir eingefallen sind, die irgendwie so halbwegs Sinn ergeben haben.
Die wir zusammengetragen haben.
Genau, so hat jetzt irgendjemand einen, wir können jetzt irgendwas schon mal irgendwo platzieren.
Ich habe eigentlich nur einen Kommentar, auf den wirst du aber bestens vorbereitet
sein und eine gute Antwort haben. USB ist jetzt halt mal so alles.
Ja, bei USB war ich mir nicht so sicher, ob ich USB 1 und 2 sozusagen damit
meine und USB-C als 3.0 und so. Ich weiß, das ist sehr schwierig.
Also zwischen USB-A und USB-C.
Also ich würde jetzt nach dem Bild gehen und das einfach USB-A nennen und fertig.
Wir müssen es auch nicht zu Arschverklemmt machen alles, sondern jetzt einfach mal loslegen.
Hat jemand einen Vorschlag, womit wir anfangen?
Also ich würde mal mit V24 anfangen.
Oh ja.
Also vor allen Dingen, weil da vorne ist.
Also serielle Schnittstelle für die Leute, die nicht wissen,
was das ist. Sehr lange sehr wichtig gewesen.
Ja, aber V24, das ist ja so ein bisschen verwirrend.
Viele denken RS-232 wäre V24, ist es aber eigentlich nicht, weil V24 nämlich
auf einem anderen Signallevel arbeitet, eigentlich.
und ist dadurch, dass der mit plus minus 12 Volt, glaube ich,
arbeitet, ein extrem robuster Standard.
Also ich würde ihn relativ weit oben ansetzen, schon alleine deshalb,
weil RS-232 als der Nachfolger davon halt immer noch im Einsatz ist.
Es gibt da immer noch die Server, wo du vorne dein sehr helles Kabel reinstecken
kannst, um die Kiste, weiß ich nicht, aus welchem Zustand wieder rauszuholen, wenn es sein muss.
Also erst war V24 da und dann R232C?
Ja.
Ich weiß schon.
Aha. Also, einfach mal die Intelligenz gefragt.
V24, R232C beziehen sich beide auf serielle Schnittstellenstandards,
sind aber nicht identisch. Sie stammen aus verschiedenen Normierungssystemen
und decken unterschiedliche Aspekte ab.
Ursprung und Zweck V24, Definition elektrischer Signale und Signalbelegungen
für serielle Kommunikation, was bei Modems.
R232C, technischer Standard für elektrische Eigenschaften und Steckverbinder
der seriellen Schnittstelle.
Also die ergänzen sich in gewisser Hinsicht. Von daher rede ich dann doch eher von V24.
Egal, also ich würde sagen, die serielle Schnittstelle als solche ähm,
Also ich würde sagen, mindestens B.
Ja. Ralf?
Ja, hätte ich jetzt erstmal keine,
Einbände.
Luca?
Zu diesem Interface habe ich keine Meinung. Das ist so weit vor meiner Zeit.
Ernsthaft? Also, ich meine, jedes Terminal irgendwie war über V24,
jedes Modem, also V24 war unser Gateway in das Das war ein Workhorse.
Damit hat man alles angeschlossen.
Genau, aber man muss auch sagen, unterschiedliche Stecker, unterschiedliche
Belege, Kabel, wo nicht immer jeder PIN war,
das ganze Signaling war mal so, mal so, 7-Bit, 8-Bit, irgendwie Parität und so weiter.
Man musste echt viel konfigurieren. Also ich würde sagen, VGA definitiv.
V24.
Also sicherlich nicht weniger als B. Ja, also das ist einfach eine sehr wichtige Schnittstelle.
Großartig war es nicht definitiv kein S.
Nee, war nie richtig geil, aber hat immer robust seinen Dienst getan.
So, dann machen wir noch weiter mit Centronics. Wer kennt das noch?
Das war wahrscheinlich auch weit vor deiner Zeit, Luca.
Ja, ich habe auch schon mal irgendwie alte Drucker benutzt.
Das ist schon das.
Ne?
Centronics ist dieser Parallelport, aber mit diesem komischen Stecker.
Genau, dicker, fetter Stecker, der sehr viel Platz verbraucht,
sehr clumsy, aber was man definitiv Zentronics zugutehalten muss,
da ist irgendwie immer klar gewesen,
wie das Interface ist. Also wenn es Zentronics war, einfach ran und hat funktioniert.
Außerdem war das noch diese D-Stecker, die immer noch diese Klammern an der
Seite hatte, mit denen man den aber auch so richtig schön an den Rechner ran
machen kann, ohne zu schrauben.
Vor allen Dingen, ich meine, als der noch akut war, waren die Drucker auch so
groß, dass die Größe des Steckers nicht weiter gestört hat.
Das stimmt allerdings.
definitiv genau, also ich bin da ein bisschen,
ich meine man konnte mit Centronics jetzt nicht so sehr viel anfangen,
also V24 war definitiv Versatiler und Centronics war halt so Printer only,
es war also wirklich eine Schnittstelle, die echt nur für Drucker war auf.
Der anderen Seite, man konnte mit Centronics auch nie viel falsch machen hat
das Ding eingesteckt und dann hat es auch im Prinzip funktioniert,
also dazwischen stand noch einen Druckertreiber meistens, aber da kann ja der Stecker nichts für.
Ja, trotzdem. Also es hat irgendwas mit Druckern zu tun, also würde ich schon
mal mindestens ein Tier abziehen.
Ich würde den jetzt auch nicht in S oder A tun, aber ich finde ein B hat der auch verdient.
Ralf?
Da bin ich ein bisschen emotionslos.
Da bist du emotionslos. Ich sage auch C, also das ist definitiv,
ja, also das ist halt nicht so geil jetzt wie V24, nicht so universell,
und hatte auch nicht so die Bedeutung. Es war halt nur bei Druckern.
Ja, schon, aber wo ich sage, zuverlässig. Irgendwo weiter hinten ist SCSI.
Da würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, das hat immer gut funktioniert.
Ja, okay, gut. Wir können das ja auch noch justieren. Das ist ja alles nicht final.
Aber AC ist auch okay.
Wollen wir erstmal in der Vergangenheit bleiben?
Ich würde sagen, die schönen alten Sachen.
Die räumen wir erstmal ab. Okay, dann können wir eigentlich mit SCSI auch gleich
weitermachen. Wo ist es denn? Hier.
Das ist nämlich eigentlich auch fast der gleiche Stecker.
Der sieht sehr ähnlich aus. Also ich wäre sogar so drauf, dass ich sage D.
Also SCSI, wer kennt es nicht? Ralf, hast du SCSI?
Ich habe die selber verbaut bei Comtech im Laden. War nie Fan von.
Vor allen Dingen Terminatoren. Ich sage nur Terminatoren. Wackelige Kabel.
Also zuverlässig ist anders.
Also wer nicht weiß, was SCSI ist. Also Small Computer System Interface heißt das, glaube ich.
Und es war in Ende der 90er Jahre, Ende der 80er Jahre in die 90er rein.
Bis Anfang 90er würde ich sagen.
War es noch eine ganze Weile in die 90er rein. Für große Festplatten und dann auch für Scanner.
Für Scanner, ja.
Flachbrett-Scanner.
Auch diese Optical Drives, die man beschreiben konnte.
Der große CD-ROM, das erste CD-ROM von Apple, das war alles noch SCSI und das
war am Mac einfach der Standard.
Und immer so ein bisschen obskur, weil auf dem auf der Rechnerseite war das
glaube ich ein DB25 Stecker und auf der Peripherie war es dann dieser wulstige
oder war das nicht sowieso?
Ja, aber ich glaube, das war so ein Mac-Ding, dass der auf der Rechnerseite ein DB25 war.
Keine Ahnung. Also das ist so...
Ah, da steht es ja. Apple-Stecker. Sie schreiben Apple-Stecker.
Es fehlen zahlreiche Masseleitungen. So, so.
Ja, also das mit diesen Terminatoren, das war natürlich immer das Schlimmste.
Großer Mist.
Also man konnte das Ding halt im Bus anordnen, aber du musstest dann diesen
Bus korrekt terminieren.
Also man musste die Daisy chainen, eins nach dem anderen und das letzte Gerät
musste den Terminator haben.
Also einigen wir uns doch auf eine D.
Ich würde D sagen.
Ja.
Klingt gut.
Ja, okay, ich denke auch, dass also wenn Zentronics auf C ist.
Also es hat irgendwie immer funktioniert, aber es war nie geil.
Genau, es war nie geil, das stimmt. Es war überhaupt nicht geil. So.
Local Talk ist vielleicht auch noch in der Altersstufe?
Definitiv. Local Talk.
War im Prinzip ein serieller Stecker von Apple für Apple?
Von Apple für Apple basierte auf dem RS422 Interface.
Also das war ein serielles RS422 Interface und Apple hat das mit 230 Kilobit pro Sekunde.
Da fliegt Da fliegt einem der Hut weg. Aber damals, muss man sagen, hatten wir ja nichts.
Wir hatten ja nichts.
Und was ja so Leute aus der Windows-PC-Welt nie kannten, war ja,
man konnte so zwei Macintoshes eben mit diesem relativ günstigen Kabel,
ja mal so einem seriellen Schnittstellenkabel miteinander verbinden und dann hatte man...
Apple Talk.
Dann hatte man ein lokales Netzwerk.
Da hatte man ein lokales Netzwerk und dann konnte man dem Drucker auch über
Local Talk anschließen und dann tauchte der Drucker in einem Chooser auf.
Da gab es dieses Programm Chooser und der Chooser hat im Prinzip einen Scan
auf dem Netzwerk gemacht und die Devices haben sich gemeldet.
So wie man das halt heute von Bonjour kennt.
Bonjour, was von Apple tatsächlich auch in die Welt gebracht wurde,
weil eben auch in der IP-Welt dieses Feature immer gefehlt hat.
Ja, also niemand ist auf die Idee gekommen, dass ein Gerät sich im Netzwerk
vielleicht mal mit einem Namen und einer Dienstklassifizierung einfach mal melden
und sagt, hallo, hier bin ich.
Und das war halt bei Apple Talk immer von Anfang an der Fall.
Und ich kann dir sagen, Laserweiter anschließen, Macintosh daneben.
Local Talk Kabel dazwischen und das Ding sagt einfach, hallo,
ich bin's, dein Laserwriter. Ich bin hier.
Wähl mich aus. Im Chooser. Und dann klickst du einfach dieses scheiß Symbol
an und dann hast du deinen Droger gesetzt.
Und dann sagst du Print und dann kommt die Seite raus.
Das hat zehn Jahre gedauert, bis der Rest der Welt diesen Level an Qualität
im Leben leisten konnte.
Und Local Talk mag langsam gewesen sein, aber Local Talk war unkompliziert,
dünnes Kabel, einfacher Stecker, ordentlich beschriftet, reinstecken und du
hast schon mal ein Computernetzwerk, wo die anderen Leute noch nicht mal davon
gehört haben, dass es sowas gibt.
Ich würde sagen, LocalTalk definitiv ein A.
Weil no hassle, viel Funktionalität, okay nicht schnell, aber für die damalige
Zeit einfach eine sehr billige Lösung und ich habe noch nie gehört,
dass irgendjemand mit Local Talk irgendein Problem hatte. Später gab es dann noch PhoneNet.
Das war dann quasi für RJ11-Anschlüsse. Da hast du so einen kleinen Transziver
hinten reingesteckt und dann konntest du einfach normales Telefonkabel machen.
Und dann hattest du einfach in bestehenden Telefonvernetzungen in Firmen konntest
du mal eben das Netzwerk dann auch über verschiedene Etagen und so weiter aufbauen.
Einfach über die Telefonverkabelung.
Also grandios.
Ich sage A, weil wenig spricht.
Es ist nichts Schlechtes dran.
Ja, es war auch immer ein bisschen langsam, aber gut.
Ja, es war schneller als alles andere, weil es nichts anderes gab.
Ja, bis so irgendeine andere Lösung aufgebaut hat, das hast du über Local Talk
das Fall schon übertragen.
Also zu dem Zeitpunkt war Ethernet noch auf diesem Thinnet-Koaxialkabelstecker.
Stimmt, war nicht mehr Fick.
Ja, ja, also das war definitiv nicht so gut wie Local Talk.
Übrigens, kleine Anekdote. auf der Easter Hack in Hamburg, da hatte irgend so
ein Typ alte Unix Workstations mitgebracht und hatte die da am Laufen und der
hatte tatsächlich ein Thick-Ethernet-Kabel auch dabei.
Das dicke Wurst.
Wow, dicke Kälbe, Yellow Kälbe.
Genau, mit den Vampirklemmen und all dem. Ich fand das super.
Das erste Mal, dass ich das gesehen habe, ist mir aufgefallen.
Ich dachte mal, es wäre noch dicker, das Kabel. Aber so richtig dick ist es dann doch nicht.
So, wir müssen langsam in die Neuzeit kommen, Sonst verlieren wir hier unsere Jungspunde.
Ja, aber haben wir noch irgendwas, was noch alt ist?
Ja, wir haben was Altes, was es auch noch lange gehalten hat.
Mal ein kleiner Ausflug in die Audio-Welt. Wie wär's denn mal mit Tosslink?
MIDI ist älter, oder?
MIDI ist gute, satte 8-Bit-Zeit.
82.
Lass uns erst mal MIDI machen.
Ja, also da würde ich natürlich jetzt ein großes Plädoyer für MIDI halten.
Der Stecker war halt immer so, mäh.
Dienstecker, 5-Polig, nicht toll. Aber ohne MIDI wären weite Teile der modernen
Musikproduktion nie entstanden, auf die Art und Weise, wie sie entstanden sind.
Es ist einfach Dinge, Computer, Synthesizer, Expander,
Master, Keyboards, alles miteinander verbunden und jeder wusste genau,
was zu tun ist und das Konzept mit in,
out und through war schon auch immer ein bisschen weird alles,
aber am Ende des Tages liefen die Dinge, die Auflösung war nicht toll mit nur
128 verschiedenen Anschlagsstärken und sowas, aber es hat halt gereicht,
um dahin zu kommen, wo wir musiktechnisch heute sind.
Von daher mindestens ein A. Ich finde, MIDI haben wir viel zu verdanken.
Das Protokoll ist so simpel.
Kannst du geile Sachen darüber machen.
Ja, so simpel ist es schon ein bisschen zu simpel eigentlich.
Ja, viel.
Nee, das eigentlich geile an dem MIDI-Stecker-Standard war, und das hat keiner
der anderen Standards, ist die galvanische Trennung.
Du hast nämlich immer auf der Empfangsseite eine Leuchtdiode gehabt,
der gegenüber ein Fototransistor war.
Das heißt, die Geräte, die du mit MIDI zusammengesteckt hast,
waren tatsächlich elektrisch voneinander getrennt.
Ach echt? Und das ist sichergestellt?
Das ist extra für oder gegen Brummen?
Gegen Brummschleifen. Dafür haben sie das gemacht. Gegen Brummschleifen. schleifen.
Das heißt, jedes MIDI-Interface hat immer diese Leuchtdiode in der Buchse?
Ja.
Ah, das wusste ich gar nicht.
Wusste ich auch nicht. Schon was gelernt.
Also das finde ich schon großartig. Also klar, ist natürlich sehr direkt, wofür es designt wurde.
Also ich, keine Ahnung, ich war nie großer Fan von MIDI, aber ich könnte mir
ein S trotzdem vorstellen.
Also ich muss auch sagen, MIDI, ich meine, MIDI ist, so alt dieses Protokoll
ist und so einfach es ist, und man könnte ihm das vorwerfen,
dass es alt und einfach ist, aber...
Alt und bezahlt.
Als es neu war, war es ja nicht alt.
Als es neu war, war es nicht alt. Und es ist vor allem ein Standard,
der sich bis heute gehalten hat, ohne dass man groß unter ihm leiden muss.
Also MIDI ist nach wie vor Go-To.
Du gehst zu Thomann und du kriegst tonnenweise MIDI-Geräte.
Heutzutage natürlich primär alles erstmal über USB, Gar keine Frage,
also das Protokoll als solches, das Interface, deswegen wollte ich auch so eine
etwas weitere Definition haben von Interface, auch wenn es seinen physikalischen
Transport ein bisschen dann gewandelt hat, aber es zeigt sich ja,
sowohl die alte MIDI-Verkabelung ist auch nach wie vor valide,
wird auch teilweise immer noch in Racks benutzt.
Es gibt jetzt in dem Sinne auch gar kein anderes Kabel.
Es gibt nur bessere Computerverbindungen, aber untereinander sind die nach wie
vor mit diesem MIDI-Kabel ausgestattet.
Und die eigentliche Beschränkung mit diesen 16 Kanälen, die so ein bisschen
wenig erscheint heutzutage, hat aber irgendwie auch gereicht.
und kannst es auch irgendwie gut multiplexen und pipapo und verschiedene Busse
haben und die Computer haben dann eh viel ausgeglichen.
Also ich würde sagen, MIDI ist ein S-Tier.
Ja, ja. Auch wenn es immer viel gefrickelt war am Ende des Tages.
Weil du musst es immer viel einstellen.
Achso, Sonderregel S-Tier, wir müssen uns auch alle einig sein,
dass irgendwas S-Tier ist.
Ich habe da keinen Widerspruch. MIDI hat mir viel bedeutet.
Wir haben den ersten S-Tier. Okay.
Dann vielleicht noch aus der alten Zeit den PS2 den PS2.
Der ist ja auch immer noch da und das ist ja vor allem so ein komisches Doppelinterface der ist.
Eigentlich nicht mehr da,
Du findest kaum noch Mainboards, wo so ein PS2 dran ist. Nein, nein.
Tonnenweise.
Tonnenweise, nein, nein.
Also ich habe es zumindest noch vor nicht langer Zeit gesehen.
Ob ich jetzt noch die neuesten Rechner, die noch habe, weiß ich nicht.
Meistens 25 langsame USB-Buchsen dran, aber PS2 findest du nicht mehr so oft.
Aber es hat es sehr lange gegeben. Kleine Fangfrage, warum heißt dieser Steckerstandard
so wie er heißt? Nicht nachgucken.
Nicht.
Weil IBM das Personal System 2 damals auf den Markt gab.
Ah, genau.
Zudem auch das Operating System 2 gehörte, das OS Halbe, wie es manche nennen.
Genau. OS 2.
OS 2.
Ja, das war auch ein großer Wurf.
Ja, da ging man leider ins Leere.
Die einen sagen so, die anderen so.
Naja, geht so. Also OS2 kam ja, also erstens habe ich mal was mit OS2 sehr erfolgreich
gemacht und von daher bin ich OS2 ewig dankbar und zweitens hat OS2 noch sehr
lange in deutschen Geldautomaten überlebt.
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich mal in einem deutschen Geldautomaten,
das darf man eigentlich gar nicht erzählen, habe ich es mal erlebt,
dass zwischen den Hin- und Herklicken
auf irgendwelchen, nee es war ein Kontoausdrucksdrucker, aber ist egal,
Hin- und Herklicken der Menüs tauchte immer so ein Terminalfenster immer zwischendrin auf.
und ich habe dann mit relativ hektischem Rumgetippe, hatte ich dann plötzlich
dieses Terminalfenster, es blieb dann vorne und es war eine Rootshell.
Aber mangelst Tastatur konnte ich da nie was mit anstellen.
Es ist sehr schade, aber wer auch immer dieses Ding gewartet hat,
hat seine Shell nicht zugemacht.
Vielleicht wäre ja irgendwo ein PS2-Interface gewesen.
Also ich versuche jetzt aber nochmal ein paar inhaltliche Punkte hier zu bringen.
Also PS2 ist ja deshalb ungewöhnlich, weil es so ein Doppelinterface ist.
Einmal Tastatur, einmal Maus und die Stecker sind eigentlich exakt dieselben.
Aber sie sind unterschiedlich Farben.
Aber sie sind farbcodiert. Das heißt, das ist der einzige Stecker hier in unserem
ganzen Brimborium, wo die Farbe wirklich eine entscheidende Rolle spielt und
auch diese Farbe war fest verdrahtet.
Das heißt also, die Tastatur war immer lila.
Ich finde, das sind sehr schöne Farben und die Maus so ein schönes Mintgrün.
das heißt also vom Style Faktor her würde ich mal sagen ist PS2 ja definitiv
der Gewinner, endlich mal Farbe an die Stecker wir.
Müssen nochmal kurz überlegen was hat das denn abgelöst,
Wie waren denn die Tastaturen?
Beim IBM PC.
Der PC war so ein DIN-Stecker, so ein dicker, fetter Tastaturstecker.
Mit so einem Spiralkabel dran.
Glaube ich. Meistens mit Spiralkabeln, aber das ist ja für den Stecker jetzt
unerheblich. Und die Mäuse gab es nicht.
Gab es keinen, war V24, glaube ich.
Die Mäuse waren entweder seriell oder es gab gar keine Mäuse.
V24, genau. Das heißt, es waren so zwei sehr unterschiedliche Beile, sehr dick.
Und V24 brauchte man halt eigentlich für andere Sachen, fürs Modem und so.
Und dann Maus da anschließen.
Meistens gab es gleich noch eine Steckkarte zur Maus dazu, damit man noch einen
weiteren Port hatte, wo man die Maus anschließen kann.
Also das war auf jeden Fall ganz schlimm.
Da war PS2 ein großer Fortschritt.
Da war das ein Improvement, war aber trotzdem nie ein geiler Port.
Nee, also ich würde sagen C.
Also ich meine, nach meiner Zuverlässigkeitskriterium liegt er natürlich schon
relativ weit vorne, weil das hat irgendwie immer funktioniert.
Also ich hätte mir jetzt nur ein B gegeben.
Aber ich würde auch ins C-Horn stoßen.
Also hier, Farbcodierung war übrigens am Anfang noch gar nicht da,
das kam erst viel später.
Ich fand, der steckt sich auch ganz angenehm, schreibt Felix.
Ist nämlich auch so ein Faktor.
Immer so ein bisschen Angst, die kaputt zu machen, wenn man die falsch anguckt.
Ich würde sagen, zusammen so mit Zentronics als Single-Purpose Interface,
das passt schon irgendwie ganz gut.
Wir können das ja auch nachher noch mal reviewen, falls uns das irgendwie nicht gefällt.
Der Chat könnte übrigens mal sagen, ob das Beobachten unserer Aktivität hier
im Web, ob das irgendwie gut funktioniert. Ich wäre schon froh,
dass es hier nicht abschmiert.
So, da müssen wir aber natürlich als nächstes ADB aufrufen. Der Apple Desktop Bus.
Da bin ich echt blank, nie gehört.
Was? Das ist nicht dein Ernst. Was war dein erster Mac?
Hatten wir doch irgendwann mal ein Lion oder sowas zu der Zeit.
Lion? Nein, was sein erster Mac war.
Ja, ein MacBook Pro vor 14 Jahren.
ADB war einfach nicht...
Im Prinzip ein Vorgänger zu USB, könnte man fast nicht behaupten.
Seit, ich glaube, Macintosh 2.
Kann sein.
Seit dem Mac 2 gibt es ADB und der Apple Desktop-Bus ist genau das.
what it says on the tin. Also du könntest dort halt alle möglichen Desktop-Bus-Devices
anschließen, mit anderen Worten, die Tastatur.
Und die Maus.
Und die Maus und das halt auch Daisy-Chain, weil es halt ein Bus ist.
Das heißt, du hast die Maus an die Tastatur angeschlossen und die Tastatur an
den Rechner so, wie sich das gehört und nicht wie bei den PCs mit ihrem komischen PS2.
Zwei Kabel ziehen.
Und ADB hat sehr lange gehalten. Also das ADB-Keyboards, ADB-Mäuse, all das.
Naja, bis zu dem ursprünglichen iMac, wo nur noch USB dran war.
Genau. Bis zum iMac gab es ADB. Und das war eigentlich das Achievement.
Und ich bin von daher fast gehalten zu sagen, das hat seine Aufgabe hervorragend
gelöst. Es gab nie Ärger mit ADB.
Ich würde es in B tun, weil ich meine, das ist jetzt auch kein so doller Standard,
aber er hat immer gut funktioniert. Das sage ich jetzt bei fast allen.
Aber nö, also er war auch nicht klobig oder clunky oder irgendwas.
Ich glaube, es war sogar ziemlich genau der gleiche Stecker wie PS2.
Also zumindest war er sehr ähnlich.
Sehr ähnlicher Stecker.
Sehr ähnlich. Aber er ist definitiv über PS2. Also das würde ich schon mal sagen.
Ja, also B muss es mindestens sein.
Na, wegen mir.
Dann machen wir mal B. So, noch mehr alte Scheiße. Ich habe jetzt auch mal hier
so Steckkarten mit reingenommen, weil das ja eigentlich auch Interface sind.
Dann müsstest du wahrscheinlich den Nubus als nächstes nehmen.
Okay, naja, eigentlich, ich weiß nicht.
ISA, meinetwegen auch erst ISA.
Die ISA-Karten.
ISA, also ISA, oh Mann. ISA, für wer wieder nicht weiß, was Sache ist.
Ich habe es schon mal benutzt, glaube ich. Du hast es schon mal ISA benutzt.
ISA ist der allererste Expansion. Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Genau, das ist sozusagen das Original IBM PC Erweiterungsinterface,
Industry Standard Architecture. Also die Abkürzung sagt schon alles.
War auch ein Industriestandard.
ISA, zum Reinstecken von Karten, war eine Vollkatastrophe.
Also nicht nur, dass es immer total schwierig war, diese Karten in diese Rechner
reinzuprokeln und wieder rauszubekommen. Und zu schrauben.
Festzuschrauben.
Und dann musste man meistens dann noch so Dipswitche einstellen.
Und dann musste man noch so IRQ einstellen. Und dann musste man IRQ.
Genau. Und Adressräume vergeben und lauter so ein Ding.
Zum Kotzen.
The full Monty.
Also Isar, würde ich sagen, ist für mich ein klarer Kandidat für F.
Das ist wirklich so, okay, man konnte es irgendwie erweitern,
aber es war einfach nicht mal the bare minimum, haben sie darüber nachgedacht.
Das war einfach ein geistloser, gefühlloser Angriff auf die Benutzerschaft.
Ja, man muss ihm zugutehalten, dass darüber natürlich dann schon sehr komplexe
Erweiterungen möglich waren.
Also sprich, du hattest dann halt schon irgendwie eine Superspezial-Audiokarte
plötzlich an deinem Rechner, was der selber nicht konnte.
Das geht mit vielen der anderen Anschlüsse alle nicht.
Aber der Standard an sich war ein Scheiß.
Da ist PCI drin.
Audiokarte.
Da ist Nubus dabei.
Das Wort allein. Audiokarte. Ich bin ja froh, dass es mittlerweile nicht mehr existiert.
Oder sagen Leute noch Audiokarte? Das hat sich so ein bisschen gehalten, eine Audiokarte.
Man nennt es Audio-Interface inzwischen.
Ja, ich glaube auch. Aber lange Zeit hießen auch Audio-Interfaces Audio-Karte,
weil man das so gewohnt war.
Naja, aber als Steckkarte gibt es die schon lange nicht mehr.
Also als überheblicher und versnobbter Macintosh-Benutzer, der ich eindeutig bin, gerne auch,
Nichts hat mich so sehr dazu gebracht, auf PC-Menschen hinabzuschauen wie Audiokarten.
Weil erstens, dass es überhaupt erforderlich war, eine zu haben.
Also, dass der Computer noch nicht mal Audio abspielen konnte.
und dann was war das für ein was war das für ein Spießrutenlauf den die Leute
machen mussten um die zum Laufen zu kriegen also Soundblaster Karten und dann
welcher IAQ und irgendwie Obwohl Soundblaster waren die ersten.
Die überhaupt ordentlich funktioniert haben Ja.
Aber ich meine, was war denn das für ein Kampf, das hat ja Jahre gedauert bis
sie überhaupt mal Töne abspielen konnten.
Dazu muss man aber sagen, also gerade so ISA und diesen ganzen anderen Gedöns
Da sieht man halt sehr stark an,
dass IBM damals den eigenen Rechner, den sie auf den Markt gebracht haben,
nicht ernst genommen haben, sondern dass sie den im Prinzip aus der Resteschublade
zusammengekleistert haben und weil irgendwie Management hat gesagt,
wir brauchen sowas und gib ihm.
Und ich glaube, gerade ISA zeigt sehr deutlich, dass da überhaupt keiner Bock
drauf hatte, das ordentlich zu machen.
Also wir hatten die Debatte schon mal, Tim, und ich werde jetzt exakt das wieder abspulen.
Ja, du hast recht, was irgendwie Standard-Soundkarten anging,
aber es ermöglichte halt PC-Jüngern wie mir, die ich damals war,
solche Goldstücke, wie die hier gerade im Chat gepostete Soundblaster AWE32 zu installieren,
auf der ich noch günstigen Speicher installieren konnte, um dann die Original-Soundbänke
der Depeche Mode Original-Emulator-Synthesizer dort draufzunehmen.
zu laden und hochprofessionell Musik zu machen, was zu dem Zeitpunkt auf dem
Level mit keinem Mac der Welt möglich war.
Aha.
So, das heißt also, ja, das hatte einen riesigen Range, die Soundkarten,
ja, aber es gab im PC-Bereich Soundkarten, die irre waren, was sie geleistet haben.
Und das muss hier protokolliert werden. Malding machen wir eine Tierlist mit,
Erweiterungskarten, aber der Isabus war scheiße.
Der Isabus war scheiße.
Und der Isabus ist für mich einfach eine F. So, bam.
Wobei man sagen muss, ich meine, im Macintosh-Bereich gab es auch lange Soundkarten.
Also dieses ganze Pro Tools-Gedöns war ja im Prinzip auch,
nur, ich stecke ganz viele Karten nebeneinander und klemme die dann auch noch
mit einem extra Kabel zusammen, damit die auch etwas mehr Daten übertragen können.
Meine Herren, war das ein Gefrickel.
Das stimmt. Insofern können wir dann auch gleich auf den Macintosh-Bus gehen. Nubus.
Mit dem habe ich also überhaupt gar keine Erfahrung gehabt.
Ja, ich schon.
Ich auch nicht.
Also Nubus ist halt, also die Macintosh 2, seit dem Macintosh 2,
Macintosh 2 CI, CX, diese Serie, also die 90er Jahre,
Ende der 80er kam der raus und bis es dann irgendwann PCI-Karten gab in,
keine Ahnung, wann gab es?
Das waren aber glaube ich schon Power Max.
Die Power Max hatten glaube ich auch noch Nubus.
Sicher? Ne, ich glaube damit mit PowerMax kam auch die PCI-Karten.
Sicher bin ich mir jetzt natürlich nicht.
Also ich habe jetzt ja gerade mal Bilder im Internet. Der Stecker selber ist
aber auch schon gruselig. Das sieht jetzt nicht so viel besser aus als ISA.
Wie gruselig.
Mit diesen irgendwie 80 PIN, die einfach irgendwo rumstehen.
Das ist ja eine Erweiterungskarte. Da brauchst du ja viele PINs.
Ja, aber da ist aber die Schnittstelle zum Reinstecken selber von ISA scheint
mir da aber fast robuster, ehrlich gesagt. Mach mal ein Bild rein.
Überhaupt gar kein Vergleich, mein Freund.
Also diese muckeligen, was ja dann auch bei den PCI-Karten noch übernommen wurde,
dass du nur ein Dings hast, wo du den immer in diesen Slot reinrammen musstest,
damit er sitzt da auch wirklich fest.
Nubus-Karte war halt einfach Doppelpin-Connector, das schiebst du einfach oben
drauf und das saß saftig da drauf.
Es war klar, wenn das Plastik auf Plastik ist, dann ist der Anschlag da und
dann musst du auch nichts konfigurieren, dann musst du keine IRQs einstellen,
keine DMA Sachen machen,
du hast die Karte reingesteckt, der Computer hat gesagt, oh,
diese Karte wurde gerade hier eingesteckt.
Der PC wusste ja noch nicht mal, welche Karte im Rechner ist mit ISA.
Bei ISA nicht, das kam alles später.
Und das war bei Nubus schon immer so.
Also ich habe mich jetzt nur auf diese reine Bauform mit diesen herausragenden Pins bezogen.
Also von denen habe ich, ich habe ja mal drei, vier Jahre bei Comtex Rechner
geschraubt und diese Viecher waren einfach immer die Pest.
Die sind umgeknickt, die sind verbogen und sowas hattest du mit irgendwie PCI,
Isa hattest du diese Prost.
Diese Karte, die einfach nur die Platine am Ende noch so ein paar Streifen dran
hat, das scheint mir schon robuster zu sein.
Also ich glaube, so eine Nubus-Karte willst du nicht ein Dutzend mal ein- und ausbauen.
Goldfinger nennen die sich übrigens, diese Streifen. Goldfinger.
Goldfinger heißen die?
Ja, also zumindest auf Englisch. Keine Ahnung, wie es auf Deutsch heißt.
Goldfinger. Also ich hatte einen Macintosh 2 CI Grafikkarte,
war irgendwie mit Nubus.
Ich sage nicht, dass es nicht funktioniert hätte oder so, sicherlich klar.
Völlig unproblematisch.
Nur jetzt zu sagen, dass diese Steckerform jetzt deutlich besser wäre als die
von Isar oder die jetzt auch bei PCI verwendet wird, immer noch.
Ja, weil bei Isar kannst du dir noch nicht mehr sicher sein,
ob du wirklich den Kontakt richtig hergestellt hast, weil die Karte halt unter
Umständen sich verklemmt, weil oben dieser komische Blechteil dann irgendwie
irgendwo klemmt, verbogen war.
Ja, bei diesem Pin konntest du dir sicher sein, weil du hast dann gesehen,
wie die Pins verbogen sind und nie wieder irgendwo vernünftig reinpassten.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Das Problem, also theoretisch okay, meinetwegen,
aber faktisch ist es, also das ist definitiv, finde ich, ein solides C.
Meinetwegen.
Um das abzuschließen. Alles klar. Was haben wir denn noch an ältlichen?
Was ganz furchtbares? ATA.
Auch MFM RLL oder so ähnlich hieß.
Also ATA, wofür stand ATA nochmal?
Nicht das Putzmittel, ne?
Nicht das Putzmittel, sondern ATA steht für Advanced Attachment.
Also ATA, schrecklich. Können wir vielleicht ohne größere Debatte zu F schieben.
Oder? Achso, ja.
ATA, irgendwas mit Attachment stimmt. Es heißt nämlich AT-Attachment,
weil es sich auf den IBM-Personalcomputer-slash-AT bezieht.
Und da wurde dann halt dieses Interface eingeführt, was zum Anschluss von Festplatten war.
Und zwar diese allererste Generation von Festplatten, sogenannten MFM-Platten.
Damit ging das irgendwie los.
Das ist sozusagen auch das Äquivalent.
Also, wo man wissen musste, wie viele Köpfe das Ding hat und wie viele Spuren
und, und, und, und, ah, und dann musste man das alles im BIOS eigentlich, oh nee.
Also ist alles ekelhaft, also Arta war wirklich, wirklich.
Ja, das ist F.
Er verdient das so, das ist genauso wie Isa.
Ein gutes F, ein, ja.
So.
Next. Jetzt kommen wir langsam in die Bereiche, die du auch kennen solltest, Luca, oder?
Na Arta, damit habe ich ja auch schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht.
Achso, wer hat sie nicht? Dann wähl du mal das nächste aus.
Das nächste?
Ja.
Also ich meine VGA können wir uns doch mal anschauen.
Ah, das Interface, was vielleicht gar keins ist.
Es ist kein digitaler Interface, aber es ist ein Interface.
Es ist ein Interface, das stimmt.
Ich finde es relativ furchtbar, weil es zum Beispiel auch nicht digital ist.
Ja, auf der anderen Seite, es hat lange durchgehalten, weil es war gut genug,
um lange durchzuhalten.
Es hat viel zu lange durchgehalten.
Ja, viel zu lange.
Also auch aus der Praxis, komme ich schon an, wenige Dinge habe ich so gehasst
wie VGA-Kabel. Das ist auch wirklich, die saßen nie richtig rein.
Du hast wahrscheinlich nie mit Skat-Kabeln gearbeitet.
Oh, ich habe durchaus auch mit. Die wollte ich ja drauf haben,
die wären ja noch unter F gewesen. Also sofort Skat ist also der unterste Bodensatz
von allem, was jemals an Kabel und Interfaces gebaut wurde.
Aber VGA ist auch wirklich nur sehr knapp darüber.
Von daher würde ich dem auch ein freudiges F durchaus...
Naja, ich finde, die ist es schon wert, weil es...
Es hat zumindest funktioniert.
Also die saßen so scheiße, diese Konnektoren.
Man musste sie immer feststellen.
Weil die immer stauben mussten.
Man war das Rot nicht richtig und dann musste man wieder ruckeln,
damit alle drei Farben auch zu sehen sind.
Und dann musste sie wieder ein bisschen rausschrauben, weil irgendwie sitzt das jetzt zu fest.
Und nee, furchtbar das Ding. F.
Gut, also wir schwanken.
VGA, F.
Meines Wegen auch F.
Nee, also so weit würde ich nicht gehen. Weil dafür hat es einfach viel zu lang,
also das hätte sich nicht, guck mal, Isa und Arta, das war dann auch echt irgendwann weg.
Weil das konnte dann keiner mehr sehen. Und das ist dann irgendwie besser geworden.
VGA hat sich viel länger gehalten. Das heißt, VGA war länger good enough und
damals war es auch tatsächlich,
wenn man das mal vergleicht, das hat ja, gut, das bezieht sich jetzt mehr auf
die Grafikkarten und weniger auf die Schnittstelle, da vermischt sich das jetzt
so ein bisschen, aber das war ja Fidelity.
Also VGA war ja eigentlich das erste
wirkliche akzeptable Farbbildschirminterface, was so auf dem Markt war.
Das war sozusagen das erste, wo nicht alle gleich weggelaufen sind und was auch
lange Zeit über große Auflösungen hin mitskaliert hat.
Also es hat geschafft sozusagen mitzuwachsen mit der Verbesserung der Grafikkarten
und hat trotzdem irgendwie noch gereicht.
Ich würde sagen, dann ist es eher ein D.
Ja, immerhin war es glaube ich auch der erste Stecker, der R,
G und B getrennt voneinander übertragen hat und das hat schon geholfen, auch bei der Qualität.
Können wir vielleicht DVI gleich daneben setzen?
Ja, ja.
DVI ist so ein Standard, den ich eher nach F schieben würde noch.
Was ich bei DVI immer blöd fand, ist, dass es da mehrere Varianten von gibt,
die auch ein analoges Signal unterstützen und dann hast du hier irgendwie gerade den falschen Stecker.
Also es darf auf keinen Fall besser sein als VGA.
Also ob es jetzt aber D oder F ist, da bin ich jetzt ein bisschen emotionslos.
Also schon allein, weil diese Stecker waren immer wackelig und du hattest auch
gern mal verbogene Pins.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und wenn du nicht aufgepasst hast, hast du mit einem Stecker,
der einen verbogenen Pin hat, auch noch deinen DVI-Port kaputt gemacht?
Also nee, definitiv F.
Aber wieso, das schaffst du aber auch mit VGA. Also ich fand jetzt DVI nicht
schlechter als VGA und es war zumindest digital. Und du hast dann auf einmal
eine viel bessere Bildschirmqualität als mit VGA.
Ja, aber gleichzeitig hast du diese fünf oder so verschiedenen Varianten davon, die irgendwie...
Ja, aber das hat sich dann eigentlich, das war nicht wirklich ein Problem. Also du konntest...
Ja, doch, war es schon.
Inwiefern?
Ja, weil du dann hier irgendwie gerade nur kein Dual-Link-Kabel hattest,
sondern ein Single-Link.
Also irgendwie gab es diese zwei Varianten I und D, die gab es irgendwie in
Single und Dual und die hatten mehr Pins, glaube ich.
Also ich würde es in D nehmen.
Und irgendwas Fünftes gibt es auch noch, ne?
Es gab auch so einen, wo, also auf der einen Seite ist ja so ein Kreuz,
so ein theoretisches Kreuz, das ist entweder nur vertikal oder horizontal gefüllt
oder ganz und dann gab es so Stecker, die an den vier Seiten des Kreuzes nochmal
so kleine Koaxalsteckerchen hatten.
Also das ist einfach so vom Standard her.
Das ist halt kein Standard. Nicht jedes DVI passt in jedes DVI rein.
Das ist dann kein richtiger Standard.
Also es gab drei Varianten. Es gab das analoge, nur analog, DVI-A,
das habe ich aber in the wild nirgendwo gesehen.
Dann DVI-D, das ist Digital Only und dann gab es DVI-I, das ist beides.
und das ist dieser komische Kreuzteil auf diesem Stecker ist halt der analoge
Teil und der Rest ist halt digital und DVI ist halt elektrisch kompatibel mit HDMI,
also das war im Prinzip so der Vorläufer eigentlich auch von HDMI,
von DVI aus hat sich alles entwickelt und von daher war es der erste digitale,
Bildschirmstandard überhaupt und ich muss sagen,
ja okay das war jetzt alles nicht so optimal vielleicht, dass es zwei Varianten
gab, aber es war ja auch ein Transition-Interface.
Also es ging ja auch darum, sozusagen eine Rückwärtskompatibilität herzustellen.
Es hat sich am Ende nicht so lange im Markt gehalten, weil der Stecker war dann
zu groß und vor allem sind die Grafikkarten,
sehr viel schneller besser geworden, sodass dann immer die Übertragungsraten
wieder nicht ausgereicht haben und nachgebessert werden musste.
Aber das war dann, sagen wir mal, ich würde nicht sagen, dass es F ist,
weil es war keine Vollkatastrophe.
Es hat das erste mal digitale Anstauung eines Bildschirms gebracht.
Ja, aber geil war es auch nicht. Die Stecker haben nie richtig gesessen und
haben immer wackelig und rausgefallen und so.
Also VGA hast du wenigstens angeballert und dann hieb das Ding.
Bei DVI-Kasse auch festschrauben.
Nee, da waren nicht immer überall Schrauben dran.
Die hatten das auch ziemlich häufig.
Ja? Naja gut, dann mach ihn auch in D und gut ist.
Also ich finde D okay für D-V-I. D für D-V-I.
Er hat vor allen Dingen auch nicht lange durchgehalten. Also geil war er nicht.
Man muss auch F ist schon Special Place in Hell. Also das ist so...
Gut.
Da muss man schon... Das muss man sich auch verdienen.
Ja, ich hebe die Hände und du hast recht. Special Place in Hell ist jetzt zu heftig für DVI.
So, wer möchte den nächsten Stecker auswählen? Ralf?
Nee. Dann Luca.
Okay, ich nehme HDMI.
HDMI, da bleiben wir beim Thema. Alright. HDMI.
Ich persönlich muss sagen, dass ich HDMI eigentlich sehr geil finde.
Also es ist ein Standard, der einfach funktioniert.
Wenn irgendwo eine HDMI-Stecker ist, wenn irgendwo eine HDMI-Buchse ist,
du steckst ein Kabel rein, das tut einfach.
Jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass es natürlich,
verschiedene Protokollstandards gibt, aber im Großen und Ganzen,
wenn du einen Monitor mit HDMI hast, dann kannst du da auch irgendwas anschließen und.
Dann dann.
Passt das auch irgendwas.
Kommt dann da meistens rein oder raus das stimmt schon aber,
sagen wir mal das problem irgendwie dass der monitor nicht seine refresh rate
die er kann darüber machen kann oder oder er macht es doch und dann sehen die
farben kaputt aus länge der kabel sagen wir mal so.
In konferenzräumen hast du meistens,
Hattest du früher immer ein VGA-Kabel auf dem Tisch, um an den Beamer anzuschließen
und jetzt hast du immer ein HDMI-Kabel auf dem Tisch liegen,
damit du deine Präsentation da irgendwie über den Beamer machen kannst.
Ich würde auch sagen, es ist schon deutlich besser.
Und das funktioniert in der Regel auch. Also ich würde ihn jetzt nicht unter
S oder vielleicht auch nicht unter A tun, aber er ist auf jeden Fall ein ganzes Stück von DVI weg.
Das würde ich auch so sehen. Der Stecker an sich funktioniert ganz gut.
Es gibt irgendwie genau eine Richtung, in die er da reinpasst und das ist auch
einigermaßen gut ersichtlich, in welche Richtung der reinpasst.
Aber er steckt nicht gut fest.
Er steckt so. Aber er muss auch nicht so, also auch wenn du ein bisschen an
dem ruckelst, das macht normalerweise nichts.
Er ist da, finde ich, recht robust dann doch in den Steckverbindungen.
Das mit den ganzen Protokollen, die dann irgendwie immer verwirrender werden,
was dann noch alles, ob dann Netzwerk noch drüber und Strom und so weiter,
hätte sicherlich alles irgendwie ein bisschen weird.
Ja, aber das hat DisplayPort das Problem. Also vor allen Dingen,
was mich an HDMI und DisplayPort nervt, ist, dass die Stecker so ähnlich sind, dass du durch,
einfaches Ranfühlen, ich greife hinter den Monitor und du kannst nicht unterscheiden,
ist das jetzt ein HDMI-Anschluss oder ist das ein DisplayPort-Anschluss?
Ich habe DisplayPort vergessen.
Das dachte ich gerade eben auf dem Klo auch, das DisplayPort hier fehlt.
Was bei HDMI noch dazu kommt, ist HDCP.
dieses eingebaute DRM das ist natürlich etwas.
Was man nicht haben möchte Das ist eher ein Minuspunkt aber sämtliche anderen
nachfolgenden Standards, also DisplayPort hat das Problem doch auch, oder?
Wahrscheinlich, aber wer hat damit angefangen?
Ja, HDMI hat damit angefangen Gut, das gibt natürlich Abzüge in der B-Note Also.
Ich würde ihm, glaube ich, ein B ist schon okay.
Also ist denn, wie verhält sich denn irgendwie DisplayPort zu HDMI,
die sind doch irgendwie auch alle weitgehend kompatibel auf eine bestimmte Art,
aber dann wieder irgendwie nicht?
Nee, das ist was komplett anderes, oder nicht?
Ja, eigentlich schon. Wenn du DisplayPort hast, möchtest du es auch verwenden.
Aber HDMI ist eigentlich der kompatiblere Standard, weil du da irgendwie einfach
alles reinstecken kannst. Das funktioniert meistens.
Ja aber also ich meine Displayport hat schon mehr Bandbreite was bei einer höheren,
Bildwiederholrate oder irgendwie.
Ja wir müssen mal ein bisschen auf die Tube drücken wir sind jetzt schon wie
lange haben wir Sendung hier schon 4 Stunden irgendwas und es sind noch einige Anschlüsse vor uns.
Also A oder B.
B also ich bin jetzt bei B ich.
Meine es ist ein sehr erfolgreiches Ding und es wird auch noch in zehn Jahren
am Beamer hängen. Das ist auch irgendwie klar.
Und auch an jeder Switch.
Und auch an jeder Switch. Auch Switch 2.
Also es hat schon die Qualität von Local Talk, würde ich sagen.
Ja, von mir aus.
Aber es ist kein S.
Nee, kein S.
So.
Next.
So, wo ich auch echt eine totale Hassliebe und mehr Hass als liebe, PCM-CIA.
Ja?
Das ist halt so ein bisschen wie ISA, so die ISA-Karte zum draußen dranstecken.
Es war cool, was man damit machen konnte.
Es war pain in the ass, wie diese Dinger sich anfühlten, drinsteckten, außen rausragten.
also ich hatte lange beispielsweise an einem Laptop von mir eine PCM-CIA-Karte
um die über so ein Funk-Netzwerk irgendwie anzuschließen WLAN gab es das erste
Mal über PCM-CIA-Karten und,
so das war schon das.
Ist ja übrigens das Bild hier eine,
wie hieß die nochmal die Wavelan-Karte von,
3.com.
Also ich sag mal so, ich würde es jetzt C unter Schmerzen, lieber D.
Ich hätte gesagt D.
D, aber ich meine immerhin PCMCIA hat uns irgendwie all diese ganzen Funkstandards
eröffnet und man musste nur katschack rein und fertig.
Man musste nichts konfigurieren, keine Jumper, gar nichts und so.
Ja, aber hast du dich da gut bei gefühlt, wenn du diese Karte da so reingerammt
hast von der Seite und dann steckte da immer, hing da immer sowas raus von deinem Laptop?
Also meine, ich hatte ehrlich gesagt, hatte ich einen Laptop mit PCM-CIA,
hatte irgendeinen Macintosh,
Ein PCM-C-E-Slot?
Also ich hatte zwei oder drei verschiedene.
War da nicht irgendwie so ein PCI oder so dahinter eigentlich?
Oder irgend so was anderes? Keine Ahnung.
Also ich persönlich bin jetzt nicht so überzeugt davon. Aber gut,
es war sehr universell einsetzbar. Da können wir uns drauf einigen.
Das stimmt. Man muss ja nicht keine Jumper setzen. Also ob es jetzt C oder D
ist, da würde ich mich jetzt nicht verkehren.
Trotzdem war das halt so, hängt so draußen dran an einem Laptop.
Ist halt auch nicht geil.
Also, war halt ein Versuch, irgendwie was zu verändern. C oder D?
Das ist mir ein bisschen wurscht.
Das kann nicht so schlecht sein wie DVI oder VGA.
Ich würde schon C, kann man schon mit leben.
Gut.
Tosslink. Mach mal Tosslink.
Tosslink.
Cooler Anschluss. Glasfaser zu einer Zeit, als keiner davon geredet hat.
Das stimmt.
Also in Sachen Coolness-Faktor vielleicht der beste Anschluss hier.
Nee, das nicht.
Von der Art und Weise, wie sich das Ganze anfühlte, fand ich,
war das immer so ein bisschen spooky.
Der war auch super locker immer, dass man sich dachte, das kann doch überhaupt nicht funktionieren.
Aber dadurch, dass es optisch war, muss es halt auch nicht irgendwie jetzt so
super grippig sein. Es muss halt mal so gerade eben reichen.
Finde ich schon immer noch gut. Habe ich sogar noch im Einsatz an einer Stelle.
Also die ersten CD-Player hatten das ja oder ganz frühe CD-Player schon.
Also ich hätte dem jetzt ein A gegeben.
Also mein erstes Tosslink-Kabel hat nur Tage gehalten und das ist irgendwie
am Stecker abgebrochen. Keine Ahnung, was ich da gemacht habe.
Länge auch kein Problem.
Was ja viele Leute nicht wissen, zwei Fakten über Toslink-Verbindung.
Erstens, es gibt ja zwei verschiedene Stecker.
Es gibt diesen Spitzen, der sozusagen mit der Audio-Klinke kompatibel ist,
der von so manchen Tragbahnen verwendet wurde.
und es war dadurch möglich, den Klinkenanschluss an einem Computer so zu bauen,
dass er sowohl diesen Toslink-Stecker als auch den normalen Klinkelstecker annehmen
konnte und das war der Fall beim Macintosh.
Man konnte tatsächlich bei vielen Laptop-Modellen lange, lange Zeit direkt Toslink
und dann Digital-Audio einführen.
Es hat mich immer sehr geärgert, dass Apple das zwar drin hatte und dann leider
die zweite naheliegende Sache nie gemacht hat, was der Brüller gewesen wäre,
weil du kannst über dasselbe Kabel ja nicht nur den normalen 44,1,
48 Kilohertz Singletrack machen, sondern du kannst ja auch ADAT darüber machen
und hast über dasselbe Kabel acht Tracks gleichzeitig übertragen können,
was ja viele professionelle Audiogeräte lange Zeit unterstützt haben.
Das habe ich auch gemacht damit.
Genau, ich hatte auch hier im Studio noch irgendwie so einen ADAT,
wo ich dann irgendwie acht Analogleitungen drüber gestandelt habe.
Aber auch da, optisch galvanische Trennung.
Genau. Also insofern wirklich eigentlich ein geiles Teil und hat sich auch lange,
lange Zeit gehalten, weil den gab es halt auch schon in den 80ern und hat es
wirklich bis vor kurzem noch in die Neuzeit geschafft.
Du musst zugeben, es ist trotzdem sehr Nische.
Ja, gut, Nische, aber sagen wir mal, für das, was es machen sollte,
nämlich Audio übertragen, extrem problemlos, billig,
war durchaus verbreitet, war versatil und hätte Apple mal Ader-Treiber geliefert,
hätten sie da schon sehr früh sehr cool Audio drüber machen können und das haben
sie aber leider irgendwie verkackt.
Vielleicht war die verbaute Elektronik auch nicht schnell genug, das kann durchaus sein.
A oder B?
Ich hätte durchaus nach A getan.
Eindeutig auch sagen.
Ich muss mich übrigens korrigieren, das ist keine Glasfaser,
sondern polymere optische Faser. Polycarbonat.
Ja, das ist ein Plastik. Also du kannst das Ding nicht zwei Kilometer lang machen.
Aber es ging immer lang genug.
Es ging immer lang genug. Ich hatte da auch nie Ärger mit. So. Next.
Wenn wir in der Ecke der esoterischen sind, dann lass uns doch DMX gleich hinterher schreiten.
Ja. DMX. Ich habe ein bisschen gezögert, ob ich das reinnehmen soll.
weil das ja so ein Lichtsteuer Protokoll ist MIDI für Licht, genau,
Hat sich beileibe nicht so durchgesetzt, aber ist auch durchaus ein Dauerbrenner.
Also so DMX ist auch immer noch da.
So wie du MIDI-Stecker findest, findest du auch DMX-Stecker.
Das sind auch so fünftpolige XLR-Stecker, die sich elektrisch irgendwie noch
ein bisschen anders verhalten als...
Als XLR.
Ja, die Kabel, also es ist kein normales Mikrofonkabel. wir haben da irgendwie
andere Dämpfung, Schirmung, irgendwas drin.
Ich habe es nicht so ganz verstanden, aber du kannst bei Thomant DMX-Kabel und Mikrofonkabel kaufen.
Ja, die haben wahrscheinlich einen anderen Wellenwiderstand.
Irgendwas. Ich weiß es nicht ganz genau. Ja, ist eigentlich ein okayes Interface.
Ich muss aber sagen, ich habe relativ wenig Erfahrung damit,
deswegen kann ich da nicht so viel zu sagen.
Für mich ist das irgendwie so, ja, funktioniert gut, kann man machen,
ist irgendwie ein B oder so.
Passt.
Nie Kontakt zu gehabt.
Ja, der Bassist bei mir in der Band, der hat da so ein bisschen Licht.
Der hatte dann irgendwann das Problem, dass er, also der ist ja Professor für
Hochspannungstechnik und macht gerne mal so, er nennt es Spratzlshow.
also da wird dann Lichtbogen erzeugt mit der entsprechenden Hochspannungsanlage
und da hat er dann Licht für aufgebaut
und irgendwie hat die Anlage es geschafft in dem DMX-Kabel so viel,
Spannung zu induzieren, dass es ihm dann den Lichtmischer dann zerlegt hat.
Also aber ich glaube, das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt Schuld von DMX.
So, was nehmen wir uns jetzt?
Kurzer Nachtrag, weil ich das im Chat übersehen hatte. der Apple Newton hatte PCM-Ci.
Stimmt. Also da wäre ich jetzt auch nicht...
Aber der ist auch...
Ja, das war zu der damaligen Zeit ganz geil, aber heutzutage betrachtet ist
es schon auch ein weirdes Teil.
Jeder professionelle Scheinwerfer hat DMX-Anschlüsse, wird hier gerade im Chat behauptet.
Das stimmt schon. Ja, ja, nee, hat sich nicht durchgesetzt. Ja,
doch, hat sich durchgesetzt. Wir haben nur alle keine Anwendung dafür.
Kann man jetzt mal einfach so sagen.
Richtig. Aber deswegen ist es ja auch in B gelandet. Da ist es glaube ich ganz gut aufgehoben.
Hat jetzt nicht so viel Finesse, aber ja.
So, jetzt haben wir noch einen älteren Halbwegsstandard. Den müssen wir noch
abräumen, würde ich sagen.
Ethernet?
Ne, jetzt kommt erstmal SATA.
SATA.
Als Nachfolger von ATA.
Riesenfortschritt gegenüber ATA.
Hat sich, finde ich, extrem gut bewährt. Also ich habe eigentlich mit SATA-Anschlüssen
festplattenmäßig nie wirklich Probleme gehabt.
Korrekter Stecker kann man nicht falsch ranstecken, war auch halbwegs schnell, wurde immer schneller.
Ja und vor allen Dingen SATA, soweit ich weiß, fahren die weitestgehend das SCSI-Protokoll.
Das kann gut sein, das ist immer noch.
Deswegen gibt es da irgendwie so eine ganz komische Kompatibilität zwischen
SATA und SCSI auch heute noch.
Ich habe es nie so richtig verstanden. Ähm...
Ja, die Stecker, die klicken fest und sind also ich, ja, A wäre ich.
Ich hätte bei A auch keine Schmerzen. Sata war immer gut.
Gut. Apple-Doc-Connector.
Nie benutzt.
IPod als das iPhone.
Das Problem war, dass der relativ viel Hebel auf die Innereien des iPods,
gemacht hat und Einer meiner ersten iPods ist auch tatsächlich mehr oder weniger
dadurch kaputt gegangen, dass der Dock-Connector-Stecker irgendwie die Platine kaputt gehebelt hat.
Ich würde den nicht allzu hoch ansetzen.
Ja, ich hatte die relativ lange und ja, sie haben funktioniert,
aber es fühlte sich immer scheiße an.
Also schon beim ersten iPod war das alles irgendwie… C?
Ja, ja. Auch diese Docks, die es da gab, die waren auch alle so,
man hatte so das Gefühl, ja, es funktioniert, aber nicht anfassend.
Jetzt wollte ich dran wackeln. Ja, also bestenfalls C.
SD vielleicht? SD-Karte?
Knifflig.
Also ist SD überhaupt so ein Interface?
Es ist ja im Prinzip auch so was wie SATA in gewisser Hinsicht.
Also das Interface zu diesen Karten ist ja auch so ein Festplatteninterface.
Ja, so gesehen könnte man es mit reinnehmen.
Vermutlich ist es sogar auch SATA, wenn ich äh.
Keine Ahnung, da habe ich mir nicht Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Ja, wie sind denn eure Erfahrungen damit?
Eigentlich ganz positiv, bis auf das Micro SD einfach zu kleines,
ich verliere die Karten ständig.
Also die, keine Ahnung, ob es der Staubsauger-Roboter ist oder was,
also die werden von alleine weniger.
Ja, wenn man die nicht ständig im normalen SD-Kartenadapter aufbewahrt,
dann sind sie einfach weg.
Und dabei sind sie so teuer. Ja, also grundsätzlich finde ich auch geiler Standard.
Was, die sind doch tierisch günstig geworden inzwischen.
Viele, naja, werden sie ja immer größer und dann auch wieder gleich teurer,
wenn sie es auch echt nicht schnell haben willst.
Also beispielsweise, was du jetzt in die Switch 2 nur reinpacken kannst.
das wäre nur der allerneueste irgendwie XT Extreme Standard so.
Normale, schnelle, gute Karte kannst du da nicht reinpacken als Speichererweiterung.
Also eigentlich mag ich das nach wie vor sehr.
Mir ist nie irgendeine kaputte untergekommen. Das war alles immer sehr robust,
was halt Pain in the S ist. Das sind halt diese drei unterschiedlichen Größenformate.
Aber sind das nicht drei?
Zwei.
Ich glaube es sind zwei.
Die SD-Karte und die Micro. mehr gibt es nicht.
Gibt es nicht noch irgendwas dazwischen?
Also ich sage mal so, von allen Kartenstandards, die man je in digitale Kameras
reingesteckt hat, ist SD eigentlich der einzig sinnvolle gewesen, meiner Meinung nach.
Ja.
Also mir sind schon mal SD-Karten kaputt gegangen zu Raspberry Pi 1 Zeiten.
So, ihr habt Unrecht, es gibt eine Mini. Die war allerdings nicht weit verbreitet, aber ein oder zwei.
Komisch, halb groß, ne?
Genau.
Ach echt?
Ja, als du das gesagt hast, habe ich auch kurz überlegt, war da nicht was.
Sie hatte wenig Verbreitung, aber ich habe da noch welche irgendwo rumliegen.
Ja, aber ich glaube, dass die zu Pi-1-Zeiten schnell kaputt gegangen ist,
lag wahrscheinlich weniger an der SD-Karte und mehr daran,
dass wahrscheinlich die frühen Pi-Systeme einfach zu viel Kram gelockt haben
und einfach zu schnell durch den Flash speichert.
Ja, es lag auch vor allem daran, dass wenn du ein scheiß Netzteil benutzt hast,
was ein bisschen zu wenig Spannung reinstellt, dann haben sie irgendwie die SD-Karte geschrottet.
Und oben drüber gab es natürlich noch Kompakt-Flash.
Genau, Kompakt-Flash fand ich ganz furchtbar.
Das war richtig scheiße, genau. Und demgegenüber war halt dann SD auch so ein
Riesenfortschritt, weil man vorher Kompakt-Flash hatte.
Also ich meine, dass der Raspberry Pi die SD-Karten kaputt macht,
kann man glaube ich den SD-Karten nicht unbedingt anrechnen.
weil ich habe relativ viele SD-Karten mit nicht ganz so vielen Digitalkameras
verwendet und hatte nie ein Problem, dass mir da eine kaputt gegangen ist.
Ja, ich würde halt auch sagen, mir ist sonst nie eine kaputt gegangen.
Deshalb sind die wohl eigentlich recht robust.
Also ich hätte sie jetzt irgendwo bei A oder B auch verortet.
Ich würde die bei A.
Ich würde auch sagen, mindestens A. ich meine, man könnte sogar sagen,
ich meine, was ist denn an SD?
Also es steckt überall drin. Es funktioniert.
Selbst der Mac Studio hat einen.
Es gibt zwei Terabyte SD-Mikro-SD-Karten. Zwei Terabyte Mikro-SD-Karten.
Ich habe jetzt leider den Preis mir gerade nicht gemerkt. Aber...
Der dürfte jetzt nicht so ganz so niedrig sein.
Aber es gibt auch noch mehr. es gibt noch weit mehr als 2 Terabyte oder 4 sogar wie weit?
128 Terabyte SDUC das sind die normalen SD-Karten keine MicroSD das glaube ich nicht was?
das sind schon MicroSD das gucke ich jetzt mal nach.
Also SD war halt nie besonders schnell aber es war für das was man damit gemacht
hat immer schnell genug.
Also ich könnte...
Wird halt immer noch schneller, muss man auch sagen.
Also eine 2 Terabyte Sun-Disk kostet hier gerade irgendwie 214 Euro.
Ja.
Also...
Das ist nicht viel Geld.
Eine NVMe in der Größe.
Es gab auch lustige,
Spezialkonstruktionen. Hattet ihr mal so eine mit Wi-Fi dran?
Ich weiß, dass es die gab.
Die dann in der Kamera sich in Netzwerke einloggen konnten für eben Wi-Fi-Transport
von Bilddaten und ähnliches.
Und ich hatte sogar mal eine, wo Wi-Fi und noch eine Geolokalisierung drauf war.
Also das war auch noch eine Geokoordinate mit in deinem Bild hattest.
Also von daher, falls du jetzt gerade nochmal ein Plädoyer für den S-Tier halten
willst, ich wäre dem nicht völlig abgeneigt.
Ja, aber ich meine, eigentlich ist nichts falsch dran, es ist irgendwie kompakt,
es passt extrem viel drauf, die Dinger werden immer besser die ganze Zeit,
meistens funktioniert es, es ist eher eine Frage des Formats.
Ja, stimmt, ein Ende dieses Standards ist momentan nicht abzusehen.
Und es ist super praktisch, man kann da ganz viele dabei haben.
Man kann die immer überall reinstecken. Jedes Gerät nimmt das.
Also ich würde sagen, SD-Karte ist definitiv S-Tier.
Zumindest der Standard als solche. Also jetzt mag jetzt bessere und schlechtere
geben, aber als Interface und Formfaktor auf jeden Fall mal da oben.
Genau, darum geht es ja. So, jetzt haben wir die letzten sechs. Welche als nächste?
Lass uns mal Lightning nehmen?
Lightning.
Auch so ein Standard, der jetzt gerade erst in die Obsoleszenz entlassen wurde.
Zum Glück.
Nein, es ist irre.
Wie mir diese Kabel kaputt gehen.
Ich glaube, du kannst jetzt von Apple keine neuen Lightning-Produkte mehr kaufen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Also zumindest keine, ja doch vielleicht noch das eine oder andere iPad.
Super.
Ja, also nochmal, Tim?
Ja, sag mal, was du von Lightning hältst.
Also Lightning funktioniert. Der Connector ist eigentlich ganz geil an sich. Es ist relativ robust.
Würde ich ja gerne widersprechen.
Wieso?
Also ich habe mindestens 20 kaputte Lightning-Kabel.
Das Problem ist, wenn man sie zum Laden benutzt, dann
ist immer relativ viel spannung auf einem
einzigen pin und ich habe zum beispiel einen stecker den kann ich nur noch in
eine richtung in das ipad stecken in das alte weil auf der anderen seite der
pin auf dem stecker schon so weit weg gebrutzelt wurde dass der einfach keine connection mehr macht,
Also das ist so.
Ja, exakt das.
Also prinzipiell ist Lightning ganz cool. Er ist eigentlich auch ein robuster Stecker.
Aber wie gesagt, wenn man den viel und lange verwendet, dann nutzen sie sich
doch schon sehr stark ab.
Ich bin erstaunt, dass USB-C deutlich besser hält. Weil das hatte ich nicht
erwartet, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich auch nicht. Zumal ja Lightning, ich meine, Leitling hat,
finde ich, zwei interessante Innovationen mit sich gebracht.
Der erste Stecker, den man halt so mal so rum und so rum reinstecken konnte.
Also es war egal, wie rum du ihn reingesteckt hast.
Klar, wenn man von Schuko absieht, aber ja.
Technisch stimmt das bei Schuko auch nicht unbedingt. Das ist nur in Deutschland
so, weil wir diesen mittleren Pin nicht haben, den die Franzosen haben.
Ja, das ist aber nicht Schuko.
Ja, okay, aber das ist Schuko-Genuss.
Wahrscheinlich Konte Schuk oder so.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Idee gewesen in Frankreich und in Deutschland ist es leider...
Der mittlere Pin? Wieso ist der eine gute Idee?
Weil du dann halt klar ist, wie rum es verkabelt ist.
Als wir in Frankreich Installation gemacht haben, mussten wir alle unsere Kabel
markieren, damit wir irgendwie einen Brummen rauskriegen und so.
Ach, du meinst, auf welcher Seite ist...
Neutral und...
Ist neutral und wo ist die Phase?
Genau.
Das ist aber bei Design, dass du das nicht weißt.
War auf jeden Fall ein Problem. Egal. Aber anderes Thema. Lightning hat also
das auf jeden Fall gebracht und auch dieses,
dass du so einen festen metallischen Core hast, dass also dieser Stecker an
sich so eine Stabilität hat und also verbogen kriegst du den nur mit roher Gewalt.
Während so diese ganzen anderen Stecker, die immer die Pins innen haben,
mit ihren dünnen Hüllen und so.
USB-R, ganz schön.
Ja, also die verbiegen leicht und so weiter und Lightning war in sehr viel also
ich lasse mich auf mindestens B.
Weil dafür war er einfach Also er war auf jeden Fall.
Besser als der Dock-Connector. Das ist auf jeden Fall klar.
Und es geht ja nicht nur um den Stecker. Es geht ja auch um das Interface und
Lightning hat halt geladen, Lightning hat relativ hat USB 2.0 Speeds geliefert,
hat Audio auch noch mit drauf gehabt.
Also es ist schon irgendwie ein korrektes Interface.
Also ich würde ihm ein A geben.
Nein, dafür ist er zu schnell kaputt.
Aber wie gesagt, also er ist nicht so robust, wie er verspricht,
robust zu sein, weil wie gesagt, diese Pins das Problem haben,
dass sie sich halt abnommen.
Also auf B lasse ich mich noten.
Ich hatte nie ein kaputtes Lightning-Kabel, also ich weiß gar nicht.
Ich auch nicht. Also packen wir erstmal in B.
Wir machen ja noch die Abschlussrunde. So.
Fünf haben wir noch.
Fireware.
FireWire.
War schon cool, vor allen Dingen zu der Zeit.
Ja, aber natürlich mit den permanent sich ändernden Steckern.
Es gab irgendwie Sony iLink, der vierpolige, dann gab es den,
mit dem sie gestartet sind, mit so einer komischen Form.
Dann gab es schnell FireWire 800. Wieder ein anderer Stecker und mittlerweile
ist es ja in USB-C übergegangen, wie ich das richtig sehe.
FireWire war natürlich schnell, Firewire war auch weitgehend unproblematisch, war daisy-chainable.
Also ich hatte nie Probleme mit Firewire, vor allen Dingen, was bei Firewire
immer großartig war, die niedrige Latenz.
Also zu dem Zeitpunkt, als Firewire rauskam, konnte USB nicht anstinken.
Also das war gut. Inzwischen ist USB so schnell, dass das latenzmäßig sich nicht
mehr so viel nimmt, aber ich habe immer noch ein Audio-Interface mit FireWire,
gut, da habe ich so eine super,
FireWire 400 auf FireWire 800 Adapter und dann FireWire 800 auf Thunderbolt
2 Adapter und dann der Thunderbolt 2 Adapter auf einen USB-C Adapter,
Dank des Adapters Und das funktioniert nach wie vor ohne Probleme.
Also,
Korrekter Hinweis aus dem Chat FireWire konnte DMA.
FireWire lehrte mich, was DMA-Attacken sind.
Genau, das war ja sozusagen die Möglichkeit, über FireWire direkt auf den Speicher
zuzugreifen und das war ein schönes Security-Ding.
Ich meine, das war auch der Grund, warum es so schnell war.
Im Prinzip war es schon so eine Art PCI in gewisser Hinsicht.
B oder A, würde ich sagen.
Also B wäre ich ganz entspannt.
Ich würde ihm sogar ein A geben weil das eigentlich immer super funktioniert
hat, gut das mit den DMA-Attacken, da ist was dran Luca.
A oder B?
Ich habe das ehrlich gesagt nie verwendet Keine Ahnung.
Ich würde es eher,
Firewire war zwar verheißungsvoll, aber es war nie so versatil Es hat sich natürlich
im Audio-Bereich durchgesetzt, bei Festplatten eine Weile.
Video.
Und Video so ein bisschen, aber es hat.
In der PC-Welt hat es nie wirklich Fuß gefasst.
Es war immer ein Fremdkörper. Genau, ich würde sagen B.
Na gut.
So, Thunderbolt.
Bleiben wir doch mal gleich beim Thema.
Thunderbolt.
Thunderbolt ist ja im Prinzip sozusagen das moderne Firewire auf USB-C-Basis.
Deswegen habe ich auch, glaube ich, USB-C nicht reingenommen,
weil, also, sag mal, wir haben jetzt USB und Thunderbolt in dieser Liste.
Und für mich sind das sozusagen die beiden Interfaces.
Also USB-C ist für mich, wir haben da den USB-C-Stecker.
Aber du kannst darüber entweder Thunderbolt machen oder USB 3.0. sozusagen.
Wobei Thunderbolt im Prinzip ja ein PCI ist.
Wobei Thunderbolt ein PCI ist, deswegen ist das alles sehr schwierig.
Also ich würde Thunderbolt relativ weit oben einordnen, wären da nicht zwei Dinge.
Erstens, das Zeug war immer relativ teuer und hat sich eigentlich auch nicht
so richtig durchgesetzt.
Und das zweite war, dass zumindest die Thunderbolt 2 Stecker,
die ja so ähnlich waren wie Mini-Display auch nie so heldenhaft gehalten haben.
Das stimmt und das hat sich jetzt auch gerade komplett verdrängt dass wir natürlich
wie bei Firewire auch bei Thunderbolt,
Prinzip 2 warte mal, gab es nur einen Stecker oder gab es, nee es gab einen
Stecker, genau es gab diesen Mini-DP und danach sind sie auf USB-C gegangen,
Genau Also es ist Letzten Endes war
es genauso wie Firewire aber jetzt mittlerweile ist es halt the shit Ja.
Aber ich glaube, wenn man von Thunderbolt spricht, dann muss man wahrscheinlich
wirklich auch den Thunderbolt der ersten Generation, also diesen,
Mini Displayport Stecker und so weiter ähm,
Ja, deswegen.
So ein A kann man schon machen. Finde ich schon an der Stelle.
Das war halt einfach mal besser als Firewall.
Jetzt Gert Feeling hätte ich nicht. Ja, doch. Ja, meinetwegen A.
Auch weil es jetzt sozusagen eigentlich das geile USB-C ist.
Mhm.
Weil das ist das, was jetzt wirklich den Highspeed macht, mit dem du Bildschirme
anschließen kannst, mit dem du 10 Gigabit Internet machen kannst.
Ich hatte sogar mal eine externe Grafikkarte.
Über Thunderbolt.
Über Thunderbolt, ja eine Grafikkarte, die in so einem extra Gehäuse war,
das fürchterlich laut war und dann über ein gefühlt 15 cm langes Kabel,
das super unzuverlässig war.
Ich sage jetzt, jetzt machen wir mal PCI, weil danach kommt schwierige Entscheidung.
PCI, so, also ich meine, wir hatten Nubus, hatten wir auf C,
PCI, denke ich mal, hat mindestens ein B verdient, weil das hat dann wirklich
dieses, wir erweitern den Computer um allen möglichen Scheiß auf einen anderen Level gehoben.
PCI hat so extrem vieles Zeug überlebt und ist immer noch State of the Art.
Also ich würde PCI sogar bei A reintun.
Mindestens.
Ist es eine S?
Ja.
Würde dem nicht entgegenstehen.
Ich hätte es jetzt eher bei A.
Warum?
Es ist schon immer noch eine Karte und es muss so gesteckt und geschraubt werden.
Das ist also jetzt eher so ein...
Ja gut, aber das sind ja auch Karten, die...
Die willst du ja fest verbauen.
Also sagen wir mal, der Stecker ist noch das Kleinste an der Karte.
Wenn du moderne Grafikkarten anguckst, so die mit den drei Lüftern und mit den
600 Watt Stromanschlüssen, die einem wegbrennen, wenn man nicht aufpasst.
Sagen wir mal so, ich habe vielleicht jetzt auch einfach so ein Bauchstörgefühl,
Isar auf dem letzten Platz und PCI auf dem ersten Platz zu haben.
Ob dann der Range so riesig war.
Doch, Isar.
Jumper hin oder her.
Also Isar war immer ein Pain in the Ass. Das war nie ohne Pain in the Ass.
und eine PCI-Karte, eine PCI-Grafikkarte kannst du heutzutage in den Rechner
starten und dann fährt er hoch.
Gut, da hast du noch keine Treiber installiert, aber er fährt hoch und du siehst
ein Bild und es tut einfach.
Es gibt noch so viele Expansion-Geschichten, die man heutzutage damit machen kann.
Irgendwie extra NVMe oder SATA-Interfaces.
Oder PCIe 16 mit Bifurcation oder so.
Da geht noch richtig was und der neueste Standard hat nochmal aufgebohrt und
hast du nicht gesehen also ich würde sagen ein S wäre schon verdient.
Ja wenn ihr euch da alle einig sind werde ich da jetzt nicht.
Noch sind wir uns nicht alle einig wie bist du denn deine Meinung.
Ich habe es ja gerade gesagt ich fände es bei A legitim Luca A finde.
Ich auch okay.
Tja, dann muss das wohl A sein.
Dann packen wir es erstmal auf A. So, und jetzt kommt die schwierige Frage. USB.
Da müssen wir jetzt das greifen und was ich damit meine, ist halt eigentlich
USB A, also USB 1, 2 und 3. Das meine ich damit.
Also ich meine, man kann viel Schlechtes über USB sagen, aber das U ist auf
jeden Fall gerechtfertigt.
Das stimmt. Das S auch.
Ja, das S. Das S spielt nicht so eine Rolle, aber dieses Universal. Ich meine,
es gibt aus jeder Kategorie Geräte, die du über USB anschließen kannst.
Das ist halt wirklich der Universal-Standard geworden.
Und zu dem Zeitpunkt, als Apple diesen komischen bunten, blauen,
kugligen iMac rausgebracht hat, wo nur noch USB dran war und alle,
um Gottes Willen, was macht ihr denn?
War die Tastatur über USB und die Maus war über USB und wenn ich unbedingt ein
Diskettenlaufwerk haben wollte, habe ich das auch über USB angeschlossen und,
keine Ahnung, also ich finde das, klar,
man kann den Stecker nur in einer Richtung reinstecken und es ist nicht offensichtlich,
welches die richtige ist und das nervt uns alle.
Und man muss es dreimal umdrehen, bis es richtig ist.
Genau, das nervt uns alle.
Endlich mal ein vierdimensionaler Konnektor.
Aber man muss sagen, keiner der anderen Stecker ist so universell wie USB.
Also das muss man einfach mal so sagen.
Selbst PCI kommt nicht dahin.
Das stimmt.
Deswegen würde ich mindestens auf A tun.
Ich meine, an USB-A-Stecker hin, USB-A-Stecker her, der Erfolg von USB und wie
du schon sagst, die Universalität ist halt einfach unbestritten.
Also es ist einfach ein Erfolgsprodukt und das wird noch alle anderen Schnittstellen
lange, lange Zeit über, also bis allein der USB-A-Stecker von dieser Welt verschwindet.
Also es ist ja schon sehr schwierig.
Der Rückzug hat angefangen.
Ja, aber es ist behäbig. Ich suche derzeit die ganze Zeit nach USB-C-Netzteilen mit vielen Ports.
Find mal erstmal einen, wo kein A-Port mehr dran ist.
Also das dauert wirklich noch sehr, sehr lange.
Und ich meine, du kannst auch heute immer noch so 19 Zoll Geräte kaufen,
diese HDMI-Switches, die ich mir hier so eingetreten habe.
Die haben alle noch V24-Schnittstellen.
Und wie lange ist das jetzt her? und bis als USB-A so als Universalstecker weg
ist, das wird noch sehr lange gedauert.
Ich habe einen Kühlschrank, wo ein USB-A-Stecker-Ding dran ist,
damit du da mal eben dein Handy dran laden kannst.
Oh Mann, genau das meine ich halt.
Aber was ja an dem Connector ungeil ist, ist wie, also du musst den nur einmal
schief angucken und dieses blöde Housing da ist verbogen.
Das hatte ich fast nie.
Ich auch nicht.
Ich habe schon mehrere USB-Stecker kaputt gemacht.
Ich merke schon, deinen Blicken muss man ausweichen.
Kein Vergleich zu meinem Lightning-Verschleiß.
Man kriegt die immer noch wieder so hingebogen, weil das so blödes Glech ist.
Ich sage mal, als Schnittstelle hat USB-S verdient.
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Finde ich auch. Also auch wenn ich da jetzt gerade gelästert habe drüber,
aber das ist schon ganz cool.
So, jetzt kommt das Einfachste.
Ethernet. Das willst du natürlich auch auf S haben.
Ich finde, Ethernet ist die Schnittstelle des Jahrhunderts.
Jetzt muss ich kurz fragen. Du redest von dem Ethernet, das man da in dem Bild
sieht, sprich der RJ-Sonst-Was-Stecker.
RJ45.
Nee, ich rede von dem Interface. Und kaum...
Weil das,
Finwire-Ethernet mit den mit den Koaxialsteckern und den T-Stücken und auch
den Terminatoren ist jetzt aber nicht bei S.
Naja, du musst das dann immer im Kontext der Zeit sehen.
Also Ethernet gibt es ja schon seit den 70ern.
So, damit fing es an mit Yellow Cable. Und da war es schon einfach geil,
weil du konntest dieses dicke, fette Kabel durch so ein Büro legen und überall
mit diesen Transzibern anstechen.
Also da hat man ja wirklich das Kabel angestochen und darüber irgendwie einen
Bus gemacht und dann kam da irgendwie 10 Megabit raus.
Aber auch die Kabel hatten Terminatoren, ne?
Ja, okay, gut, aber die Schnittstelle als solche hat überlebt und was sich vor
allem an Ethernet, wir haben uns jetzt sehr viel mit Steckern und Hardware und
so weiter rumgeschlagen, aber eins muss man auch mal sehen,
Ethernet hat sich seit es begonnen hat nicht verändert.
Die MAC-Adresse ist mit 48 Bit durchgestartet, das funktioniert heute noch.
Und also die gesamte Logik dieser Schnittstelle, der gesamte Ansatz zu Networking
ist total, es ist immer noch die allereinfachste Lösung.
Wenn du irgendwie ein Netz haben willst, dann willst du Ethernet haben,
weil das irgendwie softwaretechnisch kein Problem ist.
Überall unterstützt wird und es wird deshalb unterstützt, weil es sich einfach
durchgesetzt hat gegenüber allen anderen Systemen. Tokenring, was gab es nicht alles.
Ja, es gab die verschiedensten Konzepte und lange Zeit war ja nicht klar, was gewinnen würde.
Und irgendwann kam dann halt diese geile Idee, ja, lass uns doch mal hier diese
RJ45-Steckerverkabelung, die halt in Häusern, Büro- und Office-Gebilde war, übernehmen.
Die aber ja kein Bussystem mehr ist quasi.
Nee, aber sogar da hat es halt skaliert.
Also wenn du einen dummen Hub hast, schon, aber ja.
Ja, genau, aber man hat es geschafft, diese Logik des allerersten Kabels bis
heute in alle möglichen Interfaces, ist jetzt auch in Glasfaser und so weiter.
Also Ethernet ist überall und Ethernet ist ja auch über Ethernet hinaus.
Also es ist sozusagen die MAC-Adresse, findest du mittlerweile auch bei Bluetooth und so weiter.
Also alle Ideen in Ethernet haben alle den Test der Zeit bestanden.
Wobei, ich glaube, Token Ring hatte auch MAC-Adressen. Also eine MAC-Adresse
ist schon auch eigentlich...
Ja, aber Ethernet ist ja älter. Also es kommt ja alles von Ethernet.
Als Token Ring?
Ja, ich glaube schon. Also IBM.
Das ist jetzt in eine ähnliche Zeit gepackt.
Ja, das ist sicherlich auch eine ähnliche Zeit.
Aber eine Hardware-Adresse zu haben, macht einfach Sinn. Also ich glaube nicht,
dass es eine Erfindung von Ethernet ist. Aber...
Mac-Adresse.
Weiß ich nicht. Also klar,
einfach, dass die Adresse eines Hardwaregerätes eine andere ist,
als das, was ich als Protokoll obendrauf fahre, ist einfach ein Konzept,
das irgendwie Sinn ergibt.
Es gab ja auch noch andere.
Wo kommt die Mac-Adresse? Sagt mir Wikipedia wieder nicht hier.
Wobei der Name wahrscheinlich von Ethernet Leute.
Es ist halb zwei, ich muss ins Bett.
S-Tier Ich finde nichts ist so sehr S wie Ethernet,
Dieser Schnupsi.
Der immer abbricht, ist.
Halt nicht so schick I-Triple 802 war der Ursprung und abgeleitet davon Ethernet,
Token Ring Wi-Fi und so weiter, okay, meinetwegen Dann,
Aber ich bin trotzdem begeistert von Ethernet Ich finde, Isolid ist einfach
das geilste Interface von allen.
Einfach immer gut, schnell, zuverlässig, robust.
Wenn wir jetzt nochmal aufs Gesamtbild schauen, da gibt es sicher ein etwas
überraschendes Ergebnis, nämlich dass wir 4S-Tier haben.
Das ist sehr viel.
4S ist schon mal 4. Und dann hat man einen quasi fast linearen Abfall von dann 6a, 5b, 5c, 3d, 2f.
Das heißt, wir sind eigentlich recht zufrieden mit unseren Interfaces.
Es war nicht alles schlecht.
Es war ja nicht alles schlecht.
Ja, ich meine, es fehlen jetzt auch noch ein paar.
Nö, aber das kann man da rauslesen. Es war nicht alles schlecht.
Ja, aber so auch im Verhältnis zueinander, ich glaube, mit dem Bild kann man jetzt leben.
Gut, dann machen wir da jetzt einen Screenshot davon und dann ist das sozusagen
hier die Dann ist das Kanon, die Wahrheit Dann ist das einfach mal so,
wie es ist denn die Freakshow hat gesprochen Ah.
Jetzt hast du die Buchstaben abgeschnitten Ja.
Jetzt mach ich einfach so, zack Ja Und es macht auch Spaß mit den Tierlists,
oder? Ich find das ganz gut Das kann.
Man mal einstreuen, aber irgendjemand hat schon den Chat, wie lange haben wir
jetzt, ich glaub zwei Stunden an dem Was?
Guck mal, wie lange deine Aufnahmezeit schon ist. Fünf Stunden haben wir durch.
3.19 und Fünf Stunden durch.
Das hatten wir schon eine Weile nicht mehr.
Ja, hat jetzt ein bisschen länger gedauert.
Das war gut auf jeden Fall. Und wenn man nicht noch sowas langes wie die C oder
so hat, dann kann man das schon mal machen.
Okay, dann würde ich mal sagen, Outro.
Genau.
Ihr könnt uns weiter Vorschläge machen. Es kamen schon ein paar Vorschläge rein.
Ein paar sehr geile waren noch schon dabei.
Ja, dann notiere die nochmal. Ich war noch nicht ganz so begeistert,
weil es muss halt dann auch,
naja, sagen wir mal so, es muss ungefähr schon mal so 10 bis 15 Elemente haben
können, die alle auch mehr oder weniger zur gleichen Domain gehören und die
jetzt nicht nur so meinungsbehaftet sind.
Aber naja, das war jetzt ein erster Versuch, aber war jetzt nicht so schlimm. Oder?
Nö.
Ja, dass wir uns da auskennen, ist optional, oder?
Details.
Okay.
Ja, Luca, vielen Dank für's dabei sein.
Ich danke euch.
Genau. Dann sag ich mal, Wir leiten hier mal das Ende ein.
Also, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Vielen Dank, Chat. Ich hoffe,
ihr hattet Spaß mit dem Zählen. Feedback, Feedback, Feedback bitte zu mir.
Und gucken wir mal. Rangsy hat gehalten. Meine App ist nicht abgestürzt.
Habe ich das geil geweint oder was?
Ja, das ist schön. Ein paar Optimierungen sehe ich da noch, aber cool.
Du hast aber auch gesagt.
Dass die Leute nicht so genau hingucken sollen. Hintesten.
Okay. Tschüss.
Tschüss.